THIS.
MEETING TO ORDER THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION.
FINANCE THIS IS OUR OUR SECOND
HEARING BUT OUR FIRST ONE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION AND WE'RE SUPER
EXCITED A TO HAVE OUR THREE
SEGMENTS --
BEFORE US I THINK I WAS TELLING
ARE PRESENT A FULL TIME TO THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME IN A FEW YEARS
THAT WE'VE HAD ALL. THREE OF YOU
HERE TOGETHER AT THE SAME TIME
SO -- YOU
KNOW HIGHER EDUCATION IS THE TOP
PRIORITY FOR OUR MEMBERS FAR
ECONOMY FOR OUR ECONOMIC FUTURE
SO.
IT CERTAINLY AS A AS A GOOD
DISCUSSION WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DATE SO THERE'S SOME THERE'S
SOME GOOD NEWS AND THE BAD NEWS
IN THE BUDGET --
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THIS IS
THE BEST JANUARY BUDGET FOR
HIGHER ADS IN WELL OVER A DECADE.
THAT IT'S A FRONT LOADED BUDGET
TO ALLOWS --
UC AND CSU AND TO SOME EXTENT --
COMMUNICABLE JUST --
TO TO PLAN FOR FOR THE FEW --
THE BAD NEWS IS IS PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE A MAY SURPRISE AND
HAVING YOU KNOW THREE AND FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR EACH
SEGMENT TO GO.
ON TOP OF THE JANUARY BUDGET --
WE WE DO KNOW THAT THE THAT TAX
RECEIPTS COMING IN ARE NOT
COMING IN AS GREAT AS WE WOULD --
PROJECTED IF IT CONTINUES LIKE
IT IS NOW WE WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE
A DECREASE.
AS FAR AS AVAILABLE MONEY IN THE
IN THE IN THE MAY REVISE WERE
HOPING THAT THINGS WILL TURN
AROUND BETWEEN NOW AND MAY SO AT
LEAST HAVE --
YOU KNOW EQUAL FOOTING WERE AT
JANUARY POTENTIALLY TO MAKE SOME
MORE --
HIGHER EDUCATION INVESTMENTS --
THAT BEING SAID IT'S A GOOD
START FOR FOR OUR BUDGET IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE HAVE --
YOU KNOW ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION ONGOING
EXPENDITURES.
REVENUES FOR THE YEARS
CALIFORNIA FOR THE CA A CERTAIN
AGES THREE PROP NINETY EIGHT
HAVE A SIZEABLE INCREASE AS WELL --
WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE SOME AND AND
IMPORT INVESTMENTS THE JANUARY
BUDGET --
FOR THINGS THAT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LIKE EXPANDING OUR
SECOND TIER OF OUR PROMISE
PROGRAM WHICH AS YOU KNOW THE
ASSEMBLY.
HAS BEEN SUPPORTERS --
SINCE THE BEGINNING --
WE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT OTHER
ISSUES IN THEIR COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE --
YOU KNOW EXPANDING PROGRAMS FOR
IBC PNS PLENTY IN VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS --
ALSO TAKING A LOOK AT FULL TIME
FACULTY ISSUES AS WELL WE LOOK
AT THE PROMISE PROGRAM ONE THING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT ALL.
FULL TIME STUDENTS NOT JUST
FIRST TIME CAN --
CAN ACCESS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AT THE F. AT FREE
TUITION AS FAR AS THE THE UC AND
CSU BUDGET IT PROVIDES BASICALLY
A WORKLOAD BUDGET TO ALLOW THE
UC AND CSU TO TAKE CARE OF THE
BASIC NEEDS. ONE ISSUE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY IS GOING TO BE
MONITORING WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE IS ENROLLMENT GROW.
CLEAN THAT'S ONE ONE SHORT
COMING IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THERE IS NO --
THE MONEY IN THE IN THE UC
BUDGET FOR NEW ENROLLMENT GROWTH
THERE'S SOME MONEY TO PAY FOR
PRIOR ARRANGEMENTS FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH BUT NO AT NEW
ACCESS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT SOMETHING
THAT.
IS CONCERNING TO US AND IT CSU
BUT WE STILL HAVE AS OUR CANCER
WHITE WILL EXPLAIN.
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND CSU
STUDENTS WHO APPLY EVERY YEAR A
QUALIFIED BUT WE HAVE.
TO TURN AWAY BECAUSE OF A LACK
OF ACCESS BUT OVERALL WE THINK
IT'S A VERY.
PROMISING START TO OUR TO OUR
BUDGET YEAR FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND OF COURSE ALWAYS LOOK
FORWARD TO TO WORKING WITH THE
SUIT TO THE SEGMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE INVEST IN OUR
ECONOMIC FUTURE AND OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION --
SO WITH THAT WE WANT TO BRING UP
OUR PANELISTS AND AND BEGIN WITH --
TODAY'S HEARING --
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER --
OPENING REMARKS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
NOTHING NINE LIKE TO BRING UP --
OKAY OKAY EXCUSE ME FIRST WE'RE
GOING TO BRING UP.
THE LA --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO GIVE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET PROPOSALS.
YES AND WHILE WE'RE COMING UP
WE'RE GONNA TAKE REAL QUICKLY
[inaudible]
MCCARTY HERE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
MEDINA.
O'DONNELL HERE QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED.
ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHELLE NEW IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I WILL BEGIN WITH A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND
THEN HIGHLIGHT THE MAJOR
SPENDING PROPOSALS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MY COLLEAGUE JACK'S WORLD.
WILL THEN PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
FOR THE UNIVERSITIES AND STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN ALL
THREE OF THE STATE'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND IN
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS AND TIMELY COMPLETION OF
A DEGREE OR PROGRAM.
AND TO BETTER ENSURE THAT
COLLEGE REMAINS AFFORDABLE.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TOLL FUNDING
OF THIRTY SIX POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
WHICH IS MADE UP OF TWENTY POINT
FIVE BILLION GENERAL FUND AND
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX.
AND FIFTEEN POINT NINE BILLION
IN OTHER FUNDS.
THIS TOTAL REFLECTS BOTH DIRECT
FUNDING AT THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS
AND FUNDING FOR FINANCIAL AID.
THAT STUDENTS MAY RECEIVE AT
ELIGIBLE INSTITUTIONS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
YEAR OVER YEAR INCREASES OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION ON
GOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE UC.
THREE HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CSU.
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION ON
GOING PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR PROGRAM AS
ADMINISTERED BY C. SACK.
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WILL WORK TOGETHER.
ALONG WITH EMPLOYERS OF FACULTY
THE STATE AND STUDENTS IN ORDER
TO ENHANCE THE HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MODEL
TO BEST SERVE STUDENTS AND TO
MEET THE CHANGING AND EVOLVING
WORKFORCE NEEDS OF THE STATE.
WITH THAT I'LL DESCRIBE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
NINE POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING. FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ADULT EDUCATION
AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR AVAILABLE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES AND STUDENT
FEES.
THIS FUNDING SUPPORTS GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT AND
NUMEROUS OTHER PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BILLS ON
AND SUPPORTS INVESTMENTS MADE IN
RECENT BUDGET AX.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT FUNDS AB NINETEEN WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM.
AND ALLOWED COLLEGES TO WAIVE
TUITION FEES FOR FIRST TIME FULL
TIME STUDENTS IN THEIR FIRST
ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISES
A FRAMEWORK THAT --
PRIORITIZES AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESS WHILE ALSO MAXIMIZING
STUDENT SUCCESS AND THE
NAVIGATION OF COLLEGE PATHWAYS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
FORTY MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT A
SECOND YEAR OF FREE TUITION FOR
STUDENTS.
BY EXTENDING THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISED TO FIRST TIME
FULL TIME STUDENTS AND THEIR
SECOND ACADEMIC YEAR.
IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND --
TO EXPAND OUT REACH AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
THE FORMULA ALLOCATES GENERAL
PURPOSE APPORTIONMENT TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BASED ON
ADDITIONAL FACTORS SUCH AS THE
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ENROLLED.
AND SPECIFIED STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS SUCH AS THE COMPLETION
OF A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE.
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA AND
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING SOME
REVISIONS TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN TO ADDRESS --
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE NON LEASE
IN THE DATA BEING REPORTED.
SPECIFICALLY MAINTAINING TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RATES
INTO.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
CAPPING YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH
FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION AT 10%.
THESE REVISIONS ARE INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THE LONG TERM FISCAL
STABILITY OF THE FORMULA AND
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
ENSURE.
THE ACCURACY OF DATA.
SIX THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
APPORTIONMENT INCLUDING.
TWENTY SIX MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND A THREE POINT 46% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
IN ADDITION THEIR COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS OF THREE POINT 46%
FOR VARIOUS OTHER PROGRAMS AND
THESE ADJUSTMENTS TOTAL ABOUT
THIRTY TWO MILLION.
PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES TEN MILLION PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR LEGAL
SERVICES TO UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
AX PROVIDED ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO MAKE THIS
FUNDING ON GOING. FOR STATE
OPERATIONS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A ONE
TIME NON PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. FOR
STAFFING CONTRACT FOR THE
FUNDING FORMULA OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
IN ADDITION THE BUDGET PROVIDES
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING NON
PROP NINETY GENERAL FUND.
AND ONE POSITION FOR AN
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER TO
IMPROVE.
THE DATA AND NETWORK SECURITY
CAPACITY AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
FINALLY FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITIES PROJECTS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE MILLION
IN GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND
FUNDING. FOR TWENTY SEVEN NEW
AND CONTINUING PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE JACK'S WALLED.
AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AFTER PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MICHELLE JOCKS WORLD --
DEPARTMENT FINANCE GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I'LL BEGIN WITH UNIVERSITIES --
THE GOVERNOR'S DOLLARS ON DURING
GENERAL FUND.
US FOR FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY.
THIS INVESTMENT WILL ENSURE THAT
BOTH UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS WILL BE
ABLE TO MEET IMMEDIATE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
INCREASE EFFORTS TO RAISE
GRADUATION RATES IN OVERALL
STUDENT SUCCESS.
MNC INFORMATION PROGRAMS THAT US
SUPPORT ACCESS TO THESE
INSTITUTIONS.
IN LIGHT OF THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN BOTH THE CSU AND
THE UC.
THE ADMINISTRATION EXPECTS
TUITION REMAIN FLAT IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS CONVEYED THAT
THE FUNDING PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET IS CONTINGENT ON TUITION
AND FEES REMAINING FLAT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL BEGIN AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION WITH EACH
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
ON HOW WE CAN COLLABORATE ON
SHORT AND LONG TERM INITIATIVES
TO PROVIDE FISCAL CERTAINLY FOR
STUDENTS IN THE FAMILIES.
INCREASED ACCESS IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS CREATE A MORE EFFECTIVE
AND COST EFFICIENT SYSTEM OF
HIGHER EDUCATION AND PROVE THE
LINK BETWEEN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND THE SKILLS NEEDED FOR THE
ECONOMY NOW AND IN THE FUTURE.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS ISSUE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
FOUR POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THIS
YEAR'S YOU CURRENTLY SERVES
ABOUT FOR UNDER TEN THOUSAND
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS
ADDS TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES AN INCREASE
OF FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE UNIVERSITY. THREE HUNDRED
AND THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH IS ONGOING.
THE POLLS CAN BE BROKEN UP INTO
FOUR PARTS.
THE FIRST COMPONENT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS ONGOING.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE COST OF
INCREASED COMPENSATION FOR CSU
EMPLOYEES.
AND A SUPPORT HEALTH AND
RETIREMENT BENEFITS MAINTENANCE
AND OTHER OPERATIONAL COSTS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF OUR
PROPOSAL RELATES TO ACCESS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
SIXTY TWO MILLION FOR A ROMAN
GROWTH EXPANDING TO SEE ISSUES
CAPACITY BY 2% OR ROUGHLY SEVEN
THOUSAND FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO COMBAT
STUDENT HUNGER HOMELESSNESS TWO
BILLION ONE TIME JOURNAL
FUNTRIVIA POTENTIAL CSU CAMPUS.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
200-525-0000 ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO HELP FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS ACCESS THE
CSU.
THE THIRD COMPONENT OF RCC
PROPOSAL FOCUSES ON STUDENT
SUCCESS.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET CALLED
ON THIS ISSUE TO INCREASE FOR
YOUR GRADUATION RATES AND SHEER
TRANSFER GRADUATION RATES WITH
SPECIFIC EMPHASIS ON CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS ARE UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY GROUPS.
THIS IS THE GRADUATION ISSUE OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ADOPTED BY
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
COMMITS THE UNIVERSITY TO
AMBITIOUS GRADUATION GOALS
INCREASING THE FOR YOUR FRESHMAN
GRADUATION RATES ARE AT LEAST
40% INCREASING THE CHEER
TRANSFER GRADUATION RAPE TO AT
LEAST 45%.
INCLUDING GAPS NOW COMES BETWEEN
THE START AND STERN GROUPS OF
THEIR PEERS.
TODAY THE UNIVERSE THAT THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND I'M
GOING TO THE TO THE GRADUATION
IS ALSO A TOTALLY TOTAL GREAT
GENERAL FUND THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE INCLUDING SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
THE BUDGET PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FIVE WORK.
THE FOURTH AND FINAL PIECE OF A
PROPOSAL ADDRESSES CRITICAL
FACILITIES THE TO THE CSU.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATES
TWO AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE CSU TO
HELP ADDRESS IT'S DEFERRED BACK
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
AND EXPENSE ON CAMPUS CHILD CARE
CENTRES.
MOVING ON TO THE UC.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
THREE POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION OF
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE TEN
UC CAMPUSES ENROLL APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS.
WITH ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED INTO
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS CONNECTED
TO ITS EXTENSION PROGRAMS.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES INCREASE OF
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION IS ON GOING.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ON
A ONE TIME BASIS TO SUPPORT FOR
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS AND FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME TO DEVELOP AND
EXPAND DEGREE COMPLETION
PROGRAMS THAT USE EXTENSION
CENTERS.
THIS INVESTMENT IS MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES LARGER THAN WHAT WAS
PROPOSED IN LAST YEAR'S
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND CONSISTING OF ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR CONTRACTUALLY
OBLIGATED COMPENSATION NON
SALARY PRICE INCREASES.
AND SIMILAR COSTS. FORTY NINE
POINT NINE MILLION FOR DEGREE
CHAMBER AND STERN SERVICES
PROGRAMS FIFTEEN MILLION TO
ADDRESS STUDENT HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS. TEN MILLION TO
SUPPORT.
ENROLLMENT BACK CURRENTLY PAY
FOR WITH ONE TIME FUNDS AND FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO ENDS
THE PRACTICE OF SHIFTING GENERAL
FUND OUT OF UC'S BASE BUDGET AND
BATTLING WITH PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX MONTHS TO SUPPORT GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION.
THIS CHANGE PROVIDES EASY WITH
FORTY MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
UNDER THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
UC'S ESTIMATED FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG AND FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO THE UC. TO EXPAND
AND PILOT DEGREE COMPLETION
PROGRAMS AND EXPAND A
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS AT ITS
EXTENSION CENTERS.
ALTHOUGH THE ALL THESE OUT YOUR
COMMITMENTS DO NOT APPEAR IN THE
BUDGET BILL THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED ONE POINT THREE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES
BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND ONE MILLION ONGOING GENERAL
FUND FOR FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO ENSURE
THESE EXISTING PROGRAMS HAVE
ONGOING SUPPORT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
CONTAINS SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
AID PROPOSALS THAT WILL HELP
STUDENTS PARENTS AND
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTS
THAT APPROXIMATELY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS RECEIVE
NEARLY TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
AID AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM THE
STATE'S LARGEST YOU FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM IS EXPECTED TO SERVE.
FORMER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND PROVIDE MORE IS
MADE.
TYPICALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL
FUND. TO INCREASE OUR PROVIDE
ACCESS AWARD THING TO INCREASE
WILL PROVIDE ACCESS WORDS TO
STUDENT PARENTS.
STUDENTS ATTENDING THE UC SYSTEM
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT DEPENDENT
CHILDREN AND RECEIVE A CAL GRANT
A OR B. AWARD WE'LL GET AN
ANNUAL ACCESS WORK OF UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CAL GRANT SEES STUDENTS WILL SEE
THEIR BOOK AND SUPPLIES GRANT
INCREASE FROM ONE THOUSAND
NINETY FOUR DOLLARS TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF NEW
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARDS BY
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
FROM 250-007-52330.
THOUSAND COMPETITIVE CALENDARS
RECIPIENTS ARE OFTEN
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS WERE
OLDER FROM LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND FACE SERIOUS
BARRIERS TO COMPLETION.
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS WILL IMPROVE
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY FOR
STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL NEED WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT QUALIFY FOR
CAL GRANT AWARD.
WITH THAT --
WILL CLOSE AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND JENNIFER CAN FOR CELLO FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I THINK THE SERGEANTS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED A HAND OUT ENTITLED
OVERVIEW OF HIGHER EDUCATION
PROPOSALS GREAT --
PAGE ONE OF THE HANDOUT JUST
SUMMARIZES ALL THE PROPOSALS YOU
JUST HEARD ABOUT SO THE GOVERNOR
HAS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN
NEW HIRE AND SPENDING.
ABOUT 30% OF IT IS ONE TIME
ABOUT A BILLION OF IT IS ONGOING --
AS YOU PLANTS OVER THE LIST YOU
CAN SEE THAT AMONGST THE ONE
TIME SPENDING IN THE BOOK OF IT
JUST FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
ON ON GOING COMMITMENTS THE
LARGEST COMPONENTS ARE FOR
COMPENSATION AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL INCREASES AS YOU
GLANCED DOWN THE LIST YOU CAN
ALSO SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
TREATING THE SEGMENT SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENTLY IN SOME KEY AREAS
AND ROAMING GROWTH.
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DEALING WITH STUDENT HEALTH
ISSUES JUST FOR EXAMPLE?
SO YOU MIGHT REMEMBER FROM YOUR
BUDGET OVERVIEW HEARING THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION AN ON GOING SPENDING IN
TOTAL SO YOU CAN SEE HERE OF THE
ONE BILLION IN NEW ON GOING
SPENDING.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX MILLION
AS PROP NINETY EIGHT THAT SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION AS
NON PROP NINETY EIGHT SO THAT
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
ONGOING SPENDING.
ABOUT A QUARTER OF IT IS BEING
SPENT ON THE UNIVERSITY SOME
FINANCIAL AID YOUR FIRST ORDER
DECISIONS ARE TO SEE IF YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT LEVEL OF
ONGOING SPENDING AND WITH ABOUT
A FOURTH OF IT.
GOING FOR THESE PURPOSES.
THE SECOND PAGE JUST SUMMARIZES
ALL OF THE CAP OUTLAY HIGHER AT
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
THERE'S THIRTY PROJECTS NEW
PROJECTS TOTALING ONE POINT TWO
BILLION AND BUDGET YOUR STATE
COSTS.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE DIFFERENCES
HERE SO IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES FUNDING PULMONARY PLANS
AND WORKING DRAWINGS FOR TWELVE
NEW PROJECTS TOTALING EIGHTEEN
MILLION.
IN PROP --
ONE IN PROP FIFTY ONE BOND
RELATED COSTS. FOR CSU HE'S
PROPOSING FUNDING ALL OF THE
PHASES OF THE PROJECTS IN ONE
YEAR USING UNIVERSITY BOND
FUNDING FOR THAT. FOR THE UC
PROJECTS IT'S THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE OF MOST OF THESE PROJECTS
ALSO USING UNIVERSITY BOND FUNDS.
SO THE REST OF THE HAND OUT AS
OUR ASSESSMENT AT A HIGH LEVEL
OF THESE PROPOSALS.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING A
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT APPROACH
THAN THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION SO
THIS ADMINISTRATION AS
CONNECTING AUGMENTATIONS TO
SPECIFIC BUDGET PRIORITIES.
WHEN WE TURN TO LOOKING OUT
SPECIFIC BUDGET PROPOSALS THERE
ARE SOME THAT WE THINK ARE REAL
WELL CRAFTED THERE'S DATA THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN PROVIDE
TO DEMONSTRATE THERE'S A PROBLEM
OR AN OPPORTUNITY THERE IS A
CLEAR POLICY OBJECTIVE?
IS CONNECTED WITH A POLICY
SOLUTION THAT'S TIGHTLY ALIGNED
THERE'S AN ACCURATE COST US TO
MEN THERE ARE PROVISIONS FOR
MAKING SURE THERE'S TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ABOUT HOW THE
MONEY IS BEING USED.
AND THEN THERE ARE OTHER
PROPOSALS WERE ONE OR MORE OF SO
THAT'S WHAT THE REST OF THIS
HANDOUT IS ABOUT.
SO COMPENSATION IS ONE AREA
WHERE THE GOVERNOR IS
DESIGNATING SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE
SAYS HERE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES ACROSS THE STATEMENT
SO DEPENDING ON THE STATEMENT
THE SPECIFIC EMPLOYEE GROUPS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS
FUNDING SUFFICIENT COVER BETWEEN
TWO AND A HALF AND THREE AND A
HALF PERCENT SALARY INCREASES.
THE ONE MAJOR EXCEPTION IS FOR
YOU SEE NON REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THEIR CORE FUNDED
STAFF THE BUDGET DOESN'T INCLUDE
AN INCREASE FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES.
YOU SEE HAS REQUESTED 3% THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
THAT MAYBE YOU SEE CAN YOU HAVE
ALTERNATE A FUND SOURCES TO
COVER THAT COST BUT IT'S NOT IN
THE EXPLICIT BUDGET BEFORE YOU.
FOUR IN A ROW FOR A MOMENT
GROWTH YOU'VE ALSO ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT DIFFERENCES THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FINDING ABOUT
HALF A PERCENTAGE POINT GROWTH
AT THE COLLEGE'S 2% GROWTH THAT
CSU AND NOTHING FOR YOU SEE IT
AND NINETEEN TWENTY THERE'S NO
CLEAR GUIDING RATIONALE FOR WHY
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TREATING.
THE SEGMENTS DIFFERENTLY IN THIS
REGARD.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS FUNDING
STUDENT IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVES
OUT ALL THREE SEGMENTS ALSO
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS TAP ON
OUTCOMES BASED FUNDING FOR THE
COLLEGES.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT CAPTAIN
THAT AS A DISINCENTIVE FOR
COLLEGES TO IMPROVE.
ALSO AT THIS POINT IN TIME YOU
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF DETAIL ON
HOW YOU SEE WOULD USE ITS
IMPROVEMENT FUNDING WHETHER IT
WOULD JUST BE FOR UNDERGRADUATES
AND IT WOULD GO FOR IMPROVING
GRADUATION RATES AND NARROWING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
OR WHETHER IT ALSO MIGHT GO TO
GRADUATE STUDENTS FACULTY
RESEARCH OTHER IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVES.
PAGE FOUR OF THE HAND OUT THE
GOVERNOR'S ALSO TAKING NOTABLY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES --
TOWARD DEALING WITH STUDENTS
LIVING COSTS AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES SO AS CSU HE'S FUNDING
THESE INITIATIVES ON A ONE TIME
BASIS.
THE JUST THERE IS THAT CSU WOULD
WORK WITH DS ASKED TO TRY TO
HAVE BETTER COORDINATION AS WELL
AS LOCAL AGENCIES WORKING WITH
CAMPUSES TO HAVE BETTER
COORDINATION.
HE FUNDS THESE EFFORTS ON
ONGOING BASIS AT UC AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR YET WHETHER THAT FUNDING
WOULD GO INTO THEIR REGULAR
FINANCIALLY PROGRAM OR WHETHER
IT WOULD GO FOR TARGETED FOOD
AND HOUSING INITIATIVES.
HE PROVIDES AN ONGOING
AUGMENTATION FOR MENTAL HEALTH
INITIATIVES THAT YOU SEE BUT NO
AUGMENTATION OF THE OTHER TWO
SEGMENTS. FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HE HAS NO SPECIFIC FOOD AND
HOUSING RELATED PROPOSAL BUT HE
IS PROPOSING TO INCREASE THE CAL
GRANT JUST FOR STUDENT PARENTS
TO HELP WITH FOOD LIVING AND
OTHER.
FOOD HOUSING AND OTHER LIVING
COSTS.
THE MAJORITY OF STUDENT PARENTS
DO ATTEND COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS
SO LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE
GOVERNOR LACKS THE VISION FOR
HOW HE WANTS THE STATE TO
ADDRESS STUDENTS LIVING COSTS
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
REGARDING TOP OUTLAY THE
GOVERNOR IS BEING SELECTIVE HE'S
GOING THROUGH PROJECT BY PROJECT
AND FIGURING OUT WHETHER THERE
IS JUSTIFICATION FOR THE PROJECT
YOU CAN SEE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS ONLY APPROVING TWELVE OF THE
THIRTY NINE PROJECTS THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SUBMITTED TO
IT. ELEVEN OF EIGHTEEN PROJECTS
THAT.
ALL OF THE UC PROJECTS --
ARE BEING APPROVED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS POINT
THERE'S ALSO SOME EXPLICIT
CRITERIA THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS USING THAT WE ALSO THINK IT'S
A POSITIVE STARTING POINT.
ALTHOUGH WE THINK THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREATER
TRANSPARENCY FOR MORE
CONSISTENCY --
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
SEGMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
YOU ON WHAT CRITERIA ARE BEING
USED TO EVALUATE THOSE PROPOSALS.
AND YOU FOR THAT THE GOVERNOR
DOESN'T WANT TO RAISE TUITION
AND ALSO WANTS TO ENGAGE WITH
THE UNIVERSITIES HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
PROMOTE TUITION PREDICTABILITY --
BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE A EXPLICIT
PLAN FOR HOW TO DO THAT MOVING
FORWARD.
SO THE LAST TWO PAGES OF MY HAND
OUT FOCUS ON SOME AREAS WHERE
YOU MIGHT CONSIDER BUILDING UPON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
IMPROVING THEM REPLACING THEM
WITH YOUR OWN PRIORITIES.
MAYBE STEPPING BACK TAKING TIME
TO COLLECT MORE INFORMATION
BEFORE YOU PROCEED FORWARD.
WE THINK AGAIN THAT HAS BASIC
APPROACH IS PROMISING THAT YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND ENGAGE WITH HIM
NOW THAT YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES YOU
CAN SEE HOW WELL A LINE THEY ARE
WITH YOUR OWN.
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPENSATION
YOU COULD ENCOURAGE THE SEGMENTS
TO DO AS STAFFING ANALYSIS THAT
WOULD LOOK AT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION DATA AND THEN YOU
COULD USE THE RESULTS AT LEAST
NEXT YEAR TO INFORM THE
DECISIONS YOU MAKE?
MOST OF THE NINETEEN TWENTY
CONTRACTS OF BARGAINING UNIT
CONTRACTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
NEGOTIATED. FOR NINETEEN TWENTY
ENROLLMENT TARGETS WE WOULD
SUGGEST AT A MINIMUM YOU THINK
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES SO DEMOGRAPHIC FACTORS.
THE ALIGNMENT OF THE EXISTING
ENROLLMENT LEVELS WITH THE
MASTER PLAN ELIGIBILITY PULLS
THE NUMBER OF DENIED ALL DOUBLE
STUDENTS THE NUMBER OF RE
DIRECTED STUDENTS.
THE FIRST TWO OF THESE FACTORS
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THERE ISN'T A
NEED FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH ON
THE LATTER TWO FACTORS WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THERE IS SOME.
MERIT TO HAVE IN A ROMAN GROWTH.
IF YOU DO DECIDE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR STUDENT IMPROVEMENT
INITIATIVES WE JUST ENCOURAGE
YOU TO LINK THE FUNDING WITH
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS SO YOU
WOULD BE CLEAR ON WHAT YOU WANT
WITH CONTINUED IMPROVEMENT.
IN GRADUATION RATES NARROWING
ACHIEVING GAPS REDUCTION AND
ACCESS UNITS.
TURNING TO THE LAST PAGE THEN
THE STATE DOES HAVE A LONG
STANDING TRADITION OF COVERING
TUITION FOR FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS AND COVERING BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES FOR A SUBSET OF THE
NEEDIEST FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS.
BUT IT DOES NOT TO DATE HAVE A
LARGE SCALE PROGRAM TO DEAL WITH
LIVING COSTS.
I'M SO BEFORE CREATING A NEW
PROGRAM ESPECIALLY BEFORE
CREATING A PROGRAM THAT MIGHT
JUST OPERATE OUT ONE SEGMENT AS
OPPOSED TO ALL OF THEM.
WE THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
THE STATE COULD LEARN.
SO THE STATE COULD GATHER MORE
AND INCIDENTS AN UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY ACROSS ALL OF THE
SEGMENTS.
GET MORE RELIABLE INFORMATION ON
COST OF ATTENDANCE ESPECIALLY
FOR STUDENT PARENTS.
UNDERSTAND THE INTERACTION OF
STUDENT FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS
WITH PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
UNDERSTAND THE TRADE OFFS
INVOLVED IN PROVIDING MORE
LIVING SUPPORT FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS VERSUS OTHER LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
MEASURE UNMET NEED AND DECIDE
HOW TO PRIORITIZE AVAILABLE
FUNDS SO THERE'S A LOT TO BE
UNPACKED WE THINK IN THIS AREA
IT'S SIMILAR WITH MENTAL HEALTH.
THE STATE COULD LEARN QUITE A
BIT ABOUT WHAT ARE THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ACROSS ALL OF THE
SECTORS OF HIGHER EDUCATION. TO
WHAT EXTENT ARE FOR SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED ON CAMPUS OR OFF
CAMPUS WHAT'S THE BENEFIT OF
THAT MIX WHAT ARE THE EXISTING
RESOURCES INCLUDING STUDENT
FAMILY HEALTH PLANS TO COVER
ASSOCIATED COSTS --
AND WHAT OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
ARE AVAILABLE.
AGAIN WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
CUP OUTLAY STRATEGY IS GENERALLY
PROMISE SCENE --
BUT THERE STILL ARE A FEW
PROPOSALS PROJECTS THAT WE THINK
ARE JUSTIFIED FOR EXAMPLE AS THE
ISSUE THERE IS STILL A PROJECT
THAT WOULD FIND NOT ONLY A
RENOVATION OF THE THEATER BUT A
SIDE BY SIDE THEATER.
THIS JUST RAISE A CERTAIN ISSUES
ABOUT YOUR PRIORITIES WHETHER
YOU WOULD PREFER TO HAVE A
SECOND THEATER ON A CAMPUS OR
USE THAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR OTHER CAPITAL OUTLAY OR
OTHER OPERATIONAL PURPOSES.
AND I'M TUITION PREDICTABILITY
WE THINK THE BEST WAY TO ENSURE
THIS THIS WAS SERVICE AND SO WE
WOULD CONTINUE AS WE SAID
EARLIER HEARINGS TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO BUILD UP YOUR RESERVES
THE EVEN HIGHER LEVELS THAN
PROPOSED UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. ONE WAY TO DO THIS WOULD
BE TO SHARE SOME OF THE COSTS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THESE COST
INCREASES YOU'VE JUST HEARD
ABOUT WITH NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS SO.
FOR FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
WILL NOT PAY THE COST INCREASES
REGARDLESS.
THE NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS RIGHT NOW IS YES YOU
ARE PAYING ABOUT 23% OF THEIR
COSTS THEIR EDUCATION COSTS
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT
GOES DOWN 221%.
AT UC SINCE OUR PAINT NON NEEDY
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS ARE
PAYING 13% AND THAT WILL GO DOWN
212% IS LOWER AT YOU SEE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE FAR GREATER RESOURCES
FROM NON RESIDENT STUDENTS THAT
ARE EFFECTIVELY CROSS
SUBSIDIZING RESIDENT STUDENTS.
BUT ONE WAY TO THINK ABOUT THAN
GETTING RESERVE TO THE STUDENTS
DIRECT MORE INTO YOUR RESERVES
YOU CAN ALSO HAVE A SHARE OF
COSTS POLICY MOVING FORWARD.
WHEREAS RESERVES ARE THE BEST
WAY TO PROMOTE TUITION
PREDICTABILITY HUMMING A SURE OF
COST IS THE BEST WAY TO SEND
SIGNALS TO NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
EXPECTATIONS.
SO WHETHER THESE NON FINANCIALLY
NEEDY STUDENTS THEIR FAMILIES
THEY ENTER COLLEGE DURING A
RECESSION OR RECOVERY THEY WOULD
KNOW YOUR EXPECTATION AS TO WHAT
SHARE OF THE EDUCATION COSTS
THEY SHOULD COVER IS IT A
QUARTER.
IS IT HALF WHATEVER YOU MIGHT
CHOOSE IT TO BE.
SO I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL OF A FEW
BUTTONS FIRST OPEN UP TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO YOU MENTIONED --
THE PRIORITIES OF THE
LEGISLATURE. ONE BEING
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND SO ONE OF THAT THE NUANCES
OF THIS BUDGET AS I SAID THE
OPENING.
THE GOVERNOR HAS AT THE MAZING
BUDGET HE SPENT FIFTEEN MINUTES
TALKING ABOUT USUALLY WE'RE HERE
FOR LIKE NINETY SECONDS TALKING
ABOUT GOVERNOR BROWN'S JANUARY
BUDGET.
SO WE HAD FOUR MONTHS TO FOCUS
ON OUR PRIORITIES.
AND SO GET OUT PARK OUT FOR A
SECOND THEN THE FACT THAT THE
REVENUES COMING IN RIGHT NOW.
MAY NOT LOOK LIKE THAT MAY
REVISED WE'VE HAD THE LAST FIVE
YEARS WE'VE HAD.
OPPORTUNITY IN MAY TO DO
SIGNIFICANT GOVERNOR INITIATIVES
IN LET'S SAY MISTER DEEDS ON
THESE POLICY AREAS SO.
IF IF THERE WAS A DESIRE FOR
EXAMPLE TO PUSH FORWARD ON
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FOR YOU SEE
CSU.
AND THERE'S NOT ADDITIONAL
REVENUES ARE ARE THERE.
ARE THERE --
PROGRAMS ARE ARE --
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET WHICH YOU THINK.
DON'T -- IT
HAVE THE EVIDENCE TO BACK UP --
AND THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER BUT
THAT'S LOOKING AT THOSE IF WE
WANT TO FOCUS ON OTHER
PRIORITIES.
LIKE ENROLLMENT GROWTH YES THERE --
THEY'RE TOUGH DECISIONS AND OUT
FOR YOU TO MAKE SO WE HAVE FOUND
SOME PROPOSALS THAT WE THINK YOU
MIGHT WANT TO REVISIT.
BUT THEY'RE GONNA SOUND LIKE
VERY DIFFICULT TRADE OFFS FOR
YOU -- SO
FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDING A NEW CAL
GRANT JUST FOR STUDENT PARENTS.
WE THINK IS ADDING EVEN MORE
COMPLEX STEM NOW WE HAVE AGAIN
SPECIAL CAL GRANT ACCESS AWARDS
JUST FOR THIS ONE SUBGROUP
THAT'S A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION A HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS --
THERE YOU SEE MENTAL HEALTH
ONGOING RESOURCES --
YOU MIGHT ALSO JUST STOP NOT
NECESSARILY NOT DO SOMETHING FOR
THE FUTURE BUT FIGURE SOME
THINGS OUT BEFORE YOU WOULD
SPEND THAT MONEY THIS YEAR --
I THINK ALL TOTAL ACROSS OUR NON
NINETY EIGHT EDUCATION BUDGET SO
EVEN INCLUDING SOME THINGS WE
SAY ON THE EARLY ADD SIDE WE DO
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SOME MILLION DOLLARS
YOU COULD CONSIDER REPURPOSE
SCENE FOR ONGOING SPENDING.
THERE'S ALSO SOME THINGS ON THE
ONE TIME AFFRONT TO WHERE WE
THINK YOU MIGHT CONSIDER
REPURPOSE IN THOSE --
BUT YOU TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT YESTERDAY LIKE THIS
KINDERGARTEN FACILITY GRANT'S
INTEREST AND STILL DOING
SOMETHING BUT IT IS A LARGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
YOU COULD USE IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS. TO BUILD YOUR BUDGET
PACKAGE.
SO. ONE ISSUE THAT WAS SOMEONE
REYES AND BELIEVE BY YOU IS IN
THE UC ALLOCATION FOR THE TWO
FORTY THERE IS THE FIFTY MILLION.
FOR GRADUATION [inaudible]
INITIATIVE AND WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT GRAD INITIATIVES BUT IT
HASN'T REALLY BEEN UC.
IT'S BEEN THE CSU CONVERSATION.
SO IS THAT.
YEAH I'M SORRY THAT THAT'S
ANOTHER GREAT POINT THAT WE GO
OVER IN MORE DETAIL IN OUR
REPORT YEAH OUT OF LEAD THE KEY
ISSUES WITH YOU SEE HAVE TENDED
TO BE COST RELATED --
AS OPPOSED TO LIKE SAME KINDS OF
ISSUES WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND CSU TRYING TO
IMPROVE DEGREE COMPLETION YOU
SEE ON A LONG STANDING BASIS HAS
HAD THE HIGHEST GRADUATIONRATES
AMONG THE STATE MONTHS.
THEIR SIX YEAR RATE ISN'T LIKE
THE HIGH EIGHTIES SO MOST
STUDENTS WHO GO TO UC COMPLETE --
SO IF YOU WANTED TO AGAIN YOU
MIGHT THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
BETTER SERVED BY HAVING
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS THAT IS
ONGOING MONEY IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR ANOTHER LARGER
ONGOING COOL CORD OUT YOU SEE OR
ANY OTHER HIGHER ADD OR NON
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET PRIORITY
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY I THINK AND THEN LASTLY YOU
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE TUITION
POLICY.
I KNOW IN YEARS PAST THERE'S
BEEN IN.
CONTACT WHAT HAVE YOU BETWEEN.
GOVERNOR'S AND THAT YOU SEE IN
CSU SEGMENTS AND THAT A PIECE OF
THAT IS A TUITION POLICY AND
WHEN YOU'RE PROPOSALS HERE IS IS
LOOKING AT THEM.
THE NON NEEDY STUDENTS AND THEIR
I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THERE IS THAT THE YOU WOULD HAVE
IT.
FOR PEOPLE AT THE EXTREME AS FAR
AS INCOME AND THEY HAVE.
IT WILL BE AT THE AT KIND OF A
NO I'M SORRY I MIGHT HAVE JUST
GONE TOO QUICKLY BECAUSE THE CAL
GRANT COVERS THE TUITION LEVEL
WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU SEE ARE
CSU AND THE BOND DOES THE SAME
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SO WHATEVER THE TUITION LEVEL IS
THE STATE CALIFORNIA COVERS AT
FOR FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS
IN EASTERN FILLS UP A FAST AND
HAS.
A MINIMUM LEVEL OF NEED THE
STATE COVERS ARE TUITION COSTS
SO THE ONLY STUDENTS EFFECTIVELY
PAYING THE TUITION CHARGE AT THE
SEGMENTS ARE NON NEEDY STUDENTS
AND WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE LIKE.
TWO THIRDS OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
UNITS ARE WAIVED SO THERE'S A
CHUNK OF STUDENTS STILL BUT A
RELATIVELY SMALL STUDENT SHARE
STUDENTS ARE PAYING THE FEE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE ARE YOUR ARM.
MORE MIDDLE INCOME FOLKS AND SO
I I APPRECIATE IT IS A COST ON
THESE MIDDLE INCOME AND UPPER
INCOME FAMILIES BUT IF YOU GET
TO HAVE A LARGER RESERVE OR MORE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
THESE ARE KEY TRADE OFFS FOR YOU
TO CONSIDER --
THE CULTURE OF COSTS THAT NON
NEEDY STUDENTS RIGHT NOW THOSE
WHO ARE PAYING THE CHARGE THE
SHARE OF THEIR EDUCATION COST IS
IS STILL HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED
STRIKE POLICY CALIFORNIA IS
PAYING.
A 77% OF THE COST OF EDUCATION
FOR THESE NON FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS AT CSU ALMOST 90% AT UC --
COMBINED WITH ACTUALLY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND NON RESIDENTS
FOR YOU SEE SO WE WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TRADE OFFS FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER.
IT WOULD IT BE SUCH A TO AT THE
SHARE THEIR PAIN TODAY AT 23% OF
THOUGHTS TO SHARE YOU THINK AS
REASONABLE AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
FEES FLAK FOR SEVEN EIGHT NINE
YEARS AND HAVING THEIR SHARE
JUST IMPLICITLY GO DOWN.
YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I BUT
I GUESS I'M I'M INTRIGUED BY
THIS BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S ONE
THING THAT'S LACKING IS WE DON'T
HAVE.
RESOURCES FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH
AND I KNOW THAT THE YOU SEE --
AND SEE THIS YEAR AND TALK ABOUT
THIS A LITTLE BIT.
SO THE CURRENT TUITION FOR
EXAMPLE FOR UC'S ROUGHLY TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO IF YOUR HEY UPPER INCOME YOU
SEE FAMILY AND THOSE FAMILIES
ARE PROBABLY SAY HEY WE PAY A
LOT IN OUR TAXES AND SO FORTH
THAT'S THAT'S OUR SHARE BUT
PARKING THAT FOR A SECOND.
WOULD YOU HAVE IN THAT IT AT
TUITION BASED UPON.
AN INCOME.
SO IF YOU MAKE FAMILY OVER TO
ONE FIFTY GRAND YOU PAY X.
TUITION AND THEN.
RATCHET DOWN OR UP HOW
LOGISTICALLY WOULD YOU DO THAT
I'M SORRY WE IMAGINED IT WOULD
BE VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD SO IF
YOU DECIDED TO APPROVE CERTAIN
THINGS AND UC'S BUDGET SAY YOU
DECIDED TO INCREASE AT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT TURNED OUT TO BE A 3%
INCREASE TO THEIR CORE BUDGET
YOU WOULD JUST SHARE IT BETWEEN
THE STATE AND NON NEEDY STUDENTS
SO EVERYBODY SHARE WOULD GO AT
3%.
YEAH BUT BUT HOW WILL THAT
MANIFEST TO THAT FAMILY PAYING
THEIR TUITION BILL.
IT WOULD GO UP 3%. FOR ALL
STUDENTS WHO CURRENTLY PAY THE
FEE THEY WOULD PAY 3% MORE NEXT
YEAR NOT BASED UPON WHERE YOU'RE
AT IN THE INCOME SKIN NOW WE
WEREN'T IMAGINING ANYTHING THAT
COMPLEX.
THIS IS A CLEAR FILE IS BUT THAT
WOULD MEAN A TUITION INCREASE
RIGHT EXACTLY YES BAXTER KEY
FACTOR THAT YOUR KEY TRADE OFF.
WHETHER YOU WANT TO ASSESS NON
NEEDY FINANCIALLY STE NEEDY
STUDENTS A TUITION INCREASE
SOMEWHERE ON THE MAGNITUDE OF
INFLATION OR WHATEVER ELSE YOU
DECIDE --
AND AGAIN IT TO DO THAT
EFFECTIVELY MEANS JUST WHATEVER
NON NEEDY FINANCIALLY NEEDY
STUDENTS WERE PAIN AS A SHARE OF
COSTS IS JUST REMAINING STUDY
OVER TIME ON ON YOU ARE TREATING
THEM SIMILARLY IT TO LAST YEAR
IT'S JUST COSTS HAVE GONE UP AND
SO EVERYBODY'S PAYING A LITTLE.
BIT MORE TO COVER THOSE COSTS.
OKAY YET I THINK YOU SAID THE
KEY WORD IT'S A TRADE OFF YOU
KNOW WE COULD HAVE THESE NON
TUITION POLICIES BUT THE SAME
TIME WE CAN ADOPT BUDGETS.
LIKE WILL HAPPEN HERE IN JANUARY.
WHICH DOESN'T HAVE --
ANY MONEY FOR ENROLLING NEW UC
STUDENTS.
AND YOU KNOW MINIMAL ENROLLMENT
GROWTH STILL TURNING AWAY.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF ELIGIBLE SI
IS USED TO THAT SO THAT'S JUST
THE CHOICE WE NEED TO MAKE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MISTER MARTZ.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IDEA --
APOLOGIZE FOR A COMING IN LATE
AYE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU TRUSTED
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR.
BUT A QUESTION FOR A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE --
A WIDE WIDE THE YOU KNOW THE
THIS IS MY FIRST A NON AND BROWN
ADMINISTRATION --
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL AND AND
I'M I'M I'M USED TO SEEING A A
BUDGET PROPOSAL WITH A VERY
LITTLE DIRECTION ON HOW TO SPEND
NEW FUNDS --
WERE AS IN IN THIS BUDGET IS
SEEMS TO BE PRETTY PURSE.
FOR PRESCRIPTIVE --
I WANTED TO ASK WHY THE GOVERNOR
IS NOT PROPOSING SPECIFIC NEW
FUNDING --
FOR NEW CALIFORNIAN ROMAN FOR
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
WELL.
THE SEGMENT SUBMITTED THEIR OWN
BUDGET PLANS A REQUEST TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THE
ADMINISTRATION REVIEW THOSE.
REQUESTS AND ON THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA --
THE MINISTRATION MADE CERTAIN
CHOICES AND DECISIONS ON WHAT
WAS THE MOST CRITICAL ASPECT OF
THAT REQUEST.
COR OPERATIONAL COSTS MAKING
SURE THAT THE QUALITY THAT THAT
EDUCATION AND DEGREES YOU KNOW
THAT THE PIECE IS COMPLETE.
MAKING SURE THE STUDENTS ARE FED
AND HOUSED --
THERE'S ALSO THE THE MATTER THAT
THE USE COMPARED TO THE THIS IS
TO THERE'S A MULTIPLE FUNDING
STREAMS OF THAT THE YOU SEE THAT.
THE ISSUES YOU JUST DOESN'T HAVE
SO WHILE THERE.
WELL IT WASN'T PROPOSED IT WAS
DUE -- TO A
FOCUS ON THE MOST CRITICAL
CONCERNS HOWEVER AS YOU FOR THE
PROCESS WERE OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WITHIN THE
ARGUS DEBT ARCHITECTURE OF THIS
YOU SEE PACKAGE.
SO DID THE UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA
REQUESTS --
ADDITIONAL ON A FUNDING.
FOR NEW CALIFORNIA ROME THEY DID.
OKAY [inaudible]
AND SO.
I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS THE
THE GOVERNOR'S --
ASSESSMENT OF THE MOST CRITICAL
NEED SPREAD.
TO IF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REQUESTED --
I I I I BELIEVE THIS --
A COMMITTEE HAS.
CONSISTENTLY MADE TO ACCESS TO
ALL OF THE SEGMENTS IS BUT
INCLUDING THE UNIVERSE A
CALIFORNIA'S BEING A TOP.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I LOOK FOR TO
HAVE IN THAT CONVERSATION --
THANK YOU YEAH NO I THINK THAT
YOU'RE RIGHT ON AND THAT'S ONE
GLARING WEAKNESS AND YOU'RE
SAYING THE UC.
YOUR FIRST STATEMENT WAS THAT
THEY DIDN'T THEY MAY THE
PROPOSAL AND THAT WASN'T IN THE
PROPOSAL BUT WHAT DID WAS.
YOU JUST CHOSE NOT TO FUNDED.
FINANCE CORRECT NO MISTER
MCCARTY AT NO POINT DID I SAY
THAT THE UC HAD REQUESTED YOU
AND ROMAN FUNDING WE REVIEW THE
PROPOSAL IN SELECTED THE MOST
CRITICAL PIECES OF THAT REQUEST
FOR YOU YOU RANK THEM AND YOU'RE
ON YOUR OWN YOU DIDN'T HAVE THEM
WRITE THEM HE WENT.
DOWN ONE THREE SEVEN TWO YES IS
THIS NINE THIS IS THE RESULT OF
OUR REVIEW.
THAT'S YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
MR O'DONNELL.
YEAH I I'VE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE IS GOING TO BE AN INCREASE
FOR OR FOR UNDERGRAD ENROLLMENT
AND I I GOT A MAGIC IF WE'RE
GONNA HEAR THAT IT'S GOING TO
COME FROM.
THE PRESIDENT HERE A FEW MINUTES
AN INCREASE ENROLLMENT.
MONEY FOR AND MAYBE WERE AHEAD
OURSELVES.
I DON'T KNOW BUT THE UC
SITUATION IS A LITTLE
COMPLICATED BECAUSE THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET SITUATION WAS
JUST COMPLICATED SO.
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING IS TO FIND SOME OF THE
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL
ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ENROLLMENT GROWTH I DON'T KNOW?
YES EMILY EXACTLY I GUESS THIS
ADMIN CLARIFY THAT IS THAT YOU
SEE WHEN WE DO THEIR ENROLLMENT.
BECAUSE HOW THEIR APPLICATIONS
COMMAND IT'S HARD TO DO IT RIGHT
AWAY AFTER DOT THE BUDGET THE IF
YOU DO.
BUDGET YEAR.
PLUS ONE SO WE'RE FUNDING IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THE DEAL FROM
LAST YEAR MAYBE MAYBE I CAN
SALAS WATER WE I ALL OF BRING
THAT QUESTION OF WHEN THE
PRESIDENT COMES OF MAKES HER
PRESENTATION.
BECAUSE MAYBE SHE WILL MAKE THAT
ASK I DON'T KNOW MY UNDERSTAND
IS THEY'RE ASKING FOR MORE MONEY.
FOR MORE MOMENT AND WE'LL GET
THAT CLARIFIED BUT THAT --
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TO
COVER A THOUSAND STUDENTS FROM
LAST YEAR'S INCREASE WHICH I
THINK WAS A A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES BEES PROPOSING I
ASSUME THE BUILDING INTO THE
BUDGET. TEN MILLION DOLLARS IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY OKAY JUST A
COUPLE QUESTIONS HERE WITH
REGARD -- TO
FIRST OVER TALK ABOUT A TUITION
INCREASE --
THAT'S CAN BE A MUCH LARGER
CONVERSATION THAT CONCERNS ME
GREATLY --
AGAIN ANYTHING THAT WOULD
BIFURCATED TO WOULD BE VERY
CONCERNING TO ME BECAUSE I'M
HEARING FROM A LOT OF MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES.
THAT ARE FEELING PRESSURE AS
WELL AND I THINK THERE WOULD BE
A LOT OF PUSH BACK ON A TUITION
INCREASE YOUR FOR THEM.
AND AT SOME POINT THIS COM THIS
THIS THIS COMMITTEE WELL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP AND ABOUT HOW
THAT FUNCTIONS.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE AVERAGES ON
THAT BUT I ALSO ON ON THE NEED
SEE THE MODE AND HOW MUCH EACH
STUDENT IS GETTING.
UNDER THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP AGAIN I DON'T WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW MY QUESTION THOUGH IS
FOR THE THERE'S EVER TO MONEY --
FOR YEAH I THINK YOU'RE SEEKING
TO UNDER FIFTY TWO AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
INCREASED.
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS TIMELY COMPLETION OF A
DEGREE IN INCREASED AGREES.
OF STUDENTS FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS --
THIS IS YOU SEE IT'S OUR OB
ISN'T THE AVERAGE --
IF I RECALL CORRECTLY IF TOM HAD
THE AVERAGE TIME IT TAKES A UC
STUDENT.
IS FOUR POINT TWO YEARS TO
GRADUATE.
DOES ANYBODY KNOW.
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE LONGER
THAN THAT BUT IS IT IT MAY BE
FOUND THAT SEE ISSUE WITH A SIX
POINT TWO WOULD.
YOU SEE WAS SICK.
I HAVE A LOT OF EXPERTS OUT
THERE ARE LOOKING EACH OTHER BUT
ANYWAYS --
I'LL BE THE EXPERT ALSO IT'S
FOUR POINT.
TWO OKAY BUT EITHER WAY --
I JUST SO I WONDER WHY THEY
WOULD NEED THAT MONEY GIVEN THAT
THAT'S A PRETTY IF IF IN FACT
THAT NUMBER THAT I'VE SPEWED OUT.
AND DIDN'T MAKE UP I BELIEVE --
IS TRUE I WOULD JUST WONDER WHY
THEY WOULD NEED THAT MUCH THANK
YOU SEE WILL COVER THIS AND MUCH
MORE IN DEPTH BUT THEY DO HAVE
DIFFERENCES IN GRADUATION RATES
ACROSS CAMPUSES AND ACROSS
ETHNIC GROUPS SO IF THEY WERE TO
USE IT ON UNDERGRADUATES THE KEY
ISSUE BEFORE YOU.
AS IN THE WHOLE SCHEME OF YOUR
BUDGET HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU
ABOUT THOSE DIFFERENCES FORCES
OTHER ENROLLMENT GROWTH OR ANY
OTHER PRIORITIES YOU MIGHT
HEALTH.
CARE AND I WAS LOOK FOR SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THOSE
DIFFERENCES SO THEY CAN BE MORE
CONSPICUOUS WITH THAT BACK YOU
MISTER YEAH AND I THINK YOU
RAISE A GREAT POINT MR O'DONNELL
IS THAT IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRYING TO REALLY.
EXPAND ENROLLMENT.
AND BIRD DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN A
TUITION WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE
MONEY AWAY FROM.
OTHER PROGRAMS THE STATE BUDGET.
THIS IS SO MAKES SENSE TO HELP
STUDENTS AT UC ALREADY GRADUATE
AVERAGING FOUR POINT THREE YEARS.
THE COULD USE SOME OF THAT TO
EXPAND A ROMAN GROWTH AND THEN
TAKE A LOOK AT A MORE NUANCED A
GREAT POINT BUT JUST ONE COMMENT
ON THAT.
I THINK OUR MISSION SHOULDN'T BE.
JUST TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT.
MISSION SHOULD BE TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED.
BEFORE WE EXPAND IN ROME.
OKAY SO WITH THAT LET'S BRING UP
OUR OF MISTER GALLAGHER.
SO ONE I I DO SHARE SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS IS THE REGARDING
THE TUITION INCREASE --
BUT ALSO WITH THE FIFTEEN
MILLION --
FOR IN THE GRADUATION RATES YOU
KNOW I I WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
LIKE WILL.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO WITH THAT
MONEY AND WHAT YOUR PLAN WHAT'S
YOUR PLAN WITH THAT MONEY IN AT
LEAST FROM THE YOU SEE THAT'S
ONE THING I'LL BE LOOKING TO
HEAR?
FROM AND REALLY WHEN WE'RE SEEN.
SOME I THINK SOME GOOD PERFORMER
WITH THE MONEY THEIR USE IN.
TO YOUR BETTER GRADUATION RATES --
AND YEAH I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS ARE YOU SEE
IN.
WE ALSO AND ON THE ENROLLMENT
FRONT WE STILL DON'T KNOW.
AS FAR AS I KNOW WHAT THEIR
CAPACITY IS BECAUSE THAT
INFORMATION AS A MAN CHAIR BUT
THIS AS FAR AS I KNOW --
BUT ONE THING I WANTED TO KEY IN
ON FROM THE LA --
IS ANOTHER WAY OF LOOKING OF
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH ISSUE IS TO
ACTUALLY LOOK TO NEXT YEAR AND
SET A CAP ON ON THAT FUNDING.
RATHER THAN PAYING AT THE NEXT
YEAR LET'S LOOK INTO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR AND SAY HEY HERE'S
YOUR NUMBER.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO STAY WITHIN
THAT NUMBER.
RIGHT I MEAN AND AND TO ME THAT
SEEMS LIKE.
A POTENTIAL WAY TO REALLY STAY
ON TRACK AND STAY ON TRACK
FINANCIALLY --
FUNDING WISE RATHER THAN TO SIT
WITH THEM TO JUST KIND OF GOING
TO THE NEXT YEAR BLINDLY AND
THEN JUST.
AS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE GUESTS DO
NOW.
PAY WHATEVER IT WAS --
YOU KNOW TO ME CAN YOU MAYBE
SPEAK TO THAT A LITTLE BIT SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE MAKING THAT
RECOMMENDATION AS AS MAY BE
SOMETHING WE COULD DO.
SOMETHING THE LEGISLATURE HAS
STARTED DOING SO IT AS IF I
RECALL THE EXACT YEARS CORRECTLY
WAS FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
FOR YOU SEE THEY DID SET A
BUDGET YOU'RE PLUS ONE
ENROLLMENT TARGET.
SO YOU SEE AS OF RIGHT NOW HAS
MADE A LOT OF VIRTUALLY MOST OF
ITS DECISIONS FOR THE NINETEEN
TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR.
SO SOME OF WHAT YOU DO RIGHT NOW
FOR YOU SEE WILL HAVE LITTLE
IMPACT ON THE COMING SCHOOL YEAR
SO WHAT THE STATE HAD STARTED
DOING WAS TO SAY WELL NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THEM A TARGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO.
AS THEY GO THROUGH THEIR
NOVEMBER A LOT OF OFFERS YOU CAN
INFLUENCE WHAT THEY DO THEY CAN
KNOW WHAT YOUR EXPECTATION AS WE
STILL ENCOURAGE YOU TO MAKE THAT
A PRACTICE FOR UC AS SEEMS TO BE
A WAY FOR YOU TO BE MUCH MORE
INFLUENTIAL.
IN WHAT YOU WANT THEIR
ENROLLMENT LEVELS TO BE.
ON THE STATE HAS HAD SORT OF
MIXED SUCCESS DOING IT WITH THE
ISSUE BECAUSE THE ISSUE AS A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
CHANGE AT SPRING IN ROME AT
LEVELS SUCH THAT CITING AN OUT
YOUR TARGET DOESN'T SEEM QUITE
AS ESSENTIAL FOR THEM --
BUT IT IS AN OLD IT IS A WAY TO
GIVE BOTH YOU AND TO THE
SEGMENTS A LITTLE BIT MORE
PREDICTABILITY ON YOUR
EXPECTATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER IT'S
IT'S FIFTY MILLION NOT ONE FIVE
BY THE WAY YEAH BUT THAT'S EVEN
MORE REASON TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT [inaudible] THIRTEEN
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
QUICK QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MY APOLOGIES FOR IF YOU
WERE TO COVER THIS --
WITH THE ALLOCATIONS BOTH FOR UC
AND CSU REGARDING.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE I I SEE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LISTED OUT A
SPECIFIC LIST OF CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECT THAT WERE IN AND NOT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IS THERE ALSO A COMPANY LIST FOR
YOU SEEN CSU HI WE DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A FULL LIST OF
THE PROPOSED PROJECTS ARE
PROJECTS THAT THE UC AND CSU WE
USE THESE FUNDS.
FOR HOWEVER BOTH SEGMENTS TO
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IDENTIFIED
BACKLOG FOR MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
ARE YOU GOING TO PUT A LIST
TOGETHER.
I WILL BE WORKING WITH YOU SEE
AS THE FOR THIS PROCESS GOES
WERE TO TO SORT OF LOOK THE WITH
WHICH PROJECT WILL BE FINE WITH
THE SCHOLARS AND MAYBE WE COULD
ALL.
DO THAT TOGETHER [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
YEAH AND AS YOU'VE PROBABLY
KNOWN FROM OUR EARLIER WORK BUT
WE HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
SEGMENTS BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
THEIR PROPOSED PROJECTS THAT
FINANCE BE REQUIRED A FEW YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD TO TELL YOU
WHETHER THOSE PROJECTS WERE
ACTUALLY UNDERTAKEN. FOR THEM
BOTH TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REDUCING THE BACKLOG AT THE SAME
TIME YOU'RE TRYING TO REDUCE THE
BACKLOG AND THEN IDEALLY THEY
EVEN HAVE A PLAN FOR ADDRESSING
THEIR OUR BACKLOG ON A LONG TERM
BASIS.
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH LA --
LAST YEAR AT THE MAY REVISION
AND COULD MONEY FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE I THINK THAT WAS ON
IT MADE A LOT OF SENSE BUT ALSO
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED AT SUCH A
LATE -- LATE
TIME IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
ACTUALLY BREAK OUT THE SPECIFIC
ITEMS.
I DON'T THINK FROM --
ONGOING BUDGETARY PRACTICE IT'S
A VERY RESPONSIBLE PRACTICE SO --
I THINK COULD BE HELPFUL TO KNOW
WHERE WHEN POWER SPENT FOR IT
FOR THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR.
AND THEN MOVING FORWARD I THINK
IT WOULD BE --
MUCH MORE RESPONSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY BREAK OUT THE EXPENSES --
AT THIS POINT WE'VE BEEN TRYING.
TO GET --
SORT OF MORE INFORMATION IT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT TO SIFT THROUGH
THE INFORMATION THAT I'VE
RECEIVED.
SO IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL --
BEFORE WE COULD REALLY APPROVE
ANY APPROPRIATIONS THE COULD BE
DIFFICULT WITHOUT OUT THE LIST
OF CAMPUSES AND PROJECTS.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S A BRING UP
OUR NEXT [inaudible]
I'LL.
PERSPECTIVES FROM OUR THREE
SEGMENTS
.
THE BILL START WITH PRESIDENT
APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES CHANCES WHITE IN
OAKLEY. TO DISCUSS HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
BUDGET FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I NOTED THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE FOR THE PRIOR PANEL AND
I'LL BE PREPARED TO ADDRESS
THOSE DURING THE Q. AND A
PORTION OF OUR PROGRAM THIS THIS
EVENING --
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WAS
TRULY APPRECIATIVE OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S BUDGET INTRODUCTION IT
IS A SOLID DOWN PAYMENT.
TOWARD HELPING OUR STUDENTS
ACHIEVE.
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM OF THE IDEA
THAT EVERY PERSON SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE A
BETTER LIFE.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY START
OUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
OF FOR THE STATE FUNDING --
THE UC HAS RECEIVED IN RECENT
YEARS --
THESE FUNDS HAVE SUPPORTED KEY
PRIORITIES THAT THE UNIVERSITY
AND STATE LEADERS SHARE.
EDUCATING MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EKANAYAKE TING GROUND
BREAKING RESEARCH TO ADDRESS A
SOCIETY'S CHALLENGES AND A FUEL
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY --
THE SET THIS EVENING I'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS JUST A FEW OF CRITICAL
AREAS RELATED TO THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
FIRST SOME GOOD NEWS FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
I WILL NOT REQUESTED UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
INCREASED TUITION FOR IN STATE
STUDENTS. FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ACADEMIC YEAR
THIS WILL MARK THE SEVENTH TIME
IN EIGHT YEARS THAT WE HAVE NOT
INCREASED IN STATE TUITION.
AT THE UC.
OF A BOARD OF REGENTS CHAIR
GEORGE KEEPER IT INDICATED IN
JANUARY THAT HE DID NOT FAVOR
TUITION INCREASE.
AND HOLDING TUITION FLAT
REFLECTS OUR MUTUAL GOALS AND
INTENT.
HOWEVER.
THE COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
NEWS TO BE HOLDING TUITION FLAT.
MEANS THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
LESS INSTITUTIONAL AID TO
DISTRIBUTE TO OUR POOREST
STUDENTS FOR THEIR LIVING
EXPENSES.
CURRENTLY WE TAKE ONE THIRD OF
OUR TUITION REVENUE AND RETURN
IT TO AID TO OUR NEEDIEST
STUDENTS --
THEY CAN USE THAT FOR HOUSING
AND FOR FOOD.
AND IF WE HOLD TUITION FLAT THAT
AMOUNT DOES NOT GROW.
WE'LL ALSO WORKED AGGRESSIVELY
TO CONTAIN COSTS WITHOUT
IMPACTING THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION ALL WHILE IN ROLLING
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAN
EVER BEFORE --
BUT DOING SO AS CERTAINLY HAD AN
IMPACT ON OUR CAMPUSES.
UP AND WHILE I'M DELIGHTED TO
MAKE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY
BECAUSE HOLDING IN STATE TUITION
FLAT IS A GOAL WE ALSO OUGHT TO
ATTAIN.
AS LEGISLATORS YOU SURELY
RECOGNIZE THAT MANDATORY COSTS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
STATE FUNDING WHILE SUBSTANTIAL
HAS NOT BEEN COMMENSURATE.
WITH COVERING THE INCREASED
ENROLLMENT AND ASSOCIATED COSTS
WITH THE INCREASE ENROLLMENT
THAT WE HAVE AND KURT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THE
HOLDING TUITION FLAT FOR THIS
MANY YEARS HAS NOT COME WITHOUT
CHALLENGES.
AND REQUIRED A LOT OF WORK ON
THE PART OF OUR CAMPUSES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN TWELVE
YOU SEE HAS INCREASED BY ONLY
TWO POINT 5%.
COMPARED TO AN 18% INCREASE IN
THE COST OF GOODS AND SERVICES
AS MEASURED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CPI.
WE ALL NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES. TO ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS CAN SUCCEED IN THAT
THEY EXPERIENCE THE QUALITY OF
THE UC EDUCATION FOR WHICH WE
ARE JUSTLY KNOWN.
THIS MEANS THAT WE EITHER HAVE --
HAVE MODERATE PREDICTABLE STABLE
TUITION INCREASES.
OR A COMMENSURATE AMOUNT OF
ONGOING STATE FUNDING
ACCOMPANIED BY ROBUST FINANCIAL
AID.
IT IS WITH THIS IN MIND THAT YOU
SEE AND ITS CHANCELLORS IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE BOARD OF
REGENTS.
ARE DEVELOPING A MULTI YEAR
VISION FOR THE UC OF THE FUTURE.
INFORMED BY THE STATE'S NEEDS
AND STRATEGIES FOR REALIZING
THAT VISION.
THE DRIVING FORCE BEHIND THIS
PLAN IS TO STRENGTHEN UC'S
CONTRIBUTION TO THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM AND PIVOT FROM YEAR TO
YEAR BUDGETING AND PLANNING
PROCESS. TO AN OUTCOME ORIENTED
APPROACH THAT AIMS TO ACHIEVE
BOLD ASPIRATIONAL GOALS OVER A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
OUR MULTI YEAR FRAMEWORK
CONTAINS GOALS SUCH AS AWARDING
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
DEGREES.
BY TWENTY THIRTY IN ADDITION TO
THE MILLION DEGREES ALREADY PLAN.
REDUCING THE TIME IT TAKES A
STUDENT TO GRADUATE.
AND ASSIST STUDENTS WHO LEFT YOU
SEE BEFORE GRADUATING IN
COMPLETING THEIR DEGREE.
AND GROWING A DIVERSE FACULTY
SHOW THAT WE ARE MORE REFLECTIVE
OF THE POPULATION WE SERVE.
AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT
RELATION.
WE'VE BEGUN TO SHARE OUR MULTI
YEAR PLAN WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
FACULTY AND STUDENTS.
AND WE WILL BE EAGER TO RECEIVE
YOUR FEEDBACK.
WE BELIEVE OUR VISION WILL ALLOW
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO DO ITS PART.
IN MAKING THE CALIFORNIA DURING
THE UC DREAM A REALITY FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
THIS PLAN REQUIRES YOUR
PARTNERSHIP.
IT'S DEPENDENT ON A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE TO ENSURE THE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE TO
MAINTAIN ACCESS AFFORDABILITY.
AND IMPORTANTLY QUALITY.
I'D LIKE TO SPEND A FEW MINUTES
ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INTRODUCTION.
WHICH PROVIDED YOU SEE WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION IN NEW
ONGOING FUNDING.
AN INCREASE FROM PAST BUDGET
INTRODUCTIONS WE ARE VERY
PLEASED WITH THIS AND WE REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
THESE FUNDS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
THE UNIVERSITY IS ADDED MORE
THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES.
GREATLY EXCEEDING OUR INITIAL
TARGET OF TEN THOUSAND NEW IN
STATE STUDENTS BY TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN THROUGH THIS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WE CONTINUE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
AND FIRST CHEN STUDENTS.
BUT AS YOU KNOW UC STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED FOR MORE THAN ONE YEAR
AND OUR CAMPUSES NEED ONGOING
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THEM.
AND THE NEXT CLASS OF STUDENTS
THAT REPLACE THEM.
THROUGHOUT THEIR COLLEGE
EDUCATION. TO SUPPORT THIS
INCREASED ENROLLMENT BECAUSE WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MORE
ACCESS WE ARE REQUESTING A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION. FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY IS CONTAINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IN LAST YEAR'S STATE BUDGET THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE.
REFLECTING THE SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IN AN EFFORT
SPEARHEADED BY HIGHER EDUCATION
CHAIR MEDINA.
APPROVED ONGOING PERMANENT FUNDS.
THESE FUNDS WERE PROVIDED
INSTEAD OF A TUITION INCREASE
AND TO SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WITH ALREADY AND ROLLED.
THIS ALLOWED US NOT TO INCREASE
TUITION LAST YEAR.
BUT ALTERNATELY THE FINAL BUDGET
BILL PROVIDED THE UNIVERSITY
WITH NINETY FIVE MILLION IN ONE
TIME MONIES.
THAT ONE TIME MONEY WILL GO AWAY
IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INTRODUCTION DID NOT INCLUDE
FUNDS TO REPLACE THIS AMOUNT.
SO PUT SIMPLY ABOUT HALF OF OUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO MILLION
REQUEST IS THAT THIS FUNDING BE
PROVIDED AS PERMANENT FUNDS.
JUST AS TUITION WOULD HAVE BEEN
A PERMANENT REVENUE SOURCE.
DOING SO IS ESSENTIAL TO
SUSTAINING UC'S INVESTMENTS IN
INSTRUCTORS TEACHING ASSISTANTS
AND CAMPUS BASED PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT THESE FUNDS OUR STUDENTS
SIMPLY MAY NOT GET THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO SUCCEED.
THE OTHER HALF OF THE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO MILLION.
WOULD.
GO TO SUPPORTING A LARGE --
LARGE PART OF THE ADDITIONAL --
HAPPENED A HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION WOULD SUPPORT.
AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADS
AND ONE THOUSAND GRADUATE
STUDENTS --
ALLOWING US TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN THE FACULTY AND STAFF
REQUIRED. TO SUPPORT PREVIOUS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AS WELL AS SOME MODEST CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS.
NO I'M NOT HERE JUST TO ASK FOR
MORE MONEY I'D LIKE TO SHARE OUR
PROGRESS ON COST CONTAINMENT AS
WELL.
WE HAVE REDUCE COSTS
SIGNIFICANTLY IN RECENT YEARS.
OUR NEW PROCUREMENT PROCESS IS
SAVING THE UNIVERSITY WELL OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR.
YOU SEE HAS EXTENDED THIS
PROGRAM TO SEE ISSUE A
COLLABORATION.
KNOWN AS CAL USE SOURCE.
OUR SELF INSURANCE PROGRAM
CALLED FEAR IT LOOKS SAVES US
ANOTHER TWENTY MILLION A YEAR.
WE ENDED FINANCIAL AID TO NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN LEADING THE
FORTY TWO MILLION AN ANNUAL SO
LAMENTED ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS WHICH HAVE YIELDED A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
MILLION IN SAVINGS.
WE CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR OTHER
WAYS TO STREAMLINE OPERATIONS
AND CREATE EFFICIENCIES WHILE
MAINTAINING ACCESSIBILITY
AFFORDABILITY AND QUALITY.
SO IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE YEARS.
TO COME AND TO THE STUDENTS THAT
WE ALL --
ARE PLEASE TO EDUCATE AND
PREPARE PREPARING NEXT
GENERATION THANK YOU MISS THANK
YOU CANCER RIGHT.
WELL THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
TO THE ENTIRE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY --
GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S FIRST BUDGET
PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A BOLD AND
HISTORIC COMMITMENT --
IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IT
INDICATES IS RECOGNITION OF OUR
CAREFUL STEWARDSHIP OF STATE
FUNDS.
AND OF THE SUCCESSES WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE WITH
PREVIOUS STATE SUPPORT IN TERMS
OF ACCESS IN TERMS OF QUALITY.
AND IN TERMS OF DEGREE
COMPLETION.
BUT MORE THAN INVESTMENT HIS
PROPOSED BUDGET REFLECTS A
SHARED VISION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND ITS
CRITICAL ROLE IN HELPING
CALIFORNIA REALIZE ITS BRIGHTEST
FUTURE.
IT IS A VISION THAT HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT OVER
THE YEARS.
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT THE CAL STATE VISION IS
BEING REALIZED AND EXCITING AND
QUITE FRANKLY HISTORIC WAYS.
WELL THERE ARE A MYRIAD OF
EXAMPLES I COULD HIGHLIGHT TO
ILLUSTRATE OUR PROGRESS.
UNIVERSITIES GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TO I'VE PROVIDES
PERHAPS THE MOST COMPELLING
EVIDENCE.
WE LAUNCH THIS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WAS REALLY QUITE
AGGRESSIVE AND AMBITIOUS GOALS
FOR IMPROVING GRADUATION RATES.
WHILE ELIMINATING EQUITY GAPS
AMONG OUR STUDENTS FOR
PARTICULARLY UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS AND THOSE WHO ARE CAL
GRANT.
OUR LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS.
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ARE
INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE RESULTED
IN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ADDITIONAL TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED MORE
COURSE SECTIONS A HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC ADVISORS AND
ABOUT.
NINETY THOUSAND RENDON SEATS IN
OUR CLASSROOMS.
AS WELL AS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW STUDENT ACADEMIC SUPPORT
PROGRAMS.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION YOU PROVIDED TO US
IN THE CURRENT.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND YEAR WELL
OUR CAMPUSES TO CONTINUE THESE
TRENDS.
THANKS TO THE STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT OF ART THESE FUNDS IN
AN UNWAVERING RELENTLESS FOCUS
ON THIS INITIATIVE --
PAY SOME KEY CHANGES IN POLICY --
EDUCATIONAL POLICY ARE AMBITIOUS
GOALS ARE PROVING TO BE
ATTAINABLE.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE GRADUATED
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IN THE HISTORY OF THE UNIVERSITY
AND SYSTEM WHY GRADUATION RATES
ARE AT ALL TIME HIGHS.
WITH YOU CALCULATE THEM AT THE
FOUR YEAR THE SIX YEAR TO YEAR
TRANSFER FOR YOUR TRANSFER
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
THE FOR YOUR GREAT --
FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME STUDENT
INCREASED BY SIX PERCENTAGE
POINTS.
ARE TO YOUR GRADUATION FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES JUMPED BY 7%
AND I THANK YOU HE LAURIE YOU IN
YOUR FACULTY.
OF FOR SENDING A SUCH WELL
PREPARED STUDENTS.
THE NUMBER OF BACHELOR'S
STUDENTS AWARD IN TWO HISTORICAL
HIGH OF ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ONE THAT'S AN INCREASE OF SIX
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DEGREES
OVER. TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED DEGREES MORE THAN IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN LEGALLY IF NOT
MORE IMPORTANT.
RIVETING BROUGH BEGINNING TO SEE
SUCCESS IN CLOSING THE EQUITY
GAP BETWEEN OUR STUDENTS TO COME
FROM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
LOW INCOME.
THAT WOULD DROP THAT EQUITY GAP
BY -- AS
FULL TWO FULL PERCENTAGE POINT
WHICH IS REALLY A REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENT AND SO OFTEN THE
STUDENTS OF THE STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
WE'VE DONE THAT DECREASE IN THE
EQUITY GAP AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE ARE IN ROLLING MORE.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THAT ARE
PARA RECIPIENTS AND MORE
STUDENTS COMING FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND FIRST GENERATION.
THIS IS INDEED RESTORED PROGRESS
AND MOTHERS WORK TO DO THERE
ALWAYS WILL BE WE'RE PROUD OF
THE ACHIEVEMENT FOR PRODUCT
ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON THAT
ELEMENT OF OUR STUDENT BODY.
MORE THAN PROGRESS HOWEVER THIS
IS MOMENTUM MOMENTUM MADE
POSSIBLE BY THE SKILLED FACULTY
IN.
AND STAFF THAT WE ARE A PLUS TO
HAVE THE CSU AND OUR CAMPUS
LEADERS WHO ARE LEADING THE
CAMPUS FOCUSED EFFORTS.
TO SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS
ACHIEVEMENT AND COMPLETION OF
DEGREE.
IT REALLY REPRESENTS A DIVIDEND
FOR YOUR INVESTMENT THE STATE
INVESTMENT IN A CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY IN IN A GRADUATION
INITIATIVE SPECIFICALLY.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S PROPOSAL WILL
ALLOW THIS MOMENTUM TO BUILD.
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN RECURRING FUNDING HE
PROPOSAL ENABLE US. TO PROVIDE
FAIR COMPENSATION TO THE MORE
THAN FIFTY THOUSAND FACULTY AND
STAFF WHO WORK SO DILIGENTLY TO
HELP OUR STUDENTS ACHIEVE THEIR
ACADEMIC AND PERSONAL GOALS.
HE'LL HELP US EXPAND ACCESS TO
SERVE AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW US TO
INVEST IN THE PROVEN RESEARCH
SUPPORTED STRATEGIES FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT SUCCESS AND
COMPLETION THAT UNDER PAN OR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
IN A TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR A CAPITAL NEEDS WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT OUR CAMPUSES
CAN PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH.
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CLASSROOMS
LABORATORIES CLINIC STUDIOS IN
THE LIST GOES ON BUT WE CAN.
AND WE MUST DO MORE.
YOU'RE ONLY HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC IT'S A DIVERSE GROUP OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND YOUNG CALIFORNIANS.
SATISFY THE CALIPHATE
UNIVERSITIES ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OUR
SYSTEM WIDE WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO OPEN THE DOORS --
TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR SIXTY
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
AND WE'RE THIS BUDGET TO INCLUDE
THE INVESTMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR GRAD INITIATIVE
WHICH IS WHAT WE REQUESTED.
WE ARE CONFIDENT WE COULD
CONTINUE TO DEMONSTRATE THE
EXTRAORDINARY RESULTS THAT I
JUST DESCRIBED.
THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY REMAINS
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
ALL QUALIFIED CALIFORNIANS.
THE OPPORTUNITY IS MADE POSSIBLE
BY HER HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE DREAMS THE HOPES THE
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT COME WITH A
DEGREE FROM THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY.
AND ON A MASSIVE SCALE WE
PREPARE PEOPLE TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND FUTURE
PROSPERITY LET ALONE SOCIAL
ABILITY FOR THEIR CELLS OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE SCOPE OF OUR MISSION
REQUIRES A ROBUST FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S PROPOSAL
PRESENT REPRESENTS JUST SUCH A
COMMITMENTAND WE FULLY SUPPORT
HIS BUDGET RECOMMENDATION.
WE ALSO STAND READY IN THIS IS
IMPORTANT WE STAND READY AND
WOULD WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR CHOOSE TO FULLY
FUND OUR ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
IN OUR GRADUATION INITIATIVE
BUDGET REQUESTS.
LET'S NOT LOSE TRACK.
THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY A MANY
GUYS THINK GROUPS INCLUDING A PP
I SEE HER LOOKING AT THAT DEGREE
DEFICIT THAT THE DROUGHT OF
DEGREES BACCALAUREATE DEGREES.
IN CALIFORNIA OF ONE MILLION.
AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR HALF THAT
AMOUNT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL BOTTLER EIGHT DEGREES.
THIS REQUIRES RESOURCES TO
ACHIEVE IF WE DON'T INVEST NOW
IN A STRONG ECONOMY WE WILL NOT
ANSWER THIS CLARION CALL. TO THE
DETRIMENT OF CALIFORNIA AND TO
THE DETRIMENT OF CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU CARE MCCARTY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
TRANSPORTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON A THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US --
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ALSO
WANT TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
MY COLLEAGUES HERE AT THE TABLE
AND THANK THEM PUBLICLY FIRST OF
ALL THANK --
CHANCER WHITE FOR THE GREAT WORK
TO SEE IS DOING SEE A FUTURE
WITH THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
AND THANK A PRESENT A POLITICIAN
A FOR A COMMITMENT TO TRANSFER.
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE ASSOCIATES.
TO I HAD THE GREAT PRIVILEGE OF
LEADING. ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
GREATEST TREASURES CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND I'M GLAD TO BE BACK HERE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN.
A LITTLE OVER TWO YEARS SINCE
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES COMMITTED TO OUR VISION
FOR SUCCESS.
GUIDED BY THAT VISION WE
CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE THE STATUS
QUO.
AND DRIVE INNOVATION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH THE RELENTLESS
FOCUS.
ON ENSURING THE STUDENTS FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS.
ACHIEVE THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO FOLLOWING OUR
NORTH STAR OF CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND WE'RE
CHARGING FORWARD.
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON RESTRUCTURING
OR COLLEGES.
SO THAT THEY WILL BE MORE
STUDENT READY.
AND WE SHINE A CLEAR SPOTLIGHT.
ON THE ISSUES OF EQUITY ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN A KEY
AN IMPORTANT PARTNER.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOU PROVIDED
CRITICAL FUNDING. FOR THE GUIDED
PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK.
OUR COLLEGES R. CREATING CLEAR
PATHWAYS TO EMPLOYMENT.
AND FURTHERING THEIR EDUCATION.
THEY'RE HELPING EVERY STUDENT
CHOOSE AND ENTER THEIR PATHWAY
AND THEN STAY ON PATH --
AND WE'RE MONITORING THEIR
PROGRESS IN THOSE OUTCOMES
[inaudible]
YOU ALSO --
SUPPORTED LANDMARK A LANDMARK
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AB SEVEN OH
FIVE AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WHEN?
WHICH INSURES THAT STUDENTS ARE
NOT PLACED INTO REMEDIAL COURSES
THAT MAY DETER THEM FROM
EDUCATIONAL PROGRESS UNLESS
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS.
THAT THEY ARE HIGHLY UNLIKELY TO
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES.
THE SAME YEAR.
WORKING TOGETHER WE CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROBLEMS.
THROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
THE COMPONENTS OF THAT PROGRAM
RESONATE DEEPLY --
WITH ME AND WITH MY EXPERIENCES
IN LONG BEACH IS I'M SURE.
MEMBER O'DONNELL CAN ATTEST --
THROUGH THE LONG BEACH COLLEGE
PROMISE SCHOOL LEADERS.
WORKING WITH COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY FACULTY AND STAFF.
PROMOTE A COLLEGE GOING CULTURE.
IN CLEAR PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS
TO FOLLOW.
AS THEY MOVE FROM ONE
INSTITUTION TO THE OTHER.
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
NOW MAXIMIZES ACCESS TO EXISTING
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
ENCOURAGES COLLEGES. TO ENGAGE
IN EVIDENCE BASED STUDENT
SUCCESS STRATEGIES.
IT AUTHORIZES FUNDING TO BE USED
TO SUPPORT ONE YEAR OF FREE
TUITION.
FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THIS OR
FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
CURRENTLY INCLUDED FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
THAT AT THE ALREADY TO WAIVE
FEES IS LINKED TO CONDITIONS
SPECIFYING THAT COLLEGES MUST DO
THE FOLLOWING.
THEY MUST EXPAND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THEY SHOULD USE MULTIPLE
MEASURES FOR ASSESSMENT
EMPLACEMENT CONSISTENT WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN OH FIVE YOU MUST
PARTICIPATE IN THE GUIDED
PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK THAT YOU HELP
INVEST IN.
THEY MUST ENSURE THE STUDENTS
COMPLETE THE FEDERAL OR STATE
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM.
I ALSO KNOW HOW SIGNIFICANT THE
CHANGES WE MADE LAST YEAR WERE.
WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
NEW STUDENT CENTER FUNDING
FORMULA AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE NEW ONLINE COLLEGE.
THOSE CHANGES WILL REINFORCE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON THE GOALS.
AND CREATE IMPORTANT NEW
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR WORKERS FOR
WORKING ADULTS MANY OF WHICH ARE
REPRESENTED BY GREAT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE SEIU IN
OTHERS.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO HELP
THEM RESPOND TO THE CHANGES IN
THE ECONOMY.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES OF THE CALIFORNIA
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
RECENTLY NAMED HEATHER HYLES TO
BE THE COLLEGE'S FIRST CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
HEATHER IS AN INNOVATOR.
SHE IS AN EDUCATIONAL LEADER AND
A SUCCESSFUL ENTREPRENEUR WITH A
DEEP COMMITMENT TO EQUITY IN
EDUCATION ANY CREATING.
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDER
REPRESENTED IN UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T MET HER ALREADY.
WE WILL SOON ARRANGE FOR YOU TO
MEET HER.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU WILL SEE THE
SAME QUALITIES THAT I'M
CONFIDENT WILL MAKE HER AN
EFFECTIVE LEADER. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S NEWEST COLLEGE.
I DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
CONFIDENCE THE GOVERNOR KNEW
SOME PLACES IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AS REFLECTED IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO ENACT A
BUDGET.
THAT BUILDS ON YOUR PRIORITIES
OF REFORM AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EXPANSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE.
BECAUSE OF BILLS ON A FRAMEWORK
CREATED UNDER AB.
NINETEEN I WON AGAIN THANK
CHAIRMAN CARTY FOR YOUR EFFORTS
AROUND AB.
TWO MY STAFF WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO. TO MAKE SURE
THE BILL ACCOMPLISHES OUR SHARED
GOALS.
BUT I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE.
THAT WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
THE FRAMEWORK ENACTED IN AB
NINETEEN MUST REMAIN IN PLACE.
IF THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO HELP
US ACHIEVE THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS.
THAT PROPOSAL IS PROP A IS PART
OF A BROADER THEME IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ADDRESSING COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
SO THAT MORE CALIFORNIANS CAN
GAIN SKILLS AND CREDENTIALS THAT
THEY NEED TO SUCCEED IN TODAY'S
ECONOMY.
LET ME UNDERSCORE THE URGENCY OF
THAT WORK. TO ACHIEVE THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE REFORMS
THAT WE'VE UNDERTAKEN IN TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MUST BE
COMPLIMENTED.
WITH CHANGES TO THE FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM THAT ADDRESSES THE
TRUE COST OF COLLEGE ATTENDANCE
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET EXPANDS
CAL GRANT THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
FOR STUDENTS WHO RELY ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE MOST.
WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT FOR THE NEW CAL GRANT
FOR STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT
CHILDREN AND FOR THE NEW
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARDS.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY'S
LEADERSHIP.
IN EXPANDING FINANCIAL AID.
I COMMIT TO WORK WITH YOU TO
PUSH THE NEEDED REFORMS FORWARD
THIS YEAR.
AS YOU ARE ALREADY AWARE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE SPONSORING SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY ONE AUTHORED BY SENATOR
LEYVA.
I WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM FOR CO
AUTHORING THE BILL.
AND FOR THE SUPPORT OF MEMBER
MEDINA AS WELL.
THE BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS SUPPORTERS
REFLECT A BROAD COALITION.
INCLUDING OUR STUDENTS FACULTY
STAFF WHO WORK WITH THEM EVERY
DAY. TO ADDRESS OUR MOST BASIC
NEEDS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THOUGH --
THAT THE PRINCIPAL ABOUT THE
PRINCIPLES THAT UNDER GIRD THIS
PROPOSAL.
FIRST OF ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE BECAUSE STUDENTS WITH
FINANCIAL NEED SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL
AID REGARDLESS OF THEIR AGE.
THEIR TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL OR
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL GRADES.
A STUDENT'S FINANCIAL AID SHOULD
BE LINKED TO THE TRUE COST OF
ATTENDING COLLEGE NOT JUST
TUITION AND FEES BUT ALSO
CRITICAL ISSUES LIKE HOUSING.
FOOD TRANSPORTATION AND SUPPLIES
[inaudible]
A STUDENT.
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
AID REGARDLESS OF THE STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL GOALS THAT IS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
STUDENT SIX TO COMPLETE A DEGREE.
A CERTIFICATE OR SHORT TERM
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM WHICH MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE LOOKING FOR
PARTICULARLY THOSE.
WORKERS WHO MAY BE DISPLACED BY
AUTOMATION ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
I WON AGAIN RECOGNIZE MY
COLLEAGUES PRESIDENT APOLLO TANO
CHANCE OR WHITE FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING
FINANCIAL AID IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE ONE SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE STATE SO
GREAT OUR OUTCOMES ARE
INTERCONNECTED AND WE MUST FOCUS
ON STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY ATTEND TODAY.
NOT MOVING FORWARD.
I COMMIT TO WORKING TIRELESSLY
TO COMBAT THE ASSUMPTIONS
[inaudible]
OFTEN.
MADE ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR VALUE.
FROM TIME TO TIME I HEAR SOME.
IN THIS BUILDING.
SAY THAT --
AND INVESTMENT IN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT IS NOT A WISE
INVESTMENT I COULDN'T DISAGREE
MORE.
LIKE OTHER STUDENTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS DO FACE COSTS
FOR FOOD HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION 40% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE OVER THE
AGE OF TWENTY FIVE THESE ARE
WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
MANY STUDENTS ARE SUPPORTING NOT
ONLY THEMSELVES BUT THEIR
FAMILIES.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ALREADY WORK TO PAY FOR THEIR
EDUCATION.
WHAT WE KNOW THOUGH IS THAT
STUDENTS WHO NEED TO WORK
EXCESSIVE HOURS TO PAY FOR THE
TRUE COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE?
ARE WORKING SO MANY HOURS AT IT
IMPEDES THEIR ABILITY TO REACH
OUR EDUCATIONAL GOAL AND THESE
ARE THE INDIVIDUALS WE NEED
PARTICIPATING IN OUR WORK FORCE.
FINALLY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
DESERVE THIS FINANCIAL AID.
THEY COME FROM GROUPS THAT HAVE
FACED THE HIGHEST BARRIERS TO
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THEY ARE WORKING TO IMPROVE
THEIR CHANCES IN A VERY RISKY
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA NEEDS THEM.
IN ORDER FOR US TO SUCCEED.
SB TWO NINETY ONE SPECIFIES
INTENT THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS BE INCLUDED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE
PROGRAM.
I HOPE TO PARTNER WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ENACT THAT
APPROPRIATION.
I WANT TO BEGIN TO CLOSE BY
EXPRESSING HOW MINDFUL I AM.
ABOUT THE CONSTRAINTS CREATED BY
MORE LIMITED GROWTH IN
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT THEN WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN RECENT YEARS.
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA.
HOWEVER I SHARE THE CONCERNS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S RACE ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE QUALITY OF THE
DATA BEING USED IN THE FORMULA.
AND A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
THAT DATA --
IS ONGOING AND WILL BE COMPLETED
IN MAY TO INFORM YOUR FIND AT
YOUR FINAL DELIBERATIONS ON THE
BUDGET.
WE ALSO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
RELIEF ON PENSION COSTS.
OF THESE INCREASE PENSION COSTS
ARE WREAKING HAVOC ON OUR
DISTRICTS AND SO THIS RELEASE
WILL ALLOW THEM TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES TO BETTER SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS.
AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDING CAPITAL
OUTLAY FUNDS. TO FUND SUPPORT
FIFTEEN CONTINUING PROJECT IN
TWELVE NEW ONES HOWEVER.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT IN ENACTING
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE THE VOTERS
CALLED FOR GREATER INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS HAS
APPROVED A TOTAL OF NINETEEN
CONTINUE AND PROJECTS IN THIRTY
NINE YOU PROJECTS.
AND WE WISH TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO FUND THOSE PROJECTS.
AND EVEN WITH MORE LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE A CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY. TO IMPROVE HIGHER
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY ALL OF US
WORKING TOGETHER PARTICULARLY
THOSE AT THE TABLE.
HERE TODAY I COMMIT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
ALL OF YOU WITH ALL OF YOU.
AND IT'S A GOVERNOR HIS CALL FOR
US TO FINALLY ACHIEVE A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
EVEN GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ASSESSING HOW
OUR STUDENTS ARE DOING FROM
CRADLE TO CAREER AND SUPPORTING
HIM ALL THROUGHOUT THEIR PATH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION A LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
VERY THOROUGH --
QUESTIONS FOR OUR SEGMENTS.
ALL OF A FEW.
SOMEONE I REALLY MONTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THINKS THAT
TO ALL --
THREE FOR YOUR COMMENTS I THINK
THAT THEIR COMMENTS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM SEVERAL STAKEHOLDERS
ANNA IN IN TE COMMUNITY ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE AND RELEVANCE OF
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING --
AS IT BUILDS OUR STUDENT
POPULATION I HAVE ONE GENERAL
QUESTION FOR ALL THREE OF YOU
AND THEN I HAVE A QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY --
FOR CHANCELLOR WHITE --
I'LL START UP WITH THE GENERAL
QUESTIONS IT WAS NOTED AND
MENTIONED THAT TO US.
A NUMBER OF TIMES THAT WE HAVE
THE ONE MILLION SHORTAGE SPOT
SHORTAGE --
YOU KNOW THREE TWENTY THIRTY
INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING IT TO
ADDRESS THIS IN A MORE SYSTEMIC
WAY AS OPPOSED TO I KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GETTING TWO DAYS WHAT WE
NEED FOR THIS YEAR.
BUT IN THE NEXT YOU KNOW OVER
TWENTY THIRTY WHAT DOES THAT
PLAN LOOK LIKE IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT.
OF WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO KIND OF CRAFT ON
OUR OWN WHAT WE THINK AND I
THINK WE DO HAVE IDEAS OF WHAT
WE THINK THAT COULD LOOK LIKE.
BUT I'M CURIOUS WHAT YOU'RE
DOING -- AS
A SYSTEM.
AND IN THE SPECIFIC QUESTION I
HAVE FOR CHANCELLOR --
WHITE WAS YOU MENTIONED THE DROP
IN EQUITY GAP --
AND I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
METRICS TO USE HOW WHAT WHAT IS.
THE DROP ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE AND
MEASURE.
SO I'M HAPPY TO BEGIN AND I'LL
PASS IT OVER TO AT PRESENT ABOUT
TIME NO IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I'LL MENTION THREE
THINGS THEY WERE DOING
SPECIFICALLY.
ONE WE'VE COMMITTED TO
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF OF
CREDENTIALS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BY 20%.
ANNUALLY WE'VE ALSO COMMITTED TO
INCREASING TRANSFERRED TO CSUN
UC BY 35% ANNUALLY.
AND WE'VE COMMITTED TO CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP CUTTING IT
IN HALF.
IN.
OF FOUR YEARS IN COMPLETELY
CLOSING IT IN.
TEN CAN YOU SAY A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT IF YOU MAY GET
THE YES TO THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS YES THAT'S ON YOUR
MEASURING THAT BY TWO GIRLS
EARNED TIME TO DEGREE WHAT'S.
SO WE'RE MEASURING THAT BY.
STUDENTS COMPLETING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOAL WHETHER THAT BE
A CERTIFICATE DEGREE OR TRANSFER.
SO RIGHT NOW WE SEE CLEAR
ACHIEVEMENT ETHNIC GROUPS.
ACROSS THE STATE AND
SPECIFICALLY IN REGIONS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE PROFOUND THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY HIGH
WE'RE COMMITTED TO CLOSING THOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS OR WHETHER
THEY'RE PURSUING A CERTIFICATE.
AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE OR
TRANSFER THEIR ACHIEVING THEM --
IT EQUAL RATES ACROSS RACIAL
ETHNIC AS WELL AS GENDER --
LINES.
YEAH THANK YOU SO AS AS I
MENTIONED --
OR WE HAVE.
DEVELOPED A FOUR YEAR --
FRAMEWORK --
THAT --
PROVIDES --
THAT WE WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF GRADUATES GRADUATE DEGREE --
DEGREES BOTH UNDERGRADUATE
GRADUATE BY --
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND BY --
TWENTY THREE AND TO DO THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS.
IS TO REDUCE THE TIME TO
GRADUATION --
SO THAT THE SIX IS GO TO FIVE IN
THE FIVE TO FOUR HOURS.
THAT WOULD PARTICULARLY IMPACT
ARE A FIRST GENERATION PELL
GRANT AND UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY STUDENTS WHO ARE
TENDING TO TAKE LONGER TO GET
THEIR DEGREES.
SO AS WE IF IF WE CAN GRADUATE
THEM MORE QUICKLY MOVE THE MODEL
PROFESSIONAL OR GRADUATE SCHOOL
OR IN THE WORKPLACE THAT OPENS
UP ANOTHER SPACE FOR ANOTHER
UNDERGRADUATE.
SO THAT THAT'S CORRECT.
SO MEMBERS LIMóN THANKS FOR THE
WONDERFUL QUESTIONS SO.
ARE GRADUATION INITIATIVE --
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THAT WE
LAUNCHED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN IS A OF A MULTI
YEAR PLAN.
OF DAD WE IMAGINED NEW
INVESTMENT IN EVERY YEAR OVER
THE COURSE OF SIX YEARS EACH
BEING IT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION.
WE PRICES OUT IT'S ABOUT A OF
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR --
EFFORT IN ORDER TO IMPROVE OUR
GRADUATION RATES.
DECREASE THE TIME TO DEGREE AND
MAINTAIN HIGH QUALITY.
WE WENT INTO THE TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES AND ANALYZED
INDIVIDUALLY.
IN IN ALL THE FEELS OF THE THE
STUDENT TIME TO DEGREE AND WHAT
THE POSSIBILITIES WERE FOR
IMPROVEMENT --
SO IT'S ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ACROSS THE
TWENTY THREE IN TERMS OF THE
STUDENTS OF THAT WE SERVE.
AND THEN WE AGGREGATED JUST
ACROSS THIS IS OF THE VARIOUS
CAMPUSES HE CAME UP WITH THE
SYSTEM LEVEL GOALS --
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR ABILITY TO DO
OUR PIECE OF THE MILLION DOLLAR
MILLION DOLLAR I WHICH IS ONLY A
MILLION DOLLARS --
THE MILLION DEGREE GAP THAT THE
DROUGHT THIS FACING CALIFORNIA.
IS WE FEEL OUR A PORTION OF THAT
IS 50%.
AND SO WE PUT THIS BOTTLE
TOGETHER REQUIRES TWO ELEMENTS.
ONE ELEMENT IS FIRST TO CONTINUE
DOING CREE AND MAGE.
MEET OUR IMPROVEMENTS IN
GRADUATION RATES SO.
IN OF THE FOUR YEAR RATE --
FOR HALF YOUR RATE TO FIVE EVERY
EVERY RATE YOU CAN MEASURE WE
WANTED TO BECOME BETTER --
ANOTHER WAY TO LOOK AT THAT IS
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
DEGREES EARNED OVER A TIME FOR
STUDENT.
VERY FEW GET A FOUR YEAR DEGREE
IN LESS THAN THREE YEARS THERE
ARE SOME WHO CAME IN WITH A LOT
OF CREDITS FROM AP COURSES AND
GO YEAR ROUND AND GET HER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN THREE YEARS
BUT THERE IS A VERY MINOR.
NUMBER A LOT OF STUDENTS GET
ABOUT FOUR AFTER FOUR YEARS ONE
SEMESTER FOR HALF FIVES.
AND THE WHOLE IDEA IS LOOKING AT
DISTRIBUTION CURVE.
SO OUR GOAL IS TO TAKE THAT
ENTIRE DISTRIBUTION CURVE MOVING
UP INTO THE LEFT.
SO THE SINGLE MOM WHO'S WORKING --
FORTY HOUR WEEK AND IS ON THE
SIX YEAR PLAN LET'S MAKE SURE
THE UNIVERSITY HELPS HER AND SHE
THAT DEGREE IN FIVE AND A HALF
YEARS WHAT A WONDERFUL
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR HER AND HER
FAMILY.
IT REQUIRES TWO THINGS ONE IS
THIS RELENTLESS INVESTMENT IN
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE WHICH
IS PART OF OUR BUDGET ASKING
WHICH IS BEEN.
PARTIALLY FUNDED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THE SECOND IS TO INCREASE
OUR ENROLLMENTS SO THERE'S MORE
STUDENTS ACHIEVING AT A HIGHER
RATE IT'S A MATHEMATICAL
COMBINATION OF DOING BETTER.
INTERNING DEGREE AND MORE
STUDENTS HAVING THAT OPPORTUNITY
WHEN THOSE TWO THINGS COME
TOGETHER.
WE WILL REACH THAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
MADE THAT THE TRUSTEES REQUEST
IS. TO INVEST.
HI MORE MORE HIGHLY THAN THE
GOVERNOR HAS.
SUGGESTED IN HIS INITIAL BUDGET
WILL FUND AND ROMAN AND ON THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND WE'RE
READY WILLING AND ABLE TO DO
MORE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE EQUITY GAP I
THINK --
CHANCE FOR OF ORTIZ IS COMMON IT
IS EXACTLY RIGHT I THINK THE YOU
I POINTED OUT THAT THE EQUITY
GAP IS THEIR GRADUATION RATE IN
AGAIN HOWEVER YOU CALCULATED AT
THE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT
YEAR LEVEL.
OF HIS HAS HISTORICALLY --
FOR STUDENTS WHO COME FROM.
LOW INCOME.
WHO ARE FIRST GENERATION AND WHO
ARE THEN OFTEN OF COLOR?
AND SO OUR RELENTLESS FOCUS ON
IMPROVING GETTING RID OF THE
EQUITY GAPS YOU KNOW THE WORD
RAISING THEIR GRADUATION RATES
OF THOSE STUDENTS WHO COME UP
FROM THE UNDERSERVED PART OF
SOCIETY.
MORE THAN RAISING THE GRADUATION
RATES FOR THOSE WHO COME FROM
THE PROVISION OF OUR SOCIETY.
WHO?
DECREASES THAT AND THAT WE'VE
MOVED THAT TWO PERCENTAGE POINTS
SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE NOW NO
EQUITY GAPS.
IN FACT STUDENTS WHO COME FROM
THE UNDER REPRESENTED HERE IS
ACTUALLY ACHIEVING BETTER THAN
THOSE WHO COME.
FROM THE MORE TRADITIONAL AREAS
SO WE HAVE MADE THAT IS A SORT
OF OUR MOON SHOT --
TO GET RID OF EQUITY GAPS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IT'S
A IT'S A BIG LEFT.
AND WE DON'T CONTROL ALL OF
VARIABLES BECAUSE WE ONLY CAN DO
IS WHAT.
OUR STUDENTS BRING TO US AND
SOME OF COME OUT A VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
TAKE MORE TIME TO ACHIEVE.
THAT IS OUR MORAL COMMITMENT TO
GET RID OF THE EQUITY GAP IS
MATTER HOW LONG IT TAKES WILL
GET THEIR THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS --
I THINK I'M STILL GRAPPLING IN
ANYTHING'S ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL KIND OF TOUCHED ON
THIS IN ONE OF YOUR PREVIOUS.
QUESTIONS I'M TRAVELING A LITTLE
BIT WITH WHAT THE AVERAGE TIME
TO DEGREE IS --
AND HOW.
THAT FORMULATES TO MEETING THE
GOAL SO IF THE AVERAGE TIME TO
DEGREES FOUR POINT TWO FIVE OR
FOUR POINT.
SEVEN THEN HOW I MEAN ARE WE
REALLY LOOKING AT A THREE YEAR
LIKE IT IN ORDER TO MEET THIS.
BIG GAP IT JUST I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU GET THAT LOWER WITHOUT THEN.
IMPACT DEAN IN THE QUALITY OF
EXPERIENCE. FOR STUDENTS AND I I
DON'T KNOW I'M STILL GRAPPLING
WITH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE FORMULA IS.
WITH OUT THEN --
IMPACT DEAN.
I JUST DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GET
LOWER THE FOUR POINT --
TWO FIVE FOUR POINT SEVEN IS NOT
BAD AND SO WITH FOR GOING.
ONE LOWER THAN THAT REALLY MEANS
WERE DOING AN EXPEDITED.
DEGREE AND I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
CHANGES MAYBE I'M OFF MAYBE I'M
NOT HEARING THE THINGS I DON'T
KNOW.
MEMBER NUMBER MY MY SO AT THE
UNIVERSITYOF CALIFORNIA --
SIXTY SOME ODD PERCENT OF OUR
STUDENTS GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS.
OF ABOUT 88% GRADUATE IN SIX
YEARS.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS GET
EVERYBODY DOWN TO THAT FOUR YEAR
LEVEL?
AND TO DO THAT --
REQUIRES --
AND INVESTMENT --
IN TERMS OF ADDITIONAL.
FACULTY AND T. A.'S AN ACADEMIC
ADVISORS --
AND OTHER --
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ENABLE
STUDENTS --
TO SUCCEED AN HONOR FOR YOUR SIX
AND IT MAKES A REAL DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE WHAT WE SEE.
IS THAT --
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE TAKING
LONGER TO GRADUATE THEY DO
GRADUATE.
WITH A TAKEN LONGER TO GRADUATE --
TEND TO COME.
FROM THOSE WHO COME FROM
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES --
AND SO WE NEED --
TO REALLY WORK WITH THOSE
STUDENTS TO GET THEM TO A FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION --
A DEGREE.
SO I THINK IT MEMBER ALONE I
THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES HERE
SOMETIMES OF THE WORDS YOU GET
USE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SECURE
GRADUATION RATE TO DOESN'T MEAN
IT TAKES A STUDENT SIX YEARS TO
GRADUATE.
A STUDENT WHO GOES FOR YEARS AND
ONE SEMESTER.
GETS COUNTED FEDERALLY IN THE
IPAD'S DATABASE IS A SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATE.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT SIX YEAR MEANS SIX YEARS OR
LESS.
THAT'S WHY ARE --
MEDIAN TIME DEGREE IS.
BASICALLY A LITTLE BIT OVER FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS HALF OUR
STUDENTS GET THEIR BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN FOR A HALF YEARS
[inaudible]
OR LESS.
BUT THE SIX YEAR RIZZO OUR
RELENTLESS FOCUS IN THE GRANT
INITIATIVE.
IS AND WE JUST DISCUSSED THIS IS
TO RAISE THE THOSE WHO GET IN
FOUR YEARS THOSE WHO GET IT FOR
HALF. FIVE FIVE AND HAVE SIX AND
WE CAN BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
STUDENTS WHO COME FROM LOW
INCOME.
AND FIRST GENERATION AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
FOCUSING ON THAT EQUITY GAP IS A
HUGE DRIVER. TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THEIR DEGREE.
AND DEGREE COMPLETION IS SO
SIMPLE AS INSTEAD OF HAVING
ADVISERS SAY.
YOU KNOW WELCOME TIM I'M GLAD
YOU'RE HERE I KNOW YOU COME FROM
LOW INCOME AND YOUR FIRST
GENERATION IN YOUR IMMIGRANT KID
FROM ARGENTINA.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU ONLY
TAKE TELL TWELVE CREDITS.
WELL SIR AS I TAKE TWELVE
CREDITS.
THERE'S NO WAY IN HECK I CAN GET
DONE IN FOUR YEARS.
SO PART OF IT IS RAISING THE
EXPECTATIONS AND RATHER THAN
APPROACHING STUDENTS WHO COME --
LIKE I JUST DESCRIBED AS DEFICIT
MODELS WE ACTUALLY SEE THEM AS
ASSETS AND THAT THEY ARE CAPABLE
TO TAKE BUT TO GIVE THEM FIFTEEN
CREDITS THEY HAVE TO GET THE
COURSES THAT WORK AROUND THEIR
WORK SCHEDULES AND AND THEY'RE
PSYCH MAJOR MAKING SURE THE
SECOND SEMESTER CLASSES
AVAILABLE WHEN.
THEY'RE READY FOR IT AND SO
FORTH NATURAL THESE INVESTMENTS
COME IN.
A GREAT MORE CLASSES MORE
FACULTY MORE ACADEMIC SUPPORT SO
REGARDLESS OF THE CHALLENGES
THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT TO ACHIEVE
WE CAN TALK OFF LINE A LITTLE
BIT MORE HOW THIS MODEL WORKS.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN VERY
THOUGHTFUL SET OF CONVERSATIONS
OF LEAD TO THE GRAD INITIATIVE.
WE'RE EXECUTING IT REQUIRES
RESOURCE.
AND THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR PITCH
HERE'S TO THIS REALLY DOES
MATTER FOR STUDENTS IT REALLY
MATTERS FOR CALIFORNIA'S.
FUTURE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL
ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS MESSAGE BUT BEFORE YOU GET
THERE IT'S WHEN A NOTE THAT LAST
ISSUE IS SO KEY.
WITH STUDENTS WHO SHOW UP AT THE
CSU.
AND WE SELL AMEND LOWER
EXPECTATIONS AND BUT THEY GET A
CALTRANS.
THE SAY FULL TIME CAL RENDER
FEDERAL LOST TWELVE UNITS.
MISSY ALMOST FULL TIME.
BUT YOU KNOW.
TWELVE UNITS PER SEMESTER
DOESN'T ADD UP AND YOU RUN OUT.
OF CAL GRANT MONEY IN YOUR FIFTH
YEAR AND THE STUDENTS TO TAKE
OUT A STUDENT LOAN AND SO WE'RE
HARMING THE STUDENTS AND SELL.
AND THEY'LL CHECK PRESIDENT HERE
AT SAKS DATE NELSON HAS REALLY
STEPPED UP.
THAT IN HE'S HAVING ALL THE
STUDENTS ABOUT 75% TAKING
ROUGHLY FIFTEEN UNITS AS
INCOMING FRESHMEN REGARDLESS OF
THEIR THEIR SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS
AND HE'S FINDING OUT THAT
THEY'RE DOING WELL SO.
WE NEED TO DO THAT BUT ONE THING
THAT IS IMPORTANT THAT.
IS GOING TO BE IN THE BILL THAT
AND I ARE OFFERING THE
FINANCIALLY BILL WHICH HAS YOUR
IDEA BUT MORE SO WE'RE GONNA GO
BIGGER THAN YOU MARS GOOD YES
ONE IS ALWAYS GOOD YES.
IS TO MAKE SURE WE FIND CALTRANS
FOR SUMMER.
YES THAT IS A IS A KEY KEEP IN
THAT'S A NOW ROUGHLY AT JUST A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR --
PRICE TAG BUT IF WE LOOK AT THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE HOPING TO DO
THIS YEAR AND HIGHER AD THAT'S
ON THE TOP THE LIST OF THINGS IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WE YES.
SO -- I WILL
COME BACK A LITTLE BIT BUT LIKE
CONTINUE WITH OUR MEMBERS FIRST
SEMESTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
I I WANT TO START OFF ON A ON A
VERY POSITIVE NO YOU KNOW I AM
ALWAYS.
BRAGGING TO MY CONSTITUENTS
ABOUT HOW THE YOU KNOW THE BEST
THING THAT WE HAVE GOING IN THE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
OUR PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM INTO WHETHER OR TALK
ABOUT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
ARE COMMUNICABLE EDGES.
YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S ONE OF
THE GREATEST --
ASSETS SO WE HAVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW I SEE
MY JOB IS NOT ONLY.
TO SUPPORT THAT AND BUT ALSO DO
NOT SCREW THAT UP.
THE MED SURG --
PRESIDENT A PLATANO YOU THE U.
STARTING AFTER PRESENTATION BY
TALKING ABOUT HOW --
YOU WILL NOT BE REQUESTING A
TUITION INCREASE THIS YEAR FOR
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BASED
ON I I I ASSUME BASED ON THE THE
GOVERNOR'S --
BUDGET PROPOSAL --
I WANTED TO ASK CHANCE ARE WHITE
AND AND CHESS OAKLEY IF YOU
WOULD BE --
READY TO MAKE THAT SAME
STATEMENT OR COMMITMENT --
LET'S CHECK YOUR WHITE FIRST.
YEAH SO DID YOU DO JANUARY THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES MEETING I MADE
THAT ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE WOULD
NOT BE RAISING TUITION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
AND THAT'S A TRICK QUESTION BY
THE WAY MY ANSWER IS EASY.
BECAUSE YOU SAID OUR TUITION YES.
IF OR FEES AND YES WE WILL NOT
BE RAISING.
ANY STATE FEES ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
AND SO --
YEAH I I I KNOW THAT THAT IS SO
OFTEN -- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS --
THAT WE HEAR FROM MARK --
IN TERMS OF THE EVER.
INCREASING INCREASING COSTS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION AND I KNOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING.
TO SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
HEARING MORE MORE FROM STUDENTS
ABOUT HOW IT'S NOT THE TUITION
IT'S THIS THE LIVING COSTS AND
AND I KNOW THAT THAT IS A PART
OF THE OF FINANCIAL AID REFORM
THAT -- THE
CHAIR AND IN CHAIRMAN MEMBER
DANA ALSO OR ARE SEEKING TO
ADDRESS -- I
WANTED -- TO
GO BACK.
TO WELL --
GOING BACK TO THE ISSUE THAT --
WE WE TALKED ABOUT BRIEFLY
EARLIER ABOUT --
INCREASING ACCESS --
TO THE UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA --
HI I NOTED IN THE LA OWES REPORT
AND THAT --
IN IN FACT A FOR THE YEAR THE
UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA HAS --
APPARENTLY.
UNDERESTIMATED IN AND IS SINGS A
SUBSTANTIAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH --
IN.
THE UNDERGRADUATE --
ENROLLMENT --
AND SO I KNOW THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR --
SPECIFIED ALLOCATION FOR THE
OVER AND ROMANCE A IS THAT.
IN A PAUL TANO IS THAT FUNDING
GOING TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE OF
THE OVER ENROLLMENT.
IT'S PARTIALLY ADDRESSES IT BUT
IN IN POINT OF FACT.
WE HAVE ALL HAD --
OVER ENROLLMENT IN.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN IN. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN IN --
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND SO --
WHAT -- WE
ARE ASKING IS FULL FUNDING --
FOR THE MARGINAL COSTS OF THOSE
OVER AND ROLL STUDENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY. FOR THE MARGINAL COSTS OF
THE OVER ROLES TO WHICH IS A
ROUGHLY TEN THOUSAND PER STUDENT
OKAY [inaudible]
BUT YOU --
ARE ALSO --
YOU YOU INDICATED THAT YOU ARE
VERY PLEASED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN NEW ON GOING
FUNDING --
AND YET YOU'RE REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION ON TOP OF THAT THAT'S
RIGHT UNDER FORTY MILLION THAT'S
RIGHT OKAY AND A BIG PART OF
THAT IS --
FOR ENROLLMENT --
AND PART OF IT --
IS -- TO
CONVERT. ONE TIME MONIES THAT
WERE APPROPRIATED LAST YEAR IN
LIEU OF A TUITION INCREASE.
INTO AN ONGOING REVENUE STREAM
BECAUSE TUITION WOULD BE AN ON
GOING REVENUE STREAM.
AND ROUGHLY THE OTHER HALF OF
THE BULK OF IT IS FOR OVER
INVOLVEMENT.
AND WE WANT TO INCREASE NINETEEN
TWENTY AND AS WAS NOTED WE WERE
IN THIS WEIRD SITUATION WHERE.
ADMISSIONS DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE NOW WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
AND ROMAN FUNDING WE'RE GOING TO
GET IT WOULD BE NICE TO GET BACK
ON A CYCLE WHERE --
WE HAVE A YEAR LAG TIME --
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
RIFF --
REFORM TO THE BUDGET PROCESS --
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO ADD TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED UNDERGRADUATE AND
ONE THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENTS
TO THE UNIVERSITY WHEN WE NEED
ENROLLMENT FUNDING FOR THAT.
WHY WHY WITH THE THE COSTS OF
THE?
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT OF TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED UNDERGRADS AND AT
THOUSAND GRADUATE STUDENTS.
NOT BE COVERED BY THE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION AND THE
NEW ON GOING FUNDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
OF THE BILL --
BECAUSE THEY GET THE GOVERNOR
SPECIFIED WHAT THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY WOULD BE USED FOR AND
HE DID NOT INCLUDE THE
ENROLLMENT IN THAT NUMBER.
BUT I I THINK AS WE INDICATED TO
OR AT LEAST AS I INDICATED
EARLIER --
WHILE THAT --
IS TAKING A BIG THE GOVERNOR
SPECIFICATION.
I I THINK IT'S UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE FINE --
OUR PRIORITIES AND I THINK THAT --
TO AT LEAST IN RECENT YEARS WE
HAVE --
CONSISTENTLY EMPHASIZED.
ACCESS AN INCREASE ENROLLMENT --
WELL AT THE SAME TIME.
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT --
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING CARE OF OF OF
OF THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION FOR
CURRENT STUDENTS --
I A YEAH I I THINK I I I KNOW
THAT YOUR YOUR STAFF HAD --
TO COME TO MY OFFICE TO TRY TO
EXPLAIN [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
YOUR SIGNIFICANT --
GA REQUEST IN ADDITION TO THE
AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE VERY PLEASED
THAT'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND SO I LOOK --
FOR TO GETTING MORE DETAILS ON
HOW EXACTLY --
THOSE DOLLARS ARE --
TO BE JUSTIFIED THANK YOU ARE
GOOD.
MR DONNA BUT BEFORE I DO THAT
THING IS GOING TO ASK YOU TO MY
QUESTION JUMPING OFF THE OF OF
YOU GUYS SO.
I THINK THAT HE JUST HIT THE
ISSUE IS THAT.
THERE THE PRIORITIES THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TAX FINANCE PEOPLE
LAID OUT WOULD YOU GIVE THEM A
LIST OF ROUGHLY TEN THINGS AND
THEY FUNDED SEVEN OR SO.
AND SO THIS ONE WAS NOT ON THE
TO THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS OUGHT
TO US MOST ABOUT.
AND THAT YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO
TO PORTION SO WHETHER WE GET
LUCKY FIND TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
NEW IN MAY.
OR LOOK AT OTHER --
EXPENDITURES NAY JANUARY BUDGET
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK AND MAKE SURE
WE WE ADDRESS THIS YEAR.
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HAS --
BEEN IN ROLLING A RECORD NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
THAT'S A GOOD THING --
WHAT HASN'T BEEN SO GOOD AS WE
HAVE BEEN RECEIVING THE
ENROLLMENT FUNDING TO COVER ALL
THOSE NEW STUDENTS AND OVER TIME
THAT WILL AFFECT QUALITY YOU
MEAN THE MARGINAL COST ISN'T IT?
THAT'S RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY WE
REALLY NEED THIS COMMITTEE --
IF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT --
TO TO REALLY LOOK AT THE FUNDING
TO COVER THAT ENROLLMENT LET ME
JUST MAKE SURE REQUIRE CLEAR IN
THIS ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
AMOUNT PER STUDENT.
IS IT IS AN ACCURATE OR IN PRIOR
YEARS PRIOR YEARS WE HAVEN'T
COVERED --
THE MARGINAL COST OF THE
MARGINAL COST YES THE DIFFERENCE
COUPLE THOUSAND PER STUDENT.
TEN THOUSAND NOT THAT WE WERE
HAVING A TENER SELLING YOU SAY
IT'S TEN THE MARGINAL COST THE
STATE PORTION OF MARCIA COST IS --
TEN THOUSAND PER STUDENT YEAH.
NOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THE UC A SAYING THAT OUR
CALCULATION FOR THE MARGINAL
COST US OFF BY TEN OR SO PERCENT.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THE PRIOR YEARS WE DIDN'T COVER
THE STATE SHARE AND AS YOU KNOW
MISTER TING KNOWS.
WE MADE ARRANGEMENTS FOR THE UC
TO DO SOME RE DIRECTIONS IN
PRIOR YEARS AND THAT WAS.
ACCOUNTED FOR AND I THINK THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE ARGUED THAT THE
STATE SHOULD HAVE COVERED ALL
THAT BUT THOSE WERE OF THE
AGREEMENTS THAT WE MAY IN THE
PAST BY TWO YEARS.
WE WE CAN CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT.
YES YOU CAN GET IT ASK FOR MORE
THAT'S YOUR JOB.
YES THANK YOU --
MISTER WAS IT MEDINA O'DONNELL
MISTER O'DONNELL THANKS.
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND IT'S GOOD TO HAVE A TWO
THIRDS OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
LEADERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA LIVING
ON THE SEVENTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
RIGHT THERE --
BUT CLEAR JUST I JUST WANT TO
QUIT COMING HERE YOU I'M MOVING
BY THE WAY.
THAT YET [inaudible]
BUT I I KNOW I I APPRECIATE
LISTEN THIS THIS LEGISLATURE
ALONG WITH THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSE
YOU YOU KNOW TO TO ADDRESS THREE
THINGS REALLY VOLUME.
THE NUMBER STUDENTS GENERAL
VELOCITY.
HOW FAST YOU GET THEM THROUGH
AND ALSO YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
BUDGET UNDER VERY?
TIGHT BUDGET CONSTRAINTS JUST
ONE CONCERN I WANT 2% IS.
I THINK WE'VE DONE A GOOD YEAH I
I WANNA SHOULD TO ANY POTENTIAL
STUDENT BY THIS DEMAND THAT THEY
DO IT IN FOUR YEARS.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT FOR EVERY
STUDENT IT WASN'T FOR ME IT TOOK
ME.
SEVEN RIGHT FIVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO TO THE CSU --
YOU KNOW THAT'S I JUST HOPE THAT
WE'RE NOT BUYING INTO THAT JERRY
BROWN MANTRA THAT EVERY.
PERSON THAT'S WHERE THIS CAME
FROM LET'S BE HONEST AND THAT
WAS HIS LIFE EXPERIENCE.
RIGHT HE HAD --
HE HAD THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
GIVEN YOU KNOW WHAT GOD GAVE HIM
AND AND SOME MORE TO GET THROUGH
VERY QUICKLY.
AND AND I THINK THAT.
THE DEMAND THAT WE DO THAT IN
THAT EVERY STUDENT DO THAT I
THINK SAID CAN IMPOSE OUR VALUES
ON THEM.
BECAUSE STUDENTS HAVE A VARIETY
OF LIFE EXPERIENCES I COME FROM
HIGH SCHOOL.
WHERE A LOT OF OUR KIDS ARE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS THEIR
THEIR AYE LOW INCOME POPULATION
GREAT KIDS SOME OF GREAT
CHALLENGES?
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WERE
ACCOMMODATING THERE NEEDS.
TO AND NOT JUST TELLING THEM
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES A VARIETY DEMANDS --
DEMANDS YOU KNOW FROM THE HOME
FRONT WHERE THEY THEY MIGHT BE
FINANCIALLY MIGHT HAVE KIDS.
AND I I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN I LEAVING THEM OUT TO DRY
ARE NOT INVITING THEM IN. TO
FURTHER AT THEIR EDUCATION I I
KNOW YOU AGREE WITH ME BUT I
THINK THE EVEN THIS COMMITTEE
REALLY NEEDS TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW PROBABLY THE UC
STUDENTS PROBABLY VERY WELL
GEARED TO DO IT FOR YEARS ON
AVERAGE AND IT'S IT'S PRETTY
MUCH HAPPEN NOW.
THAT WHEN WE GO TO THE TO THE TO
THE TO THE TO THE TO THE CSU NOT
SO MUCH BECAUSE THEY BRING YOU
KNOW PROBABLY MORE LIFE
EXPERIENCE I'LL BE BLUNT WITH
YOU.
AND THEN CERTAINLY ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FRIENDS I JUST
DOES THIS COMMITTEE COLLEGE WHO
ARE AS IS COMMITTEE MOVES TOWARD.
I THINK WE WE NEED --
TO REALLY THINK ABOUT DIVERSITY
WITH A LOT OF DIVERSE SITUATIONS
AND NOT EVERY STUDENT COMES OUT
AT EIGHTEEN AND IT'S GONNA KNOCK
IT OUT IN FOUR YEARS AND QUITE
FRANKLY MAYBE THEY SHOULD.
SO WE JUST NEED TO KEEP AVENUES
OPEN FOR THEM AS WELL NUMBER
DONALD I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT I I THINK MY
RESPONSE TO TWO MEMBERS SEEM
LAME Là MORE ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION CURVE IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
NO THERE'S A FAMILY I KNOW WHO'S
OUR RUNNER VERY SUCCESSFUL
WEALTH BUSINESS IN SEAL BEACH.
AND THEY ONLY HIRE CAL STATE
STUDENTS WHO'VE TAKEN AT LEAST
SIX YEARS --
HONORED AGREE.
AND THE REASON THEY DO THAT IS
THOSE STUDENTS HAVE GREAT.
THEY HAVE PERSEVERANCE THEY HAVE
A DREAM IN A WILLING TO WORK
HARD AND THEY HAVE MORE LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
AND SO YOU KNOW THE STUDENT BODY
IS NOT A MONOLITH. ONE SIZE
DOESN'T FIT ALL.
AND IS MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
ACTUALLY PREFER STUDENTS WHO'VE.
GONE THROUGH SOME MORE BEFORE
THEY'RE READY.
TO AND THEY HAVE FANTASTIC
SUCCESS WITH THAT SO TO YOUR
POINT.
IF I CAN ADD TO THAT INSTANTLY
MOVING TO YOUR DISTRICT MEMBER
O'DONNELL I COULD PROBABLY SAY
THIS NOW.
BUT JUST REPRESENTATION WITHOUT
NO DOUBT IN MY IN FLORIDA.
BUT BUT I WE CERTAINLY DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THAT POINT OF VIEW
AND AND YOU AND I BOTH HAD I'M A
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE THAT.
LASTED MORE THAN FOUR YEARS AND
WITH THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE I WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY --
BUT WHAT WE WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT [inaudible]
OUR EITHER.
DESIGN ISSUES WITHIN OUR COLLEGE
OR ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE.
THAT CREATES A SITUATION WHERE
IT TAKES THEM LONGER THAN.
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE WANT --
TO IN SO --
IF A STUDENT NEEDS TO TAKE FIVE
YEARS TO TAKE SIX YEARS WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE THERE
FOR THEM AND DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN.
IN OUR POWER TO HELP THEM GET TO
THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE BECAUSE OF
THE ARTIFICIAL OR ARBITRARY OF
THINGS THAT WE DO AS COLLEGES.
THAT PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING
TO THAT EDUCATIONAL GOALS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO THAT IS
THE ONLY THING I'D SAY IN
ADDITION IS.
A YOU KNOW SOME STUDENTS WANT TO
FINISH AND SOME STUDENTS NEED TO
FINISH THE SOONER THEY GET INTO
THE ECONOMY THE BETTER IT IS FOR
THEIR FAMILIES SO WE WANT TO WE
WANT TO FIND A MIDDLE GROUND.
I THINK YOU'RE NOT WRONG BUT
YOU'RE NOT TOTALLY CORRECT --
AGAIN BECAUSE I I REALLY REALLY
GO BACK TO STUDENTS HAVING
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES --
EXPECTATIONS ON THEIR DAILY LIFE
I'D RATHER HAVE A A MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN COMPLETED AGREE AND
SEVEN YEARS AND BE HEALTHY.
THANK COMPLETELY AGREE IN FIVE
YEARS AND NOT BE HEALTHY AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE AS WE SHAPE
OUR POLICIES IN AS WE ALIGN OUR
FUNDING THAT WE'RE NOT PUSHING
PEOPLE TO HARD.
AS ALWAYS IT'S THEIR CHOICE.
THEIR CHOICE I GET THAT BUT
AGAIN THE LETTER WRITER CHOICE
OR THEY'RE NOT AT NOT BE OUR
MANDATE.
MR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
SO.
FIRST -- FOR
PRESIDENT PAULA TANTO --
IN DOLLAR.
THAT IS OUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS ALLOCATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR DEGREE
ATTAINMENT AND STUDENT SUCCESS.
YES WE WERE KIND OF TALK
ALLUDING TO EARLIER I MEAN YOU
GUYS ARE KIND OF ALREADY.
MEDIAN THE DEGREE ATTAINMENT --
ME AS FAR AS SOMEOF THE
DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD SO HOW
WOULD YOU PROPOSE USING.
THAT FIFTY MILLION THAT'S IN THE
PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SO EACH CAMPUS IS SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
GRADUATION OF FOUR YEAR IN RATES
ARE MUCH HIGHER AT BERKELEY AND
UCLA THEN SAY YOU SEE OR YOU SEE --
MERCED.
OF SO --
EACH CAMPUS HAS --
SUBMITTED --
PLANS FOR US AS TO WHAT THEY
WOULD DO. TO FACILITATE AND HELP
THERE'S STUDENTS GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS --
WHICH SOME OF THEM IT'S THINGS
LIKE SUMMER BRIDGE PROGRAMS --
IT INCLUDES ACADEMIC ADVISORS
AND INCLUDES.
ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTORS --
SOMETIMES IT IT MEANS OPENING UP
MORE CLASS SECTIONS SO THAT
THERE'S CLASS AVAILABILITY.
IT'S REALLY A CAMPUS SPECIFIC
SET OF PLANS [inaudible]
OKAY -- AND
THEN EMAIL.
DESPITE.
IT WOULD BE GOOD AS WE GET
FURTHER ALONG TO SEE MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFICS ON
THAT LIKE I SEE THE GENERAL
OUTLINES THERE BUT HE HAS A SAID
WHAT KIND OF MEDIAN THAT.
HERE AND I AND MY I THINK THE
QUESTION THAT PEOPLE NATURALLY
ASK IS HEY WOULD THAT BE BETTER
SPENT MAYBE ON THE MAY BE IN CS
YOU -- YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF HELPING THEM
WITH.
YES SOME OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
TRYING TO DO IN TERMS OF DEGREE
ATTAINMENT --
BUT THEN GET INTO THAT YOU KNOW
WE GO YEAH THAT'S ALREADY IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSED BUDGET FOR YOU.
BEFORE ASKING FOR ANOTHER
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION.
ON TOP OF THE TWO OR FORTY
MILLION THAT'S ALREADY PROPOSES
ONGOING FUNDING.
THE LAW THAT IS ON ON A ROAMING
GROWTH AND THIS IS JUST.
THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS YOU
KNOW YOU GUYS ARE ALREADY GOING
BEYOND.
YEAH YOU'RE OUR PULLING BEYOND
THE MASTER PLAN IN TERMS OF
ENROLLMENT --
WEIRD YOU'RE ACTUALLY OVER
APPROPRIATING --
IN TERMS OF YOUR COMING BACK AND
SAYING OKAY WE WENT OVER.
THAT AMOUNT --
AND AND I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHY
THAT'S YEAH REALLY OCCURRING BUT
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE GOING OVER
THERE AND AND AND THEN AT THE
SAME TIME.
SOME OF THE PERFORMANCE METRICS
THAT WE'VE BEEN THAT HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW FOR THE
LAST AT LEAST FOUR YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE.
STILL ARE BEING MET IN TERMS OF
PLACEMENT A RESIDENTIAL STUDENTS --
IN STATE STUDENTS AND CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP --
YOU KNOW WHY SHOULD WE CONTINUE
TO BASICALLY JUST.
RIGHT A BLANK CHECK THE YEAR
AFTER I'LL GET ALL BE AT THE
YEAR AFTER FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FOR YOU SEE --
YOU KNOW WHY SHOULD WHY SHOULD
WE TREAT YOU ANY DIFFERENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN I'M NOT SEEN.
YOU KNOW.
WE'RE NOT MEETING THOSE
BENCHMARKS FOR ENROLLING IN
STATE STUDENTS --
AND WE'RE NOT CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
ALL MEMBER GALLAGHER I I'M NOT
SURE.
WHAT YOU MEAN BY WE'RE NOT?
MEETING --
THE BENCHMARK FOR ENROLLING IN
STATE STUDENTS UNDER THE MASTER
PLAN THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
PERCENT IS TO ENROLL TWELVE AND
A HALF PERCENT OF THE FROM THE
TOP TWELVE AND A HALF PERCENT OF
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES AND WE'RE
TAKING FROM THE TOP.
OF THIRTEEN POINTS. THREE YEARS
6% -- BUT
WELL WELL BEYOND --
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE MASTER
PLAN -- WE
ARE OVER AND ROLLED BECAUSE THE
OUR YIELD FROM OFFERS OF
ADMISSIONS HAS BEEN HIGHER THAN
ANTICIPATED THERE'S A GREAT
DEMAND TO COME TO THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA --
TO GET A UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
DEGREE --
AND WHAT WE WHAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO DO OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND I THINK PART OF IT IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS MISMATCH.
BETWEEN WHEN --
THE LEGISLATURE SETS THE BUDGET.
AND WHEN WE ACTUALLY AND ADMIT
STUDENTS SO WERE.
SO YOU'RE SETTING A BUDGET FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY NOW --
AND THOSE ADMISSION DECISIONS
ARE ALREADY BEING MADE.
WE REALLY SHOULD BE TALING
ABOUT ENROLLMENT HERE.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE IF YOU
REALLY WANT TO BE ABLE --
TO TO GIVE US --
TARGETS BIG IS PART SCIENCE AND
IT'S PART PART AND WE HAVE
MODELS AND WE TRY --
TO IN ROLE THE NUMBER THAT WE
THINK WE'LL GET FUNDING.
FOR BUT BECAUSE OF THE DEMAND.
WE JUST HAVE BEEN OVERRULED THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
RABBIT CSU HANDLES THAT ISSUE
ZERO WEIGHTLESS SYSTEM RIGHT AND
THEY THEY TURN AWAY STUDENTS AND
BUT ESSENTIALLY COME BACK TO US
IT MAY REVISE AND SAY HEY HERE'S
WHO WE BLOOD IN.
AND WE'VE GOT AN ESTABLISHED
NUMBER FOR ENROLLMENT WELL WE
FUND WE'VE TRIED THAT OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS ON SUCCESSFULLY.
WELL OF THE WORKS WITH CSU I
DON'T REALLY SEE WHY IT WOULDN'T
WORK IN THE UC SYSTEM BUT I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO I MEAN LET'S LET'S SEE
SOME THE NECESSARY NEEDS TO
CONSIDER.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE IS CAPACITY
WHAT DO WE KNOW.
WHERE WE ARE AT CAPACITY IN THE
UC SYSTEM?
A WHICH CAMPUSES HAVE CAPACITY
TO GROW.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE AS SEEMS
LIKE WE STILL DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN SHARE WITH US TODAY.
SO THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES HAVE
DIFFERENT --
CAPACITY AND AND DIFFERENT
POTENTIAL FOR GROWTH --
SOME OF THE CAMP --
A UC BERKELEY ARE VERY
CONSTRAINED THEY'RE CONSTRAINED
GEOGRAPHICALLY --
AMONGST OTHER THINGS OTHER
CAMPUSES CAN CONTINUE TO GROW
MERCED IS GROWING RIVERSIDE IS
GROWING --
UC SAN DIEGO IS GROWING --
AND SO.
WE WE CAN PROVIDE THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WITH WHERE WE SEE
THE GROWTH OCCURRING ACROSS THE
UC CAMPUSES.
WELL IN THE END JUST JUST FOR ME
YOU KNOW I JUST HAVE A HARD TIME
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE YOU APPROVE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT YOU SEE
WITHOUT REALLY. TO ME HAVING
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY ON ON THESE
ISSUES THAT I KNOW OF HAVE
CONTINUALLY COME UP --
AND YEAH SO FOR ME YOU KNOW --
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO GO THROUGH A
BUDGET AND SAY AND JUST CONTINUE
TO ESSENTIALLY.
RIGHT THAT BLANK CHECK --
MORE MEMBER WE OFFER ADMISSION.
ANY STUDENT WHO MEETS OUR
ELIGIBILITY QUALIFICATIONS TAKE
THE A TO G. CLASSES [inaudible]
HAVE A THREO IN THOSE --
A TO G. CLASSES AND TAKE EITHER
THE SAT OR THE A. C. T..
WHAT WE ARE NOT ABLE TO DO IS
OFFER ADMISSION NECESSARILY TO
THE CAMPUS OF CHOICE FOR THAT
STUDENT?
BUT WE DO OFFER ADMISSION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO ALL
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS.
RIGHT UNDERSTAND THAT I'M JUST
SAYING THAT I THINK THAT THERE'S
A WAY TO GET THERE ON A AND TO
GET A A DEFINED NUMBER OF WHAT
THAT IS.
AS WE DO AND THE OTHER CAMPUSES
AS WE DO IN THE OTHER SEGMENTS
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM --
SO FOR CHANCER WHITE I DID HAVE
A QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S AND
INDICATED HIS INTENT FOR SOME OF
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNNY
TO BE UTILIZED FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES ON CAMPUS --
YOU'LL.
MAKE AN IMPORTANT ISSUE DO WE
KNOW HOW MANY THIS IS HAVE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES --
AND WOULDCSU BE LOOKING AT
UTILIZING THE FUNNY FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
OR FOR THE EXPANSION OF CHILD
CARE FACILITIES IN A BECAUSE AS
YOU SAID WE HAVE PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT.
VARIOUS LIFE EXPERIENCES
ATTENDING SCHOOLS AND YES IS ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT COMES UP.
SO MEMBER GALLAGHER THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION --
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES HAT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ONE HAVE SOME
WEATHER TO CHILD CARE CENTER OR
SOME WAY. TO PROVIDE A CHILD
CARE FOR OUR STUDENTS IN SOME
PLACES ARE EMPLOYEES --
BUT TWO THIRDS OF THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY DONE ON A SELF SUPPORT
BASIS -- OR
AN ENTERPRISE ONE ORIGINAL
REASONS REALLY NOT STATE
FACILITIES OR STATE RESOURCES
SUPPORTING THE STAFF THAT WORK
THERE.
SO THE THE REMAINING ONE THIRD
HAVE OF CHILDCARE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE TIED IN WITH OUR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS OR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS MAY GO AS LEARNING
PROCESS TO WORK WITH THESE
YOUNGSTERS IN THE CHILD CARE
CENTER.
SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS THEN OF
TAKING A LOOK AT THOSE THAT --
OF FALL UNDER THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT.
CAPABILITY TO SEE TO WHAT EXTENT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OR
EXPANSION THOSE FACILITIES ARE
NECESSARY.
SO I THINK THAT IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS WILL HAVE A BETTER
ANSWER FOR YOU BEFORE YOU GET TO
THE END OF THE THE BUDGET
PROCESS SO HERE IN THE SPRING
WE'RE DOING AN INVENTORY ON THE
STATE.
CONTROL PARTS OF THE I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THE THE MAJORITY
OF THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR WILL BE GOING TO
THE ACADEMIC SIDE OF THE CAMPUS --
BUT I CAN'T GIVE YOU A NUMBER
YET FOR THE CHILD CARE PEAS --
IT IS IMPORTANT AGAIN WITH A
POINTED MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS RAISING WITH.
A WITH SOME OF OUR STUDENTS WHO
HAVE A MORE OF LIFE TO MANAGE IN
ADDITION TO GOING TO SCHOOL.
THAT OF THESE ARE WAYS IN WHICH
WE CAN HELP REDUCE BARRIERS AND
SO THEY GET TO THEIR CLASS.
EXETER SO WE'LL BE GETTING MORE
REFINED DATA TO YOU BUT OVER ON
THE OVERALL SPEND OF THE TWO
FORTY SEVEN A SMALL PIECE OF IT.
BUT IMMEASURABLE AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OKAY.
I WILL MEMO CONTINUE AS WE GET
FURTHER INTO BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT -- AND
THEN LAST QUESTION SORRY MISTER
CHAIRMAN --
FOR CHANCELLOR OAKLEY ON THE ON
THE PROMISE PROGRAM --
ARE THERE ANY OUTCOME
MEASUREMENTS YOU KNOW GETTING
KIND OF INTO THIS PERFORMANCE
METRIC AGAIN.
ARE THERE ANY OUTCOME
MEASUREMENTS CURRENTLY TO
INDICATE THAT THE PROMISE
PROGRAM IS TO FILL IN ITS GOAL
[inaudible]
WELL IT'S AS FAR AS A CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE FROM IS IT'S DIFFICULT
TO BEGIN TO SEE THE OUTCOMES
BECAUSE IT WASN'T UNTIL THIS
LAST BUDGET.
THAT THE AB NINETEEN WAS FUND.
SO THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTATION NOW.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU?
IS WHERE COLLEGE PROMISE
INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED WHETHER IN LONG
BEACH OR IN OF INTER --
OR IN THE INLAND EMPIRE OR IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE'VE SEEN
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN TERMS OF
INCREASING THE NUMBER.
OF LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
THAT ATTEND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OR THEIR CSU WE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS THAT
SEAMLESSLY TRANSFER TO THEIR
LOCAL CSU AND THAT THE
GRADUATION RATES OF THOSE
TRANSFER STUDENTS CONTINUES TO
INCREASE.
WE'VE SEEN THAT --
THIS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY CAN SEE THAT THERE
DOLLARS ARE GOING DIRECTLY TO
COVERING THE COST OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE NOT THE COST OF TUITION.
SO UNDER THOSE MEASURES WE WHICH
WE ANTICIPATE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE WILL
HAVE SIMILAR RESULTS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE AND BE HAPPY TO BE.
TO BRING YOU THOSE --
OUTCOMES IN IN FUTURE YEARS I
MEAN THAT ARE YOU GUYS PLANNING
TO DEVELOP CERTAIN METRICS AND
TRACKING OKAY THESE ARE STUDENTS
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
ATTENDED --
NEO COMMUNITY COLLEGE THERE NOW
DOING IT BECAUSE OF THE PROMISE
PROGRAM AND THEN TRACKING.
OKAY AND DO THEY GET TO WRITE.
THE CREDENTIAL OR OTHERWISE
RIGHT --
JUST SO THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO COME BACK AND GO OKAY YOU
KNOW HEY THIS IS ACTUALLY.
YEAH FOR FILLING RIGHT AT THE
POLICY GOAL THAT I THINK WAS
BEHIND THAT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WELL I'D SAY WE ALREADY HAVE
SEVERAL MEASURES IN PLACE --
THAT WE ARE --
THAT I'VE MENTIONED SO FOR
EXAMPLE --
DECREASING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
THAT EXISTS WE THINK THAT.
IF IMPLEMENTED WELL THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISED --
INITIATIVE WILL --
ADVANCES EFFORTS BECAUSE FOR A
COLLEGE TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
FUNDS THEY HAVE TO BE PUT INTO
PLACE THE GUIDED PATHWAYS
FRAMEWORK THEY HAVE TO BE CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND HAVE TO
BE.
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF AID
THAT GOES TO THOSE FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE PROMISES PART OF AN
UMBRELLA OF A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES.
AIMED TO REDUCE THOSE GAPS
SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD WANT TO
SEE THE NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS COMING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE --
NETTLE INCREASE BY INCREASE IN
TERMS OF DIVERSITY AN INCREASE
IN TERMS OF THEIR OUTCOME SO
THOSE ARE CERTAINLY MEASURES
THAT WE WOULD ANTICIPATE.
WOULD INCREASE AND THOSE ARE
MEASURES THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
RIGHT NOW --
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
WHEN THAT THAT SOME I WOULD LIKE
YOU KNOW THAT MAYBE WE COULD SEE
IN SOME FUTURE HEARINGS IS JUST
HOW THOSE ARE BEING DIRECT AND
OBVIOUSLY I REALIZE IN THIS IS
JUST GET ENOUGH THE GROUND --
BUT I'LL SEE FOR ME I THINK YOU
GUYS CAN ALSO BE --
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IN
PERFORMANCE AND HOW THE MONEY IS
ACTUALLY UTILIZE IN ARE WE
GETTING.
THE RESULTS THAT WE WANT IS
IMPORTANT TO ME SO.
ABSOLUTELY MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU I I HAVE A MY FINAL
QUESTION BEFORE WE GET TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
JUST A QUICK ONE FOR THE
COMMUNICATIONS IS THAT.
WE'LL TALK MORE IN A CAR HEARING
ABOUT THAT THE PROMISE PROGRAM.
BUT THERE WAS A REPORT THAT CAME
OUT I THINK BY.
IT'S SOURCE OR CAL MATTERS ONE
OF THAT PUBLICATION'S RECENTLY.
THEY DID THEIR OWN SURVEY SURVEY
RIGHT THE COLD CALLED OR WHAT
HAVE YOU.
AT THE YOU KNOW TWO DOZEN
DISTRICTS AND FOUND SOME
INTRIGUING --
EXPENDITURES AND I'M NOT SURE I
THINK IT JUST WARRANTS FURTHER
INVESTIGATION SO I'M ASKING YOU.
TO COME BACK AND BE PREPARED AS
MISTER GALLAGHER SAID TO TALK
ABOUT WE SUPPORT THE THE AYE
THAT THE PROGRAM AT YOUR REQUEST
WE PUT IN SOME OF THESE ELEMENTS
TO MAKE SURE THEY NOT JUST.
FREE BUT HAVE SOME YOU KNOW
GUIDED PATHWAYS OTHER ELEMENTS
TO SUCCESS WHICH TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S DOING WHAT WE WANT TO
DO AND IF NECESSARY.
POTENTIALLY --
TINKER WITH THAT.
SO -- I
WANNA ASK BRIEFLY ON WHAT MISTER
GALLAGHER ASKED YOU PRESENT
BUILT ON ON THAN NON RESIDENT
STUDENT ISSUE.
YOU KNOW WE YOU KNOW WORKED OUT
THIS ISSUE AND FRANKLY BATTLE
THIS ISSUE FOR A FEW YEARS BUT
PUT THE ISSUE TO REST.
CHECK CHECK HIRED CHAIRMAN
DENIED --
WORK TO LEGISLATION WEIRD
SUPPORT OF MR TING AND I WORKED
WITH YOUR TEAM TO COME UP WITH.
AN ACCORD THAT THE REGENTS --
ADOPTED IN WHICH YOU THINK IS IS
A FAIR PLAN I KNOW THE SENATE
NOW IS ASKING TO CONSIDER GOING
DOWN 210% --
NON RESIDENT SO WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO SOME OF THE THIS IS --
EXCEEDED THE THE THAT NICK
NUMERIC NUMBER WHICH WE SET IN
PLACE AS AS A FAIR.
MIDDLE GROUNDS AND THAT THAT
WASN'T WHAT WE HAD.
READ UPON.
AS FAR AS A STATE POLICY AND I
ASSUME THAT YOU WORK --
PLEASE BY THAT AND SO I WANTED
TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
TALK AS FAR AS HOW WE GOT HERE
AND AND HOW DO WE PREVENT THIS
IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE YOU
KNOW WENT TO KEEP CREEPING
CREEPING UP FOR A REASON.
YEAH I'M NOT HAPPY ABOUT IT
CANNOT BE ABOUT IT EITHER IT'S
MISTER CHAIR --
THREE OF OUR CAMPUSES --
BERKELEY YOU SHOWING DAVIS
EXCEEDED THEIR AGREED UPON --
CAP NOW BY A SMALL AMOUNTS ALL
LESS THAN 1%.
OF AND SO --
TO AND IN PART OF THAT IS AS I
WAS.
MENTIONING THE MEMBER GALLAGHER
ADMISSIONS IS PART ART PART
SCIENCE AND AND YOU YOU TRY TO
GET THE OFFERS OF ADMISSION AND
THE YIELD TO MARRY UP WITH THE
AGREED UPON CAP AND THOSE THREE
CAMPUSES WENT A BIT OVER. TO
REMOVE ANY FINANCIAL INCENTIVE --
FOR CAMPUSES --
TO EXCEED THEIR AGREED UPON CAP.
OF WE ARE GOING --
TO RETAIN IN TUITION THE THOSE
CAMPUSES WOULD HAVE RECEIVE.
AND DISTRIBUTE THEM SYSTEM WIDE
TO BASIC NEEDS FOR OUR
UNDERGRADUATES.
GOOD SOLUTION.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE NON
RESIDENT TUITION WE'RE VERY
ADVERSE TO INCREASING FEES FOR
CALIFORNIANS BUT FOR YEAH
WEALTHY PEOPLE ARE CALIFORNIANS
SOMETHING WE HAD DIFFERENT
OPINIONS --
THERE'S BEEN CONCERN THAT IF WE
KEEP INCREASING AND NON RESIDENT
TUITION.
THERE'D BE A DECLINING PEOPLE
PLAYING.
BUT WE'VE WE'VE HAD THESE
INCREASES I THINK THREE LASTS
FOR YEARS MAYBE FOR LAST.
FOUR YEARS AND WE HAVEN'T HAD
THAT MUCH OF A DECLINE THERE'S A
BIT OF A DECLINE IN YOU KNOW.
THERE WAS SPECULATION THAT IT
WAS THE PRESIDENCY DECLARE WHAT
HAVE YOU BUT WE WE SEEN IT
SOMEWHAT FLAT AND SO.
IS THAT POTENTIALLY ON THE TABLE
TO CONTINUE.
TO INDEX THAT.
FEE AND USE THAT MONEY FOR
POTENTIALLY CALIFORNIA IN A
MOMENT YES WE'RE GOING TO BE.
ASKING THE BOARD OF REGENTS NEXT
WEEK TO APPROVE A TWO POINT 6%
INCREASE TO THE NON RESIDENT
STUDENT TUITION --
WHICH BASICALLY HOLDS THEM ON
RESIDENTS IN TUITION FLAT IN
TERMS OF CONSTANT DOLLARS AND
INDEXING WOULD BE ANOTHER WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT.
BUT THOSE.
NON RESIDENT STUDENT TUITION --
TO THE CAMPUS THE ONE I GO.
TO FIVE AND THEN USE THAT. TO TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN EXPAND SOME
MORE SLOTS AT EACH OF THE NINE
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES ARE
BECAUSE WE'RE VERY CONSCIOUS
THAT WE'RE REACHING --
A PRICE POINT THAT'S MY POINT IS
WE DID INCREASE A ONE YEAR EIGHT
ONE YOU'RE.
FIVE AND WE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE A
DROP OF PEOPLE STILL CONTINUE TO
APPLY.
BUT I THINK IT IS --
THE RECORD THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT -- NINE
RESIDENTS IN TUITION UNDER THE
TWO POINT 6% PLAN WILL BE GOING
UP SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
DOLLARS IT'LL BE OVER.
FORTY ONE THOUSAND AT THAT POINT --
AND WERE REALLY CLOSE TO SOME OF
THE THE PRIVATE YOUR TEAM COME
BACK AND TALK TO US ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT THAT --
WARRANTS FURTHER.
EVALUATION.
ZERO OKAY I WITH THAT.
MR TING.
THANK YOU MISTER SO --
JUST AS START WITH TRANSFER
OAKLEY --
WITH APPRECIATE ALTHOUGH ALL THE
WORK THAT NOT JUST THE CHANCE
OKAY BUT ALL THE SYSTEMS HAVE
DONE A REGARDING THE TRANSFER
STUDENT RATE I KNOW THAT --
THAT DID PUT SOME SOME PRESSURE
ON ALL THE SYSTEMS AND JUST
WANTED.
TO HEAR FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
HOW THE GIVEN THE SORT OF A TWO
ONE RATIO THAT WAS SENT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO.
A SO -- YEAH
I I'M I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT --
PRESIDENT APOLLO TUNNEL AND I
SIGNED --
ANIMAL YOU RECENTLY. TO CONTINUE
OUR WORK AROUND TRANSFER AND
PARTICULARLY AROUND --
LOOKING AT NOT ONLY HOW WE
INCREASE TRANSFER HOW WE USE
EXISTING ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER FRAMEWORK THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE CSU. TO FOLD THAT INTO
THE UC AS WELL I KNOW THAT --
THE ECONOMIC CENTER OF THE
UNIVERSE YOUR CALIFORNIA LOOKING
AT THAT AND WORKING WITH US SO
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THAT WILL.
COME TO FRUITION --
CLEARLY --
CAPACITY AT THE CSU AND THE UC
ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN --
AN APPROPRIATE MANDATE TO
IMPROVE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
TO TRANSFER FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
WERE HOPEFUL THAT AS WE CONTINUE
TO PUSH ON THOSE TRANSFER THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE ROOM AT THE
INN AT THE CSU IN THE UC.
NOW WE HAVE ALSO BEEN WORKING
WITH A I SEE SEE YOU --
TO SIGN AN ANIMAL YOU WITH THEM
AS WELL --
AND WE NEED THEM TO INCREASE OUR
TRANSFER CAPACITY AS WELL
BECAUSE IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
INCREASING TRANSFER AS WE SAY
WE'RE GOING TO BE --
WE NEED ALL THE SEGMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S ROOM SO --
OUR COLLEGES ARE DOING WHAT
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO DO.
THEY'RE INCREASING THE
PREPAREDNESS OF OUR STUDENTS
THEY'RE GOING TO PREPARE THEM TO
TRANSFER IN LARGER NUMBERS SO
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WILL MAKE SURE AND
HAVE THE TRANSFER CAPACITY THAT
WE NEED.
NO IT'S GREAT ÁI DIçN I
JUST MET WITH SOME YOU KNOW.
HIS HISTORIC ONGOING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CITY COLLEGES
SEVERANCE RECORDS SO I THINK --
THERE THERE ARE PLENTY OF MODELS
OUT THERE. TO TO ENSURE THAT
THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN --
I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
SEPARATE HEARING ON CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THAT --
WOULD LOVE YOUR EYES YOUR TEAM
CAN PREPARE TO THE HEARING
REALLY TRY TO GET AS MUCH ROBUST
FEEDBACK ON HOW THAT'S GOING.
ESPECIALLY BY COLLEGE BY REGION
SEEING SEEING REALLY --
WHAT SUCCESS STORIES ARE OUT
THERE I THINK I WANT ONE OF THE --
IT WE FEEL LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
SUCCESS.
IN THE MORE URBAN PARTS OF THE
STATE AND WE WE FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE THERE AREN'T AS MANY
SUCCESS STORIES IN THE MORE
INLAND PART OF THE STATE.
SO WITH SO WE CONTINUE TO BE
VERY INTERESTED. TO SEE --
HOW DO HOW DO WE LINK THE AS
ECONOMICALLY AS A SHIP?
SO -- YEAH
THAT'S JUST A JUST A POINT OF
REFERENCE FOR YOU AND YOUR TEAM.
CANCER LIKE YOU YOU AND I HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT THIS A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER TODAY WHEN
YOU CAN STOP BY THE OFFICE.
ON THE AND JUST AND JUST TO SORT
OF STATE FOR THE RECORD I KNOW
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WE'VE BEEN.
SORT OF ASKING FOR IMPROVEMENT
ON THE THIRTY THOUSAND CSU
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
WHO --
HAVEN'T FOUND A HOME WITHIN THE
SYSTEM WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU AND THEN THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WORKING WITH US.
TO ESTABLISH A REDIRECTION
POLICY SIMILAR TO WHAT THE UC
HAS AND REALLY AS I KIND OF
REITERATE EARLIER TODAY REALLY
HOPE THAT THE SYSTEM CAN BE MUCH
MORE AGGRESSIVE.
ON HOW TO REDUCE THAT NUMBER
THAT NUMBER STARTED AT FIRST
DURING THE THE BUDGET CUTS THAT
THAT WERE FAIRLY DRACONIAN --
BUT BE GIVEN GIVEN THE LAST. SIX
YEARS -- YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S CONCERNING THAT
THERE REALLY HASN'T BEEN MUCH
MOVEMENT OFF THAT NUMBER WHEN.
I I KNOW THAT OVER THE YEARS AND
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN --
SOURCE TESTIMONY SAYING HEY
WE'RE WE WE'VE GOT UNDER CONTROL
FOR MAKING PROGRESS.
AND DO JUST WANT TO ALLOW YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY OR JUST COMMENT
ON THAT.
YEAH -- AND
I APPRECIATE I THINK THE THE
REDIRECTION POLICY YOU KNOW WE
ARE.
INSTITUTING AT THIS YEAR SO COME
APRIL FIRST --
WILL BE WHEN WE KNOW HOW MANY
STUDENTS WHO HAVE APPLIED TO
THEIR THERE ARE CHOICES ARE
GETTING IN.
OF A WILL BE CONTACTED AND GIVEN
THIRTY FIVE DAYS I THINK IN
ORDER.
TO TAKE OTHER CAMPUSES THERE IN
OUR REGION.
IF THEY DON'T RESPOND A THIRTY
FIVE DAYS WILL PICK'EM FORUM AND
LET THEM KNOW --
AT NO ADDITIONAL COST TO TRY AND
GET THEM TO GO WE DO KNOW THAT A
STUDENT WHO CAN'T GET INTO LONG
BEACH STATE --
FOR FAMILY OR ECONOMIC REASONS
MAY NOT WANT TO GO OR BE ABLE TO
GO TO HUMBLE STATE WHERE THERE'S
ROOM -- SO
THERE ARE SOME REGIONAL
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE WILL FIND
OUT.
WHO WERE WERE ENTHUSED ABOUT
THIS --
REDIRECTION POLICY WE RETAIN
SOME OF THE RESOURCES THAT --
WERE AWARDED LAST YEAR THE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ENROLLMENT FUNDING. TO BE
SPENT OVER FOUR YEARS AT ONE
TIME FUNDING OVER FOUR YEARS.
SO WE'VE WE'VE DISTRIBUTED SOME
OF THAT A RESOURCES THIS YEAR
WHICH HAS BEEN TERRIFIC.
BUT WE'RE WAITING TO SEE WHAT
KIND OF EXPERIENCE WE HAVE HERE.
A WITH RESPECT REDIRECTION IS
GOING TO BE THIS OR IS IT GOING
TO BE THIS.
AND SO WERE WILL BE ABLE TO
WHATEVER IT IS WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT MONEY FOLLOWS THE
STUDENTS WHO MOVE TO ANOTHER
CAMPUS.
THE OTHER PART I THINK OF THE OF
THE THIRTY THOUSAND IS THAT OF
THE NUMBER OF OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE OF
GOT UP.
AND WITH ADMITTED.
VIED OFFERS OF ADMISSION TO MORE
STUDENTS HE'S GOT LIKE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE HERE YOU KNOW WE
SPEND MONEY ON IT BUT THE
DEFERRED MEANS KEEPS GOING UP
AND SO.
AS PART OF WHY THAT THIRTY
THOUSAND NUMBER EBBS AND FLOWS --
OF THAT THIRTY THOUSAND NUMBER
THERE'S SOME AGO BACK TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR SOME WILL
GO. TO A PRIVATE GROUP OR GO OUT
OF STATE OF EIGHT OR TEN
THOUSAND SOON TO ACTUALLY GO
INTO A BLACK HOLE AND IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA IS A GOOD
FOR ANYBODY AYE.
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING
BETTER HERE SO I APPRECIATE THE
POINT.
NO I THINK IT'S DISTANT SO I
CALLED BACK ON MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER DOWN ON INTO THE WHOLE
POINT IS JUST TO GIVE THAT
PERSON CHOICES OBVIOUSLY IF YOU
MAKE AN OFFER THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
THAT'S THEIR COMPLETE RIGHT A
BIT THE DUST.
HERE WE'RE TRYING TO FULFILL OUR
RESPONSIBILITY INTO THE MASTER
PLAN.
ON TO TO FOLLOW UP FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLS JUST
DISCUSSION ON THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE I KNOW THAT.
YOU WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE MY IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET OR GUESTS AND THIS
THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR'S
BUDGET.
DO YOU CAN YOU --
TELL US HOW THAT MONEY IS BEING
SPENT OR MAYBE YOUR STAFF CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH WITH A LIST OF
WHERE THAT WHERE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
WHAT WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
SPECIFICS BY CAMPUS BY BY
BUILDING BY PROJECT?
YOU KNOW THAT WE SEE ABOUT FOUR
BILL TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT TERRY
IN PEACE WE DON'T WANNA ON THE
CAMPUS WITH THE MOST BIGGEST
LIST WE WANT TO MAKE SURE ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES.
BENEFIT WONDERS OF THIS KIND OF
A RESOURCE AVAILABLE --
AND SO --
WILL BE ABLE TO GET TO THE DATA.
YOU KNOW I SOMETIMES WHEN WE
START TALKING IN BIG NUMBERS
HERE USE OR ABUSE HARD TO
REALIZE BUT I'D.
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT ARE
SQUARE FOOTAGE IN THIS YEAR'S
YOU WOULD BE EQUAL TO ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED FOOTBALL
FIELDS.
AND SO IF YOU JUST WANT CLOSE
YOUR EYES AND IMAGINE EMILY IT
THAT'S A LOT OF SPACE IT NEEDS
SEISMIC UPGRADES AND H. FACT
WATER MEAN ALL THE BASIC STUFF
IT'S NOT PUTTING IN.
GOLD WALLS AND FANCY CARPET IS
DOING THE BASIC STUFF SO WE'LL
GET TO THE LIST NONCHALANTLY I
THINK.
HEY I APPRECIATE THE EGALITARIAN
SENSE OF THAT BUT I ALSO --
ONE INSURE THAT YOU'RE
PRIORITIZING AGAIN Q. U. S.
CAMPUSES THAT OPENED AT
DIFFERENT DATES SOME ARE OLDER
THAN OTHERS.
IT OBVIOUSLY SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NOT FOR ANY
FAULT OF A PARTICULAR
INSTITUTIONS JUST THEIR OLDER.
SO --
HOPEFULLY THERE'S SOME SENSE OF
PRIORITIZING BY WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A GROUP HERE THAT CREATES A
VERY SOPHISTICATED ANALYSIS A
LOOKS AT AGE.
LOOKS AT USE CAPACITY LOOKS A
WEAR AND TEAR.
SOME OF THE BUILDINGS ARE ALL
THAT OLD ON THE CALENDAR
[inaudible]
BUT ARE WORN OUT.
IN OTHER CAMPUSES OF SAN MARCOS
HAS A LOT OF NEW BUILDINGS AND
SO THEY DON'T GET AS MUCH FOR
THEIR BUILDINGS WERE BUILT IN
LAST FOR THREE TO FIVE TEN YEARS
SO.
YOU KNOW.
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE HERE
GREAT.
AND THEN I THINK IN THE IN
REGARDS TO THE JEWS JUSTICE.
FOLLOW UP TO MARK MY CALLING MY
PREVIOUS CALLING THE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN MILLION THAT'S ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF IF THAT WERE
APPROPRIATED TO GET A LIST OF
WHERE.
WHERE YOU WOULD --
BE SPENDING THAT.
WE CAN PRODUCE THAT RIGHT AWAY
TO HAVE A GREAT.
ARMED.
AND I THINK --
CHANCELLOR AND IMPRISONED
POLIDORO --
MY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
KIND OF REITERATED OUR CONCERN
AROUND A NON RESIDENT ROLE NOT
REALLY APPRECIATE I THINK YOUR
YOUR YOUR SOLUTION THINGS VERY
ARTFUL MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND
I THINK --
WE WE APPRECIATE --
IN A SENSE THAT WE YOU KNOW WE
ARE REALLY WANTING TO ENSURE
THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CONTINUE
TO REMAIN A PRIORITY.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND AS IF YOU
WOULD MENTION THAT ADMISSIONS
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA IF IF YOU
CAN HIT A TARGET IT'S VERY HARD
TO BE VERY PRECISE YOU'RE YOU'RE
GONNA BE UNDER OVER YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO BE ON IT.
THIS OF THESE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS --
OCCUR BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT IN THE HOPE.
IS THAT WE REALLY --
CONTINUE TO SEE AGAIN ALL THE
CAMPUS IS HAVING A FOCUS ON ON
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THEY'RE REALLY TRYING.
TO MANAGE THE OUT OF STATE IN
ROME I KNOW THAT EVERY
CHANCELLOR.
REALLY LIKES THE FREEDOM OF THE
OUT OF STATE.
TUITION BUT IT ALSO --
YOU KNOW I THINK IT COMES AT A
COST IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR US.
TO CONTINUE TO SEE SUCH HIGH OUT
OF STATE AND ROMAN WHEN --
IN WHEN THEY'RE WHEN WE CONTINUE
TO TRY.
TO INCREASE OUR FUNDING REQUEST
BUT THE SAME TIME TO BE ENOUGH
SPOTS FOR IN OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND OUR OUR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES.
I'M SO TO KIND OF JUST ALONG THE
LINE SAY THE SAME THING THAT I
HAVE STRESS TENSOR WHY WAS JUST
TO GET A LIST OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE --
ITEMS THAT ARE BEING SPENT ON
FOR FOR THIS CURRENT CALENDAR
YEAR.
ARE FOR THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
AND THEN ALSO THE LIST FOR THEM
FOR THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION THAT YOU WOULD WOULD YOU
WOULD WANT TO SPEND I MEAN I
KNOW THAT IT'S IT'S YEAH GIVE A
MUCH LARGER LESS THAN THAT --
BUT IT WOULD JUST BE GOOD TO IF
YOU GOT THAT APPROPRIATION WHERE
WHERE IT WOULD GO AND TO TO WHAT
IT WOULD BE.
FOR WILL GET THAT TO YOU --
BEFORE I THINK THE NEXT HEARING
IS MARCH NINETEENTH THERE'S SO
WILL MAKE SURE YOU HAVE IT IN
HAND BY THEM THAT THAT BE GREAT
I THINK.
I THINK I'VE I'VE MENTIONED THIS
TO EACH OF THE THREE OF YOU
SEPARATELY I KNOW THAT.
AGAIN THIS ISSUE OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE HAS BEEN SOMETHING
THAT YOU'VE EACH TALK TO ME
ABOUT FOR PROBABLY THE LAST
THREE YEARS AND I THINK WE'LL BE.
TALKING ABOUT --
FOR AS LONG AS I'M AROUND AS
LONG AS YOU'RE YOU KNOW FROM --
THE STATE BUDGET POINT GREAT FOR
THE SYSTEMS TO KIND OF COME
TOGETHER AND I KNOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAM.
BUT TO AT LEAST COME TOGETHER SO
WE HAVE A HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT.
THE THE NEED IS AND HOW BIG IN
THE EIGHTIES AND AND SORT OF
WHERE THE NEED IS I KNOW THAT
THERE'S THOUGHT THAT YOU MAY GO --
FORWARD WITH THE BOND AND AND
AND TRY TO RAISE MONEY THAT WAY
WHICH YOU KNOW I THINK I THINK
IT'S VERY SMART AND MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE.
BUT I THINK THIS IS ALSO GETTING
YOUR TRIP TO REALLY HIGH THINK
HIGHLIGHT THIS ISSUE --
ESPECIALLY AS WE WERE YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR I THINK VERY
SMARTLY --
AND WE AGREE WITH THIS APPROACH
IS HAS REALLY FOCUSED ON ONE
TIME FUNDING.
AND THIS IS I THINK A VERY GOOD --
VERY GOOD APPROPRIATIONS FOR ONE
TIME FINDINGS I THINK THIS THIS
YEAR IS A GOOD YEAR.
TO HAVE THAT [inaudible]
DISCUSSION INDEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY
TODAY AND WE'LL SEE YEARS
SEGMENTS BACK IN THE COMING
WEEKS THEY'RE GOOD THANK YOU SIR
WITH THAT WE WILL PROCEED WITH
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
LINED UP OVER HERE.
ON THE SIDE
[inaudible]
MAMA [inaudible]
SO.
THE JOYS OF CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PLEASE BEGIN.
HELLO PROFESSOR HOW ARE YOU SIR
HOW MANY HAVE YOU LEAD OFF LEAD
BY EXAMPLE. FOR EVERYBODY QUIET
DOWN THE ROOM PLEASE
[inaudible]
CHANCELLOR PRESIDENT.
IN THE CASE OF OUR AREA.
THANK YOU PROJECTS YES PROFESSOR
YOU CAN LEAD BY EXAMPLE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO SIXTY SECONDS
OR LESS EVERYBODY CAN FOLLOW
YOUR LEAD THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MCCARTY
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS SEASONAL CANTON I'M
THE ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT --
FOR FRONT OF ACTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY SENSATION THE
FACULTY MEMBER AT CAL STATE
SACRAMENTO.
SEE THE CALIFORNIA FACT
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE OVERALL
FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE CSU
HOWEVER WE REQUEST THAT THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO BE SET
ASIDE TO HIRE NEW FOR TENURE
TRACK FACULTY IN THE CSU.
THIS MONEY WOULD RESULT RESULT
IN APPROXIMATELY THREE REQUIRE
THE CSU TO PROVIDE AN ALLOCATION
PLAN BY OCTOBER OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE PROVIDED COMMITTEE
STAFF WITH BUDGET LANGUAGE FOR
THIS REQUEST.
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO FULL TIME
TENURE TRACK PROFESSORS HARMS
THE STUDENTS WHO RELY ON CSU FOR
QUALITY PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
TURNOVER AMONG LECTURE AFFECT
THESE HIGH IF THEY MUST
NATURALLY SEARCH FOR LONG TERM
STABLE TEACHING POSITIONS.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
THE HIVE TENURE TRACK FACULTY
FOR APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
NEW FACULTY SYSTEM WIDE.
THIS WAS A GREAT STEP FORWARD
BUT NOT ENOUGH THE REQUEST FOR
THIRTY FIVE MILLION REFLECTS A
PROPORTIONAL INCREASE BASED ON
LAST YEAR'S NEW ONGOING FUNDING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU FIFTY NINE SECONDS.
I'LL TRY AND MATCH THAT --
ENTER HEARD SOFT DEPARTMENT
POLITICAL SCIENCE AT SACRAMENTO
STATE ALSO WITH THE CFA TODAY
ONE OF OUR OTHER REQUESTS IS
THAT WHILE WE ARE PLEASED WITH
THE OVERALL FUNDING LEVELS AND I
DON'T THINK WE SAID THAT IN.
THE ENTIRE TIME I'VE BEEN HERE --
THE CFA REQUEST THE TWENTY
MILLION BE SET ASIDE IN OCTOBER
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SPECIFICALLY
TO REACH A RATIO OF ONE FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT COUNSELOR FOR
EVERY FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS.
ON ALL THE CAMPUSES EIGHTEEN
MILLION TO GO TO THOSE
COUNSELORS TWO MILLION FOR A
PORTING REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
QUESTIONS OF SUCH AS HOW MANY
SUICIDES FOR CAMPUS MENTAL
HEALTH SURVEYS --
THERE'S BEEN A GROWING CRISIS
THESE ARE THE NUMBERS OF RATIOS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED BY.
THE INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COUNSELING SERVICES WHILE THERE
IS A SET ASIDE IN THE UC'S
BUDGET THE CSU HAS NOT ELSE FOR
THIS WE THINK THAT IT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE THERE.
CERTAINLY AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL SUGGESTED THE HEALTH
OF OUR OVERALL STUDENTS IS
IMPORTANT IT'S A QUESTION WITH
STUDENT SUCCESS I CAN TELL YOU.
THAT THERE WERE FIVE SUICIDES
STAFF COUNSELORS AND ALL.
THEY CAN AND WHERE WE LOOK INTO
THAT WITH THAT MENTAL HEALTH ACT
PROP SIXTY THREE SO THANK YOU.
I AM HERE ARE REPRESENTING JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
RECEIVING FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL TO INVEST TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
IN ADDRESSING STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS.
IN TODAY'S ECONOMY WE KNOW THE
POST SECONDARY CREDENTIAL IS
ESSENTIAL AND YET YOU
DISPARITIES REMAIN AND WHO HAS
ACCESS TO A COLLEGE DEGREE.
CONTRIBUTING TO THIS DISPARITIES
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS HAVING A
CRISIS IN HOMELESSNESS AMONG ITS
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
CLOSE 220% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AND THE SAME IS TRUE 411% OF CSU
STUDENTS.
DESPITE THIS REALITY CALIFORNIA
LACKS ANY TARGETED INTERVENTION
TO ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND INVESTMENT
OF TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
ENABLE THE THREE POST SECONDARY
SYSTEMS TO PARTNER WITH HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS. TO QUICKLY
MOVE STUDENTS INTO HOUSING
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT COLLEGE
RETENTION COLLEGES WOULD ALSO BE
SUPPORTED TO ESTABLISH REFERRAL
PATHWAYS TO LOCAL HOUSING
RESOURCES.
AND ENSURE THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING ALL
POSSIBLE FINANCIAL AID I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BUDGET REQUEST THANK YOU.
RASHEEDA CRUTCHFIELD ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR IN THE SCHOOL OF
SOCIAL WORK AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH AND A
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR FOR THE
CSU STUDY.
ON BASIC NEEDS EXPLORING FOOD
SECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS FOR
OUR STUDENTS.
AS MENTIONED 11% OF OUR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AND THIS
IS DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
A NUMBER OF OUR STUDENT GROUPS --
MOST STARTLING 18% FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS.
IN COLLECTING DATA ACROSS THE
STATE I'VE SPOKEN TO SO MANY
STUDENTS WHO ARE LIVING IN THEIR
CARS ARE LIVING IN TENTS.
ARE LIVING IN FARMS ARE LIVING
IN STE MOVING FROM PLACE TO
PLACE HAVING VERY DRAMATIC
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON THEIR
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH.
A SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT REALLY IS A CONNECTION
BETWEEN HOUSING.
AND HIGHER EDUCATION INVESTMENT
IN OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
PERSISTING IN ORDER TO DO WHAT
WE'VE ASKED THEM TO DO. TO REACH
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS I'LL
SPARE YOU THE DETAILS I'VE BEEN
MEETING WITH MISTER MARTIN
SEVERAL TIMES BUT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR INCREASED FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA --
PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE HOURS
FUNDING AS WELL AS A FULL TIME --
HIGHER FACULTY HIRING OF FUNDING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIR --
MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO KERN PERALTA IN SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET --
BASICALLY COLA GROWTH AN
EXTENSION OF THE PROMISE PROGRAM
WE SUPPORT THOSE --
AND RECOGNIZE THE LIMITS ON PROP
NINETY EIGHT THIS YEAR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET
PROCESS.
WE SUPPORT THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FINANCIAL AID PROPOSAL
LOOK FOR TO YOURS AND WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT.
THE ONE THING I DID WANT TO
MENTION --
AND REQUEST THIS COMMITTEE FIFTY
ONE FACILITIES --
THERE ARE NUMBER THAT WEREN'T
FUNDED NOT ONLY NEW PROJECTS BUT
CONTINUING PROJECTS PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED AND THEN
HAVE BEEN STOPPED --
SO WE WOULD URGE YOU TO LOOK AT
THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT AS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU I'M FOR
YOUR TIME COMMITTEE ALEXIS
BERRIES AND STUDENT ADVOCATE --
REALLY BRIEF I STARTED OFF
COLLEGE AS A COLLEGE STUDENT --
AND DURING MY TRANSITION OUT OF
FOSTER CARE I BECAME HOMELESS --
I WAS EMPLOYED FULL TIME AT THE
TIME -- BUT
BECAUSE OF MY AGE AND THE LACK
OF CREDIT I COULD NOT FIND
HOUSING ANYWHERE --
THIS LET ME TO SLEEPING IN MY
CAR WAKING UP PERIODICALLY TO
MOVE LOCATIONS --
FOR MY SAFETY--
AND WITH ALL THOSE THINGS GOING
ON THERE'S NO WAY THAT I COULD
REALLY MAINTAIN MY COLLEGE
STUDIES WHICH LED ME TO
EVENTUALLY DROPPING OUT --
FAST FORWARD SIX YEARS I'M BACK
IN COLLEGE BUT HAD I NOT
EXPERIENCED THE HOMELESSNESS
DURING THAT TIME I COULD HAVE
OBTAINED MY DEGREE A LOT MORE
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY --
SO WITH THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
MRS EFFORTS IN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
GOOD EVENING MARIO GUERRERO WITH
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MCCARTY I WE
DO HAVE TO PROPOSALS ONE ON
ENROLLMENT ONE ON MENTAL HEALTH
AND ONE ON TENURE TRACK FACULTY
OR STAFF HAS THOSE PROPOSALS.
TODAY I WANTED TO COVER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON FUNNY 2%
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WITH SIXTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET --
WE ASK THAT THE GROWTH BE
MEASURED BY HEAD COUNT INSTEAD
OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS --
THE REASON WE ASK THAT IS A
COUPLE THINGS --
ONE REGULARLY WERE TURNING AWAY
THIRTY THOUSAND QUALIFIED
STUDENTS FROM THE CSU --
USING FTP CALCULATIONS ALONE
WHICH ARE BASED ON HOW MANY
UNITS ARE CLASSES STUDENTS TAKE
THE CS YOU CAN ENROLL I CAN USE
ENROLLMENT FUNDS TO GET CURRENT
STUDENTS TO TAKE MORE CLASSES
INSTEAD OF GIVING NEW STUDENTS
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE TURNED
AWAY.
A SEAT AT THE CSU I WHICH IS
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE CSU IS DOING
WITH THE FUNDS FROM THIS PAST
YEAR.
ALL OF THAT IS GOOD AND THEY CAN
FUND THAT WITH OTHER WITH OTHER
FUNDING BUT WE BELIEVE
ENROLLMENT IS NOT THE FUNDING TO
USE -- WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS INTENT WHEN YOU
FIND ENROLLMENT YOUR FUNDING
ACCESS SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON ON THAT POINT
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MCCARTY AND
CHECK PRINTER WITH THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY I THINK
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS YOU
REALLY --
HIT ON BOTH THE THE PROMISE THAT
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL HAS THERE'S
A IF THERE IS A LOT TO LIKE BUT
ALSO REALLY THE NEED TO CONTINUE --
EXPANDING ACCESS BUT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AS WAS REFERENCE TO THIRTY
THOUSAND ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WERE
BEING DENIED ANNUALLY BUT ALSO
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
WE RELEASED A STATE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR BLACK CALIFORNIANS
REPORT JUST LAST MONTH THAT
SHOWED IN THAT THE RECENT BUDGET
YEARS INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND
ACCESS --
BLACK IN LATIN NEXT STUDENTS SAW
INCREASES IN ENROLLMENT AND
ADMISSIONS THAT WERE ABOVE THE
OVERALL INCREASE SO IT'S BOTH --
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IMPERATIVE
TO MEET IN TERMS OF DIVERSIFYING
THE UNIVERSITY AND REALLY A
PROVIDING THAT SOCIAL MOBILITY
OPPORTUNITY TO SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS I'D ALSO JUST LIKE
TO SHARE LETTER WE PROVIDED
PREVIOUSLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION.
OUTLINING SOME OF OUR PRIORITIES
AND REQUEST FOR THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HI GOOD EVENING A CHAIR MCCARTY
I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
REALLY LOOKING AT A FINANCIAL
AID REFORM TO MEET SOME OF THEIR
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY MANY OF OF OUR
SPEAKERS ON THERE IS A NEED IN
ORDER TO I HAD. TO REALLY CLOSE
THOSE GAPS --
WE WANT TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND ON
THE COLA AND SOME OF THE
AUGMENTATIONS ARE PROVIDED BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE
ABSENCES WITHIN THE FORMULA --
NAMELY ABSENCE OF INSTRUCTIONAL
QUITMAN AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND THAT THOSE OF NOT INCLUDING
THOSE ELEMENTS IN THE BUDGET
REALLY AT THREATENS OUR ABILITY
TO OFFER A SAFE CLEAN CAMPUSES
THAT ADEQUATE NEED.
ME TO WHAT STUDENTS NEED TO
LEARN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE ON ALL THE YEARS THAT YOU'VE
SUPPORTED FUNDING ALL CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU'LL DO THAT AGAIN THIS YEAR.
ACOSTA ESCALATION LOCALLY OR
INCREASING ANYWHERE FROM 223%
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
KNOW THAT VOTERS HAVE SUPPORTED
THESE PROJECTS AND WE HOPE THAT
ULTIMATELY WE RELEASE THEM SENSE
THAT IS WHAT THEY'VE ASKED US TO
DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JAMIE CONNECTICUT I'M A FOURTH
YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR AT
UCLA WHERE I SERVE AS
UNDERGRADUATE EXCEL VICE
PRESIDENT AND A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE UC SOON ASSOCIATION.
I AM HERE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PRIORITIES WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE INVESTMENT THAT
WE'VE SEEN ESPECIALLY RELATED TO
BASIC NEEDS AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES.
I AM EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT THIS
COMMITTEES PRIORITIZATION OF
FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH
AND I'M ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT YOU
SEE IS BUDGET ASK BECAUSE THIS
PROPOSAL WAS STRONGLY MADE IN
COLLABORATION WITH STUDENT
LEADERS.
ABOUT OUR NEEDS.
IN REGARDS THE CONVERSATION WITH
IN ROME INCREASES STUDENTS WILL
THIS IMPACT VERY DIRECTLY --
THROUGH OVERCROWDED CLASSES AND
SEVERELY LOW SUPPLY OF STUDENT
HOUSING WE HAVE USED CLASS SIZES
I MEAN IMPACTED MAJOR AND UNTIL
THIS QUARTER I HAVE NEVER BEEN
IN A CLASS THAT SPENDS MORE THAN
A HUNDRED PEOPLE --
IT BRING MORE FACULTY IS CRUCIAL
TO ADDRESSING THIS WHICH IS PART
OF UC'S ASK OF NINETY FIVE
MILLION FOR ONGOING
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMMING
SUPPORT --
ALSO I AM IN IN STATE STUDENT
AND I DO NOT SUPPORT CONSTANTLY
RAISING FEES ON ON RESIDENTS --
I LET YOU SEE STATEWIDE VOTE
COALITION AND WE INCREASE VOTER
TURNOUT EXPONENTIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ENCOURAGE ALL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS INCLUDING OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS. TO REGISTER
WITH A SCHOOL ADDRESS OF THE
STUDENTS ARE YOUR CONSTITUENTS --
TO I ALSO HAVE A LETTER ON
BEHALF OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN REGARDS TO THE
NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT CAP.
HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME'S A
BOTTLE BUT AS I'M A SOPHOMORE AT
UCLA STARTING PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND
LABOR AND WORKPLACE STUDIES.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ON THE PENDING
FINANCIAL ME ACROSS THE UC
SYSTEM.
AS A FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARRIVING
AT MY UNIVERSITY A HAS BECOME
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT.
INCREASING FUNDING TOWARDS BASIC
NEEDS RESOURCES AND THEIR
ABILITY TO SUCCEED ACADEMICALLY.
AN ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL ALSO HELP CLOSE
THEIR GRADUATION GOT FOR UNDER
PRESIDENT UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS SUCH AS MYSELF.
ADDITIONALLY I AM HOPEFUL THAT
GREATER SUPPORT FOR IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICES IT WOULD RESULT
IN INCREASED EMOTIONAL AND
FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS SUCH AS
MYSELF THE CONSTANTLY WORRY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL
BE DEPORTED BEFORE THEY CAN
FINISH THEIR DEGREE.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE HOPE
THAT YOU HOPE TO HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT DO NOT FORGET THAT WE
COULD NOT HAVE.
AFFORDED WE CANNOT HAVE
DIVERSITY WITHOUT AFFORDABILITY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHEN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS A NURSING
HOME AND I'M A STUDENT UCLA AND
ON THE BOARD OF THE HOUSTON
ASSOCIATION.
LAST YEAR YOU SEE STUDENTS RALLY
TO BLOCK A PROPOSED TUITION HIKE
BY WORKING WITH YOU IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AS PARTNERS. TO
INVEST IN A TUITION BUYOUT WITH
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE --
IT MOVED FORWARD AS AN ONGOING --
TUITION BUYOUT BUT WHEN IT BY
THE TIME THEY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK IT WAS A ONE TIME TUITION
BUYOUT.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL ONE EIGHTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION ONGOING TUITION BY
OUT AND ENROLLMENT GROWTH
ALLOCATION THAT THE UC BROUGHT
TO US -- BUT
TO YOU TODAY IT WAS CREATED IN
COLLABORATION WITH US THE
STUDENTS AND WE SUPPORT THAT.
BUT WHAT WE URGE YOU TO BE WARY
OF IS THIS CONTINUING MOVEMENT
OF COST ON TO THE BACKS OF OUR
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS.
PAYING FOR MY TUITION TO STAY
FLAT OFF THE BACKS OF MY AND
CALIFORNIA FIRST CALIFORNIA
FIRST FOR STUDENTS SOUNDS A LOT
LIKE AMERICA FIRST TO BE HONEST.
PLEASE GIVE US THE SECURITY OF
STUDENTS ALL STUDENTS NON
RESIDENTS AND RESIDENTS ALIKE TO
KNOW THAT WE WILL NOT BE FACING
INCREASED TUITION IN THE COMING
YEARS BY SUPPORTING THIS ONE
EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION BY
THE UC AND BY STUDENTS. TO
CREATE --
INCREASE TUITION I'M SORRY IT'S
A IT'S A FURTHER FUNDS THAT
TUITION ROLE BY US OUR TUITION
BUYOUT FROM LAST YEAR.
AND FULLY FUND THE INCREASE
ENROLLMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PROVIDED THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS RICHARD
SOUTHWOOD A TRANSFER STUDENT SEX
STATE.
SO -- I
STARTED OUT AS A FOSTER YOUTH
AND END UP HOMELESS AND I TURN.
EIGHTEEN TRYING TO GO TO FAX
CITY INTO MY THING AND SO IT
WOULD MEAN A LOT EASIER IF I
WOULD HAVE A LIKE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SUPPORT UNTIL I GOT A JOB.
AND THEN THE SO NAM INSECTS THEY
ENDS.
RIGHT NOW I KNOW A LOT OF OTHER
STUDENTS THAT SLEEP IN THEIR CAR
YOU GO TO THE WELL. TO SHOWER
AND EAT AND STUFF LIKE THAT SO
AND THAT IT DOES REALLY MATTER
TO SUPPORT THAT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR BILL BY.
SENATOR GABRIEL THANKS.
LARGER MEMBERS MY NAME IS EDDIE
AYE GARMENTS STUDENT SUCCESS
PARTIAL SUB YOU COLLEGE.
I AM SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL'S REQUEST FOR TWENTY
MINUTES TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
I LIKE TO SHARE PERSONAL ACCOUNT
OF COLLEGE FRIEND FROM --
CALLING WHO WAS GRACIOUS ENOUGH
TO ALLOW ME TO SHARE HIS
EXPERIENCE HERE WITH YOU TODAY --
WHEN ALEX COULD NOT SECURE A
COUCH OR A ROOF OVER HIS HEAD HE
WOULD SLEEP UNDER A BRIDGE?
ALEX WOULD SNEAK INTO A FITNESS
GYMS AND SHOWER AND GROOM
HIMSELF --
ALEX SPENT MUCH AS MUCH TIME AS
POSSIBLE.
THE COLLEGE CAMPUSES TRY TO DO
IS WORK OR AT LEAST AS MUCH AS
HE COULD --
BEFORE HE WAS KICKED OUT BECAUSE
HE KNEW THAT THE CURRENT
SITUATION HE WAS IN WAS NOT
CONDUCIVE TO HIS --
TO STUDY --
DUE TO THE LACK OF HOUSING IT
TOOK ALEX --
SIX YEARS TO COMPLETE AN A A
DEGREE IN BUSINESS MANAGEMENT.
ALEX HAD THE ASSISTANCE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS HE MAY HAVE
COMPLETED IS EDUCATIONAL
ASPIRATIONS A LOT SOONER. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS I SUPPORT THE
REQUEST FOR FUNDING TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WAS
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION --
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ANNA SPECIALLY
THE AUGMENTATION OF THE CSU WE
SUPPORT THE 2% ENROLLMENT GROWTH
THE ECHOING THE COMMENTS MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OF CFA WE'D
LIKE TO SEE IT BE ACTUAL HEAD
COUNT -- TO
PROVIDE PREVENT MANIPULATION
MORE STUDENTS ACCESS WE ALSO --
WE ASK THAT THE TENURE TRACK BE
EXPANDED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
ONGOING AND THAT --
I WANNA HIGHLY RCS YOU YOU WHICH
ARE SUPPORT STAFF THAT THEY NOT
COST SAVINGS NOT BE BORN THE
BACK OF WORKERS AND WE ADDRESSES
INVERSION GAP FROM THE STEPS
BEING REMOVED FROM SUPPORT STAFF
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE HAVE
MEMBERS THAT ARE MAKING LESS OR
THE SAME AS WORKERS.
AT START DAY ONE AND IT'S A REAL
MORALE ISSUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS GERRIT COLE
HOMA STUDENTS IF THIS GOES STATE
UNIVERSITY IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
I'M A NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS
RETURN TO MY EDUCATION AFTER AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ADDICTION AND
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN I THOUGHT
MY LIFE HAD NO VALUE.
IT'S SAD THAT IT TOOK LOSING
ALMOST EVERYTHING TO BRING ME TO
A PLACE WHERE I CAN REALLY
ADVANCE MY EDUCATION. NINE
GRADUATING PERCENT DISCO STATE
WITH A BACHELORS IN
COMMUNICATIONS AND A MINOR IN
GLOBAL GLOBAL PEACE HUMAN RIGHTS
AND JUSTICE.
MY EDUCATION DOESN'T JUST
BENEFIT ME I AM PROUD OF
RESEARCH I'VE BEEN ABLE TO DOING
A CONCEPT CALLED SEXUAL
GENTRIFICATION.
WHICH RESEARCHERS THAT RACISM
WITHIN SEXUAL ATTRACTIONS THAT
RESHAPE THE RACIAL MAKEUP OF
COMMUNITIES.
ALSO THE STUDENTS AT THE CSU
BENEFIT FROM MY STUDENT
LEADERSHIP.
AS I SERVANTS CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
INVESTMENT STUDENTS IS MORE
ABOUT DOLLARS IT'S ABOUT
INVESTING IN HUMAN POTENTIAL
THAT WILL DRIVE THE FUTURE
PROSPERITY AND ABUNDANCE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS A LARA
FOX IMMIGRANTS DO NOT VIEW
COLLEGE I AM HERE TO SUPPORT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS.
EARLY ON IN MY COLLEGE JOURNEY I
WAS FACED WITH HOMELESSNESS AND
HAD TO ALMOST DROP OUT I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO QUALIFY FOR A
NON RELATED PROGRAM OFF CAMPUS.
THROUGH YOUTH FOR CHANGE THAT
PUT ME IN A HOUSE BUT I KNOW
PLENTY OF STUDENTS PERSONALLY
WHO ARE STILL ON THE STREET.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A HOME
AND THEY'VE GIVEN UP ON THEIR
EDUCATION --
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS TERRA
BOOKER I'M HERE FROM YOU CALL IS
TO SUPPORT US IMPLEMENT
ASSEMBLYMAN GAVE ROSE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR BILL.
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS IN COLLEGE STUDENTS
I PERSONALLY FELT THE EFFECTS OF
BEING HOMELESS AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT.
WHICH DUE TO THE LACK OF
STABILITY LED TO ME DROPPING OUT
AND LATER TURNING TO DRUGS WHICH
TURNED MY LIFE UPSIDE DOWN --
CONSIDERABLY.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT WITH
ASSISTANCE FROM MY FAMILY AND
TOUGH LESSONS OF GROWTH THAT I
TO LEARN ON MY OWN.
I NOW CURRENTLY I'M IN A STABLE
LIVING SITUATION IN BACK IN
COLLEGE WORKING TOWARDS MY GOALS.
HOWEVER THERE IS A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE
THE LUXURY OF FAMILIES ARE
PEOPLE IN THEIR LIFE THAT OUR
CABLE HELPING THEM GET ON THEIR
FEET. TO ACHIEVE THE LEVEL OF
STABILITY THE COLLEGE LIFE
REQUIRES.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD
BENEFIT THESE PEOPLE THE MOST
AND HAVE A LASTING IMPACT.
I ENCOURAGE THE PASSING OF THIS
BILL GET LEFT BEHIND.
THANK YOU.
HI THERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND LISTENING I'M ALSO HEE IN
SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL IN SUPPORT OF
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
I WORK IN A SUPPORT PROGRAM FOR
BUTTE COLLEGE --
AND WE SEE MANY MANY STUDENTS
IMPACTED --
THERE IT EDUCATION IMPACTED BY
HOMELESSNESS --
IT'S A STATEWIDE ISSUE --
LOCALLY BEING A PART OF THE
CAMPFIRE AREA WE'RE SEEING YOU
KNOW LARGE LARGE NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS I KNOW IT'S A STATEWIDE
EFFORT.
BUT I THINK WHEN YOU DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE ISN'T GOING AWAY.
AND I EXPRESSED TRONG SUPPORT OF
A TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THAT AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL THANK YOU THANK
YOU I'LL TELL SOMEONE NUMBER
GALLAGHER THAT.
HE MISSED HIS CONSTITUENTS SO.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEAUTY SAID
RIGHT CRACK YEAH THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER MANLY AYE BURKE
REPRESENTING VOICES YOU CENTER
OF NAPA VALLEY AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO SUPPRT.
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST BY ASSEMBLYMAN GABRIEL
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY FOUR I
ENROLLED IN COMMITTEE COLLEGE TO
ATTEND CLASSES.
AT THE TIME I WAS HOMELESS AND
LIVING IN EMERGENCY SHELTER AS I
STRUGGLE TO PRODUCES PURSUE BOTH
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AM I
HIGHER EDUCATION I WAS FORCED TO
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT WHICH
WOULD BENEFIT ME MORE IN THE
LONG. ONE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN WORK
AND SCHOOL AS A HARDSHIP MANY
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH ARE
OBLIGATED TO ACCEPT IN THE HOPES
FOR A COMFORTABLE LIFE.
I FOUND MYSELF IN THE CYCLE
FAILURE ONE YEAR LATER I AM
STILL LIVING IN THE SHELTER WILD
ATTEMPTING TO CONTINUE SCHOOL
WHILE I CAN.
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA CAN ONLY
GUARANTEE AND DECENT STUDIO
APARTMENT LET ALONE PROVIDE
ENOUGH FINANCIAL SECURITY IN
ORDER FOR US TO CONTINUE TO GROW.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB FIVE
SIX EIGHT SO ALL OF US CAN HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FEASIBLY
OBTAIN A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
THANK [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREAS CAN
TURN THE PROGRAM MANAGER OF
VOICES NAPA YOU CENTER AS WELL
AS I'M ONE I'LL BE CASE MANAGERS
WORKING WITH THEIR FOSTER YOUTH
AND OPERATION NEWS --
I IN HERE TO REPRESENT THEM THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR QUEST FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL --
I WORKED WITH A WIDE VARIETY OF
YOUTH RANGING FROM FOSTER CARE
TO PROBATION YOU IS TO JUST
NORMAL YOU TO A FONG HARDSHIP.
AND HOW WE SO OFTEN WE PUSH
EDUCATION ON THEM AS A AS A
ANOTHER STEP FORWARD TOWARDS OUR
FUTURE BUT IF WE'RE NOT THERE TO
BUILD SURVIVE PROVIDE A STABLE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM.
HOW WE EXPECTING THEM TO REALLY
SUCCEED WALT JUST TRYING TO ME
ONE OF LIFE'S MANY REQUIREMENTS
I NEVER EXPRESSING THIS SO MUCH
ARE THEN WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT MORE
OPPORTUNITY IN TERMS OF?
MAKING SCHOOL IN EDUCATION THEIR
TOP PRIORITY RATHER THAN LOOKING
WAY FOR A PLACE TO SLEEP FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL NIGHT LET ALONE A
SEMESTER --
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR TIME WE
APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS COLONEL
TO SIGN A SECOND YEAR STUDENT
STUDYING ECONOMICS AT UC
BERKELEY I'M ALSO AN OUT OF
STATE STUDENT I WANTED TO
EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION TO THE NON
RESIDENT AND ROAMING UP.
DO YOU SHE SHOULD BE A WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT TO ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY CAME
FROM REGARDS 210% CAP WE ARE NOT
PROGRESSING AS YOU SEE WE WERE
REGRESSING.
BECAUSE A MYRIAD OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ATTEND THE UC'S CRUCIAL FOR
DIVERSITY.
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS CONTRIBUTE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS FINANCIAL AID
AND EVERY NON RESIDENT PAYS
THREE TIMES A TUITION ABOUT A
RESIDENT CALIFORNIA PAYS.
OUR TUITION SPORTS FINANCIALLY
TO ASSIST RESIDENTS STUDENTS.
WITHOUT THESE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
YOU SEE FINANCIALLY TO RECORDED
AS A SCAPEGOAT JUST BECAUSE I'M
NOT A RESIDENT OF THE STATE AND
I CANNOT AGREE MORE THAT WE
SHOULD EDUCATE ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CAPPING OF CAPPING.
OUT OF THE ROOM IS NOT THE
MATTER WHICH TO DO SO.
DO YOU SHE SAID NOT BE THE BEST
SYSTEM AND YOU SHOULD AND SHOULD
NOT BE THE A GOOD SYSTEM FOR ALL
STUDENTS AND IS TO BE THE BEST
SYSTEM.
THE SERVER SO MUCH FREE TIME
THANK YOU ARE YOU WITH US STATES
DIDN'T.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS PUBLIC
TRONG WHERE I'M A SENIOR AT UC
BERKELEY.
I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
UC BERKELEY ACC PRESIDENT
ALEXANDER WILL FOR WHO STRONGLY
URGES AGAINST THE UC NON
RESIDENT TUITION INCREASE.
AS A LOW INCOME STUDENT I'M
DISAPPOINTED IN THE TREND OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THE RELIANCE ON STUDENT TUITION
FOR FUNDING IS A DETERRENT
REGARDLESS OF RESIDENCY FOCUSING
ON GRADUATION RATES IS NECESSARY
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
EMPHASIS ON THE EXPERIENCES OF
STUDENTS TO THEIR GRADUATION
PATH.
WHETHER IT'S CONSULATE GOING TO
LECTURE ON AN EMPTY STOMACH NOT
HAVING PERMANENT HOUSING WE'RE
STRUGGLING WITH ACADEMICALLY
ASSOCIATED MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OF STATE
WHICH NECESSARY.
WHICH NECESSITATES MORE FUNDING
FOR STUDENT AID REDUCING TUITION
AND WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SOLVE THE STATE
WIDE HOUSING COSTS CRISIS.
WHAT IS ONCE AGAIN SERVE AS THE
BEACON FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME?
GOOD EVENING BARBARA GLAZER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BUDGET.
FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
THIS WILL ALLOW THE PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX FUNDS TO SUPPORT
INCREASED GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION SLOTS AND THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
DOLLARS FROM THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED AND WILL FUND ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX RESIDENCY
SLOTS FOR PRIMARY CARE AND
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT MEDICINE.
IN WE HOPE THAT THIS CONTINUES
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MEAL SWEENEY VICE
PRESIDENT OF UAW LOCAL FIFTY
EIGHT TEN ARE YOU NAY REPRESENTS
ABOUT.
THIRTY THOUSAND ACADEMIC
EMPLOYEES AT YOU SEE IN ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND IT'S THE ISSUE.
I COME HERE FOR TWO THINGS ONE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S INCREASES WERE HIGHER
AND FUNDING BUT ALSO TO FLAG FOR
THE COMMITTEE THAT THEY SHOULD
KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON SPENDING
DECISIONS ESPECIALLY BY THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AT THE
UC.
IN SEPTEMBER A SUPER MAJORITY OF
WORKERS STUDYING AUTHORIZATION
CARDS -- OF
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS TO FORM A
NEW UNION.
SINCE THEN THE OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT HAS APPROVED OUTSIDE
LEGAL COUNSEL THAT HAS BEEN
DENYING AND DELAYING THEIR
DEMOCRATIC CHOICE TO FORM A
UNION.
AND SINCE THEN --
THEY'VE NOT RECOGNIZE THE UNIT
OR SIT DOWN AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE WE DEFINITELY SUPPORTS --
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING BUT IT
SHOULD NOT BE USED THERE COULD
BE MANY OTHER BETTER USES LIKE
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND NOT TO DO
NINE DELAY THE DEMOCRATIC CHOICE
BY WORKERS THANKS.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS KAREN
SONG AND I'M A SOPHOMORE AT UC
BERKELEY.
I CURRENTLY WORK WITH THE ACC
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN PRE
HEALTH COMMUNITY I'VE SEEN FIRST
HAND FROM FRIENDS AND OTHER
PEERS THE INACCESSIBILITY OF
UNIVERSITY HEALTH SERVICES.
THIS CAN BE SEEN THROUGH THE
LACK OF RESOURCES MEN'S AND LONG
WAIT TIMES.
AS A RESULT MANY STUDENTS
INCLUDING SEVERAL FRIENDS OF
MINE HAVE TAKEN A LEAVE OF
ABSENCE TO ADDRESS THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH. FOR THAT REASON IT IS
IMPERATIVE FOR THE STATE TO
INVESTING KEY SERVICES LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES THAT
WILL PRIORITIZE A STUDENTS WELL
BEING AND FOSTER ACADEMIC
SUCCESS.
I ASKED THE COMMITTEE TO FULLY
FUND THE UC SO THAT SERVICES
LIKE MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES AND
OTHER VARIOUS RESOURCES WILL BE
GUARANTEED FOR STUDENTS THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NEIL MCCLINTIC I'M
A TRANSFER STUDENT UC BERKELEY
AND SET TO GRADUATE IN JUST A
COUPLE OF MONTHS --
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO NOT LOOK AT THEIR
PHONES WHILE IN SPEAKING --
I'VE BEEN HERE MANY MANY HOURS
TRAVEL HOURS TO GET HERE AND
IT'S PRETTY RUDE TO US --
LIKE I SAID I'M SET TO GRADUATE
BUT I'VE BEEN COMING HERE FOR
THREE YEARS FIRST THEY CAME IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
NOW I'M COMING AS A UC STUDENT.
SPENDING ON HIGHER EDUCATION
ISN'T JUST ABOUT PUMPING OUT
DEGREES FASTER AND FASTER AND
FASTER AND IT'S FRANKLY VERY
FRUSTRATING TO HEAR THAT KIND OF
RHETORIC AROUND HERE.
WHEN IT'S REALLY ABOUT ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY IS
THRIVING HAVING A GREAT TIME AND
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD TO GO THERE?
OVER HERE WE HAD THE WE HAD THE
SORRY --
EARLIER I HEARD RHETORIC ABOUT
HOW -- I
HEARD RHETORIC ABOUT HOW IT'S
ABOUT STUDENTS WHO.
ARE WEALTHY AND WHO ARE NOT
WALTHY BUT IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE
AS THAT IT'S NOT THE SITUATION
ACTUALLY IS ON THE GROUND.
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS ARE PAYING
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TUITION ONE NOT PROTECTED FROM
RETURNED AID JUST BECAUSE OF AN
AVERSION TO STUDENTS WHO WERE
PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO LIVE HERE.
BASIN RHETORIC THAT IS NEARLY
TRUMP IAN AND ITS HATRED PRADA
STATE STUDENTS AND I SAY THIS IS
AN IN STATE STUDENT.
PLEASE STOP PLAYING HOPPER TAITO
DEFERRING THIS EXISTENTIAL
CRISIS TO USE YOUR P. OR THE
REGION'S.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL DEFLECT BY
BLAMING YOU SEE A P. ON BAD
FINANCES ALL THE WHILE YOU SEE
IS NOW ACTING IN GOOD FAITH.
CUTTING BUDGETS FLASHING
ADMINISTRATION.
THE UC TOOK A BILLION DOLLAR
BLOW DURING THE RECESSION IS AND
IS RECEIVING JUST 51% OF IT USED
TO PER STUDENT DO NOT RELY ON TO
SCREEN OVER NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS BECAUSE THIS INCLUDE
NON WEALTHY OUT OF STATE.
AND NINE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AS WELL
AND ALSO POTENTIAL CAP OF 10% ON
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS MEANS THAT
ALL STUDENTS WILL JUST HAVE TO
PAY MORE TO MAKE UP FOR THE
DIFFERENCE.
SO IT'S BAD POLICY THANK YOU THE
WAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SURE BUT ALSO AS SOMEONE WHO
CAME HERE AND TOOK HOURS.
THE SAID HERE THANK YOU OKAY.
GOOD EVENING ALEX GRAVES WITH
THE ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING EIGHTY
THREE OF THE INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE --
THERE WAS SOME CONVERSATION
TODAY AROUND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CAL GRANT
DOLLARS TO STUDENT PARENTS --
COLLECTIVELY OUR INSTITUTION
RULES ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED CAL
GRANT STUDENT PARENTS AND SHOULD
THAT PROPOSAL MOVE FORWARD --
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE --
TO ENSURE THAT STUDENT PARENTS
ATTENDING OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
SUPPLEMENTAL AID --
UNDER THE PROPOSAL THEY ARE NOT --
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STUDENTS
SHOULD BE TREATED EQUITABLY AND
THAT THEY FACE SIMILAR
CHALLENGES IN COMPLETING THEIR
DEGREE AS THEIR COUNTERPARTS
ATTENDING OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS THANKS.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEE SAID DORIS
I AM A THIRTY YEAR POLITICAL
SCIENCE STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MERCED.
I'M ALSO AND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT -- I
THINK THAT THE BIGGEST THING
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE
CONVERSATION IS THE A BIG NOREEN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS NOT AB
FIVE FORTY UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
IN THE RHETORIC OF NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS --
IT'S MORE OUT OF STATE STUDENTS
THEN UNDOCUMENTED NON AB FIVE
FORTY QUALIFYING STUDENTS.
AND SO WITH THE TUITION INCREASE
AT TARGETS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO ARE NOT FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
QUALIFY FOR AB.
FIVE FORTY I DON'T THINK THAT
PAYING NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS
EXTRA A YEAR --
IS MUCH TOO MUCH OF A BURDEN ON
WEALTHIER FAMILIES AND IT IS TO
A LOWER INCOME UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY YOU
MENTIONED THAT A 5% TUITION
INCREASE WOULD BE BEST BUT WITH
LAST YEAR'S TWO POINT 5%
INCREASE IN THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
TWO POINT SIX INCREASE THAT'S
ALREADY A 5% INCREASE WITHIN THE
PAST TWO YEARS --
I WILL FIRSTHAND LET YOU ALL
KNOW THAT A DEGREE DOES NOT
EQUATE A BETTER LIFE IF I HOPE
THAT YOU DEFINE A SUSTAINABLE
LIFE.
AS A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT I
HAD NO IDEA WHAT UNIVERSITY IS
MEANT TO TRULY OFFER ME.
MY TUITION INCREASES THE TRADE
OFF OF IN STATE TUITION
REMAINING FLAT --
I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR NON
RESIDENTS TO STUDENT TUITION
INCREASE THIS PRE ACT PREVIOUS
ACADEMIC YEAR BY NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
THE QUAKE EQUITY GAP EXTENT
EXTENDS TO MORE THAN THE
SYMBOLISM OF A DEGREE --
LOOK AT THE EXPERIENCE AFTER THE
DEGREES ATTAIN MORE SO THAN JUST
THE ATTAINING OF A DEGREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ARE YOU NON RESIDENT STUDENTS
I'M UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AND WE
FALL UNDER THE NON RESIDENT
TUITION FEE --
I WON I QUALIFY FOR AB FIVE
FORTY IT'S WAIVED YES BUT DON'T
YOU QUALIFY FOR THE AB FIVE
FORTY AND AND AND EXCLUDE NON
RESIDENT.
YES BUT IF I WAS TO NOT QUALIFY
FOR AB FIVE FORTY I WOULD STILL
BE CHARGED THAT BUT AMONG THE
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS A LOT OF
US DO FALL UNDER THAT.
AND I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE BE HERE IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SARAH TO SHINE
I'M A STUDENT UC BERKELEY AND I
ALSO SERVICE THE FUN THE UC
CHAIR FOR THE UC SINICIZATION --
WHILE I HAVE A LOT TO SAY ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND HOW
HAPPY OR FOR A NEW FOCUS ON
BASIC NEED SECURITY MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND IMMIGRATION SERVICES I
REALLY NEED TO TAKE THIS TIME TO
RE CENTER ARE NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS ONCE AGAIN WHO HAVE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN BEEN A RACE
FROM THE UC STERN NARRATIVE --
THE UC STERN ASSOCIATION IS
UNEQUIVOCALLY OPPOSED TO PLACING
A CAP ON ON REGINALD ENROLLMENT
AND WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO
CONTINUING TO INCREASE THEIR
TUITION.
BOTH OF THESE MEASURES WILL
DAMAGE THE UC STATUS AS A
NATIONAL GLOBAL LEADER IN HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HARM ALL YOU SEE
STUDENTS INCLUDING CALIFORNIANS --
LUCY WAS CREATED IN THE NAME OF
THAT AS A AS OPPOSED TO THE CAP
ON ON RESIDENT YES BUT THERE IS
A CAP.
WELL WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE 10%
CAP THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED.
I THINK THE LETTER TO SCOTT PASS
AROUND WE HAVE A PRESS RELEASE
THAT WAS RELEASED TODAY AS WELL --
BUT THE UC WAS CREATED IN THE
NAME OF ACCESSIBILITY
AFFORDABILITY --
BUT I REALLY DON'T SEE THAT WHEN
WE CONTINUE TO PUSH FOLKS OUT OF
THIS INSTITUTION JUST BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
LIVING WITH AN ARBITRARY BORDER
OR HAVING THE RIGHT KIND OF
DOCUMENTATION --
I PERSONALLY YOU BARELY MADE THE
CUT TO BE A RESIDENT STUDENT I
GREW UP IN ENGLAND AND I COULD
HAVE VERY EASILY BEEN ON
RESIDENT STUDENT BUT I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH THAT MY PARENTS MOVED
QUICKLY ENOUGH --
I REALLY JUST I'M ASKING YOU TO
STOP BUILDING A WALL AROUND THE
UC -- PLEASE
RECONSIDER THE PROPOSED CHANGES
IN NON RESIDENT ROMAN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ARIANNA
TELEPHONE TEN I'M A SOPHOMORE
EAT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY I'M HERE
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO FUND THE
BUDGET ASK OF THE UC AND NOT TO
FUNDED THROUGH OUT OF STATE
TUITION INCREASES OR ENROLLMENT
CAPS.
IF THE STATE WANTS TO INCREASING
CONTINUE WITH ENROLLMENT GROWTH
THERE MUST BE THE FUNDING TO
OFFSET THE COST OF ENROLLMENT
GROWTH WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE HAVE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED SEISMICALLY UNFIT
BUILDINGS AT UC BERKELEY.
THIS PAST SEMESTER IN THE FALL
WHEN I WAS IN ROLLING FOR CALL
LOSSES.
IN OFF THE WEIGHTLESS FOR ONLY
ONE I STARTED CLASSES THREE
WEEKLY AND WITH THE WORLD UNLESS
UNITS AND I HAD INTENDED.
THIS MADE MY SEMESTER MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TRUSTFUL THAN IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
THIS LACK OF SPACE
INFRASTRUCTURE NOT ONLY MEANS
CUTTING CLASSES BUT A LACK OF
SPACE FOR IMPORTANT STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
SPECIFIC RESOURCE CENTER IS LIKE
A LOT AND NEXT RESOURCE CENTER.
SOMETHING THAT CONTRIBUTES TO
THE RETENTION OF UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS RATHER THAN
JUST INCREASING THE NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS WILL NOT PROVIDING THE
SERVICES.
THE INCREASE FUNDING OF SOUP
STUDET INITIATED OUTREACH
PROGRAMS IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME OUR OUR SEIZE ON THE UC
BERKELEY CAMPUS SPECIFICALLY
ALLOWED ME TO OUTREACH TO
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WHO WOULD
NOT HAVE OTHERWISE ATTENDED
BERKELEY.
THE NUMBERS STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO ACCEPTED MISSIONS TO
BERKELEY'S LOW AND THANKS TO THE
R. C.'S MOST OF THEIR WORK BEING
ON PAID.
DOT MAKES A DIFFERENCE FOR
STUDENTS TO CHOOSE TO ATTEND THE
UC.
FUNDING SHOULD NOT BE RELIED ON
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS AGAIN I
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO FULLY FUND
THE UC SO THAT WE CAN SERVE THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED AT THE UC'S.
MAKE SURE STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING ON TIME OUR FOOD
SECURE HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES AND ARE NOT JUST
SURVIVING BUT THRIVING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
HELLO MY NAME IS IN CREAM
CURRENTLY A SECOND YEAR UC
RIVERSIDE BEFORE I BEGIN I JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE VARIOUS
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS WERE NOT
PRESENT IN THE ROOM AND HOWARD
HOW THEY ARE CONTINUES THE
EXPLOITED RATHER THAN THIS TO
SUSTAIN THROUGH BUDGET
PRIORITIES.
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
BUDGET WAS GENEROUS THERE IS
MUCH MORE YOU CAN DO IN TERMS OF
HOUSING AND FOOD INSECURITY ARE
YOU SEE OUR ARC --
CURRENTLY OUR CAMPUS WITH
SECURITIES AT SIXTY PUT SIXTY
TWO POINT 5% COMPARED TO THE 40% --
YOU SEE AVERAGE ALONG THE SYSTEM --
OVERALL I ALSO ASKED UNDERSERVED
CAMPUSES OF THE WORK THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO MAKE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ACCESSIBLE SPACE
FOR MARGINALIZED GROUPS.
ON AND FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DRIVE IN THINKING.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASIA --
I'M A THIRD YEAR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT A YOU YOU SEE ARE
CURRENTLY REPRESENT --
AS A SENATOR WHETHER --
WELL WE DO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S GENEROUS FUNDING IT
IS STILL NOT ENOUGH THAT YOU SEE
ARE SIX SIXTY TWO POINT FIVE
STUDENTS ARE FOOD INSECURE AT
OVER 10% ARE HOMELESS.
FOOD INSECURITY HOMELESSNESS
DISPOSED DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS COMPASSES LIKE YOU SEE
ARE AND YOU SEE MERCED WE NEED
THIS ONGOING FUNDING NEVER
SUSTAIN OURSELVES AND PROVIDE
OUR STUDENTS WITH.
ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS OTHER UC
CAMPUSES TESTIFYING SPEAKS
VOLUMES HOW CRUCIAL IT IS FOR US.
THANK YOU PROJECT.
HI I'M SAMANTHA WARREN AND I FOR
SURE UC BERKELEY AND I ACTUALLY
AM I LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I IT IS REASSURING.
I WENT TO MCCARTY YES IT IS
REASSURING TO HEAR THAT TUITIONS
FOR IN STATE STUDENTS WILL NOT
CHANGE NEXT YEAR.
BUT MONEY SHOULD NOT DICTATE
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES SOON HAS AND
I THINK THAT ALSO INCLUDES NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS.
AND I'M ASKING TO CONTINUE TO
FIND TUITION BIO SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN GO TO COLLEGE AND
NOT AND KNOW THAT THEIR TUITION
ISN'T GOING TO INCREASE ALL
THEIR ATTENDING WE SHOULD.
FUND YOU SEE FOR ALL BECAUSE
THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND
MAY EVEN IF YOU'RE AFTER COLLEGE
SO THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN ACT IS
STILL WELL I COME FROM UC MERCED
AND I JUST WANTED TO STATE.
THAT SHARING OUR IDENTITIES AND
POSITION SHOULD NOT BE A SHOULD
BE UP TO US AND NOT TO YOU AND
MAKING US FEEL PRESSURED INTO
SHARING.
LIKE OUR SITUATION --
WHEN YOU ASKED --
VERY STUDENTS IF THEY WERE --
NOT RESIDENTS I THINK THAT WAS
PRESSURE FROM YOU AS LEGISLATOR
AND KNOWING THAT WE'RE LIVE
STREAM YOU SHOULD BE ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS AND MCGUINNESS
FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY MY NAME
IS POSH ON I'D WORK WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION I HAVE GOOD
NEWS AND BAD NEWS GOOD NEWS IS
I'M THE ONLY LAST PERSON BEFORE
ALL OF YOU ALL GET TO GO HOME TO
OUR FAMILIES.
SO THEY'LL BE OVER SOON THAT
MEANS HE'S THERE ARE MANY
STUDENTS THAT DON'T HAVE THAT
LUXURY MANY OF FOLKS WHO ARE
HOMELESS ACROSS.
DO YOU SEE ONE OUT OF EVERY
TWENTY STUDENTS TO BE EXACT AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE ARE PROUD AS
YOU SEE IS A TO BE CO SPONSORING
LEGISLATION SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
THAT WOULD PROVIDE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO WAS RAPIDLY
HOUSING.
ACROSS THE UC AND CSU AND WE
WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND WHILE I'M HERE ALSO
I DO WANT.
TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY FOR YOUR AIRING OF
SUPPORT FOR ITS SUMMER CAL GRANT
SOMETHING THE BEATING FIGHTING
FOR A LONG TIME SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT HE
CONCLUDES NUMBER PARDEE COMMENTS
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY AND
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THERE WAS